OVERSIGHT HEARING OF THE SENATE
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES WILL
COME TO ORDER. IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES. WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND HERE'S SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE CAPITAL WITH SOME
OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. THE
FOLLOWING OF MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATOR
MELINDA IS VICE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE BUSINESS COMMITTEE ON
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. SENATOR BATES
CENTER BAKER CENTER EGGMAN
CENTER HER TADO CENTER JONES
CENTER LEYVA. SENATOR MEN
CENTER A CHOI BOGUE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FONG ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FLORA. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON. IN THE SENATE
CHAMBER WITH ME ARE CENTER PAN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOLLY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR AND
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING WHO
WILL BE PER PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. FOR OUR REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS JUST A REMINDER
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. I S. THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING.
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN. STATE YOUR NAME AND
THEN YOU ARE PREPARED AND READY
TO ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO HEARING ROOMS IN THE SENATE
GALLERY TO THE EXTENT THAT
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW. AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS EIGHT SIX ONE ZERO ONE
EIGHT FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TEAM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. OR
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING PUBLIC COMMENT
MAY BE PROVIDED ON THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING UPON
CONCLUSION OF QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES. WHEN
WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU
WILL BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR
THIS ONLY ONE TIME. AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
WILL BE A SHORT WAIT. HOPEFULLY
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR A MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME.
YOU WILL BE ON MUTED. AND YOU
ARE NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE AND AT THAT TIME
PLEASE PROCEED. EXPEDITIOUSLY
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AS I
NOTED BEFORE YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. OVER THE PHONE. IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE DURING THIS PROCESS.
IT'S MY JOB TO MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE CONNECTIONS
MUTED. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
HERE. THERE MAY BE SOME LAG%
TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS ARE TOWARD
TECHNOLOGIES AS ARE WE- PLEASE
BE RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS LIKE TODAY'S ALLOW FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF REGULATORY
PROGRAMS. AND TO DETERMINE
WHETHER CHANGES IN THE LAW. OR
IN THE PROGRAM OPERATIONS OR
FUNCTIONS. ARE NECESSARY OR
APPROPRIATE. WE WILL BE
REVIEWING SPECIFIC ISSUES
REGARDING THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING A PROGRAM
THAT PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN
ENSURING THE EFFECTIVE DELIVERY
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES BY
THOUSANDS OF PROFESSIONALS
AROUND THE STATE. TO MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
THE BOARD WILL PROVIDE A VERY
BRIEF REVIEW OF ITS FUNCTIONS
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES WILL
COMMITTEES WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO RAISE ANY OTHER
ISSUES OR QUESTIONS WHICH THEY
MAY HAVE DURING THIS HEARING WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
PARTICIPATION OF STAFF FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE WILL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF THE NUMEROUS RECENT AUDITS
REFLECTING BOARD ISSUES AND
OPERATIONS. WE WILL ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
CONSUMER GROUPS PROFESSIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS AND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR EACH PORTION OF
TODAY'S HEARING. AT THIS POINT
IN TIME I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TO MAKE
ANY OPENING REMARKS THAT HE
MADE HIS ARE TO MAKE. SURE LOW.
HELLO THANK YOU VERY MUCH CAROL
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION AHEAD OF US. THANK
YOU SIR BEFORE WE CAN BEGIN
WITH OUR SPEAKERS I WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE THOSE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO PARTICIPATE
TO CALL IN NOW PLEASE DIAL THIS
TOLL FREE NUMBER. 844-291-6364
AND WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE EIGHT SIX ONE
ZERO ONE. EIGHT FIVE. WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM MIKE TILL THEN
DEPUTY STATE AUDITOR ON THE
ISSUES BEFORE US TODAY WELCOME
MR UNTIL THE. GOOD MORNING
BERMAN. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MIGHT TELL THEM I'M
A DEPUTY STATE AUDITOR AND I'M
HERE TO DISCUSS THE RESULTS OF
TWO WATER EXCEPT INDUCTED ON
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AND
RELATED INVESTIGATION-
SPECIFICALLY I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE FIRST SITE THAT WE
DID ON THE BOARDS AND FORSMAN
FUNCTIONS IN A ROW. AND THE
NUMBERS MORE TIME TO ABOUT.
MORE REESE. BURKE AT ACTUALLY.
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THIS-
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS AND
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. FOR THE
FIRST AUDIT THAT WE RELEASED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN FOCUS ON
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
SEND FORSMAN FUNCTIONS AND THE
BOARD IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
ENFORCING THE NURSING PRACTICES
ACT AND REGULATING OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND NURSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT
INCLUDES INVESTIGATING
COMPLAINTS. AND THESE
COMPLAINTS AGAINST LICENSED
NURSES THEY RANGE FROM
COMPLAINTS RELATED TO
INCOMPETENCE OR NEGLIGENCE ALL
THE WAY TO CASES INVOLVING
GREAT BODILY INJURY- DEATH OR
ANY CRIME AGAINST A- CHILDREN
OR THE ELDERLY. SO IN THAT
REPORT THE KEY FINDINGS WERE
NUMBER ONE. YEAR AND REALLY
EXPERIENCED SIGNIFICANT DELAYS
IN PROCESSING THESE COMPLAINTS
AGAINST THEIR LICENSE NURSES
FOR EXAMPLE WE FOUND THAT THE
BOARD CONSISTENTLY FAILED TO
MEET THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS GOAL OF COMPLETING
THESE INVESTIGATIONS WITHIN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. I TO GIVE YOU
A FLAVOR FOR THAT WE REVIEWED
FORTY COMPLAINTS AND WE FOUND
THAT FOR THIRTY ONE OF THOSE
COMPLAINTS IT TOOK THE BOARD
LONGER THAN A HUNDRED OR EIGHT
I'M SORRY EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO
RESOLVE THE COMPLAINTS. IN FACT
FIFTEEN OF THOSE COMPLAINTS
ACTUALLY TOOK LONGER THAN THREE
YEARS FOR THE BOARD TO RESOLVE
SO SIGNIFICANT DELAYS. AND
THOSE DELAYS PRIMARILY OCCURRED
WE FOUND BECAUSE OF B. R. AND
INEFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT OVER ITS
OWN COMPLAINT RESOLUTION
PROCESS AND ITS FAILURE TO MOVE
THESE COMPLAINTS THROUGH THE
VARIOUS STAGES OF THE PROCESS
IN A TIMELY AND EFFICIENT
MANNER. AND ULTIMATELY THESE
DAYS THESE DELAYS CONTRIBUTED
TO A BACKLOG OF CASES AWAITING
ASSIGNMENT TO THE
INVESTIGATORS- BECAUSE FOR
EXAMPLE AT THE TIME OF THE
AUDIT IN JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY
WE IDENTIFIED A BACKLOG OF A
HUNDRED EIGHTY CASES. THEY HAD
NOT YET BEEN ASSIGNED TO AN
INVESTIGATOR AND SEVENTY OF
THOSE CASES. REALLY INVOLVED
COMPLAINTS THAT WERE DEEMED TO
BE URGENT ARE HIGH PRIORITY AND
THEY WERE OUTSTANDING AND
HADN'T BEEN ASSIGNED TO AN
INVESTIGATOR FOR AN AVERAGE OF
MORE THAN EIGHTY DAYS. WE MADE
NUMEROUS RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING TO
ADDRESS THOSE KEY FINDINGS AND
IMPROVE ITS COMPLAINT
RESOLUTION PROCESS. AND YOU
KNOW NEARLY FOUR YEARS LATER AT
THE BOARD HAS IMPLEMENTED
ALMOST ALL OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF OUR RECOMMENDATION
RELATED TO ITS BACKLOG AND
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT NEXT. SO WE RECOMMENDED
THAT BEER AND ESTABLISH A
PROCESS FOR RESOLVING THIS
BACKLOG OF CASES AND ASSIGNING
IT TO APPLICABLE INVESTIGATORS
AND IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TWO YEARS AFTER WE
COMPLETE THE REPORT. B. R. AND
ASSERTED TO US THAT THEY HAD
RESOLVED THIS PROBLEM THEY HAD
RESOLVED THIS BACKLOG OF
COMPLAINTS AND THEY ACTUALLY
SENT US A REPORTED OUR REQUEST
IN SUPPORT OF THAT. LAST FOUR
TWO YEARS LATER IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY WE RECEIVED A
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINT. THAT
ALLEGES THAT BEER AND THEY HAD
SUBMITTED THIS REPORT BUT IT
WAS FALSIFIED. IN OTHER WORDS
THAT THE ALLEGATION WAS THE
BEER AND HAD FALSIFIED THIS
REPORT WITH THE INTENT OF
CONVINCING US. THAT HAD REDUCED
ITS BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS WHEN
IN FACT IT HAD NOT. SO WE ARE
CONDUCTING A FORMAL
INVESTIGATION AND WE ACTUALLY
CONFIRM THAT BE ARE INDEED
FALSIFY THIS REPORT. AND
SPECIFICALLY WE FOUND THAT TWO
EXECUTIVES HAD DEVISED THE
PLAN. COULD MANIPULATE B. R.
ENDS DATA SAID TO BASICALLY
CONVINCE US THAT IT HAD CLEARED
THE BACKLOG IN THE WAY THAT THE
BOARD DID THIS. IS THEY WENT
INTO THEIR- CASELOAD SYSTEM AND
THEY REASSIGNED CASES TWO
DIFFERENT INVESTIGATORS SO THAT
NO ONE INVESTIGATOR HOW TO
CASELOAD OF MORE THAN TWENTY
CASES. AND THEY DID THAT IN
PART BY SIGNING INVESTIGATIONS
TO INVESTIGATORS THAT WERE ON
LEAVE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF
TIME AND WE'RE ACTUALLY WORKING
CASES. AND TO A MANAGER THAT
TYPICALLY DIDN'T REALLY WORK ON
CASES AT ALL. SO IN RELIANCE ON
THAT REPORTS WE CONCLUDED THAT
THIS IMPLEMENTATION OR THIS
RECOMMENDATIONS IMPLEMENTED AND
WE INDICATE GOVERNOR PUBLICLY
FACING WEBSITES. AND WITHIN
TWENTY FOUR HOURS OF DOING THAT
THESE BEER AND MANAGERS WENT
BACK INTO THEIR SYSTEM AND
REVERSE MANY OF THESE
REASSIGNMENTS. AND WITHIN TEN
DAYS THEY HAD REASSIGNED ALL
THE CASES BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
INVESTIGATORS. SO WE COMPLETE
OUR REPORT PUBLISHED IN JUNE OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND WE HAD
SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS ONE WE
RECOMMENDED THAT B. R. AND TAKE
APPROPRIATE CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
AGAINST THESE EXECUTIVES THAT
ALSO BY THIS REPORT. TO WE
RECOMMENDED THAT B. R. AND
REASSESS THE- APPROPRIATE
CASELOAD THRESHOLDS FOR ITS
INVESTIGATORS AND WHEN BEYOND
REPORTED TO US LATER IN
SEPTEMBER OF THAT YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY. THEY SAID THAT THEY
DISMISSED TWO OF THE EXECUTIVES
THAT WERE INVOLVED IN
FALSIFYING THE REPORT AND A
THIRD AND A THIRD. OF THESE
EXECUTIVES ACTUALLY LEFT TO BE
IRAN BUT THEY SAID THEY PUT A
COPY OF THE INVESTIGATION AND
NOT AND POLICE PERSONNEL FILE.
THE BOARD ALSO REPORTED IT HAD
GONE THROUGH A PROCESS TO
REALLY RE ASSESS THE
APPROPRIATE CASE LOW THRESHOLDS
FOR ITS INVESTIGATORS. AND THE
OUTCOME OF THAT WAS THEY
DETERMINED THAT BASED ON THEIR
OWN EXPERIENCE. AND THE
PRACTICE OF OTHER CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HEALING ARTS AWARDS IT
REALLY THE APPROPRIATE
THRESHOLD WAS BETWEEN TWENTY
AND THIRTY CASES. AND THE BOARD
ASSERTED THAT THE ORIGINAL
THRESHOLD OF TWENTY THAT THEY
HAD PROVIDED DURING THE AUDIT
WAS NEVER THAT WAS NEVER
MEMORIALIZES AN OFFICIAL BOARD
POLICY IT WAS ACTUALLY JUST AN
INFORMAL GOAL- SINCE THEN BEER
AND HAS AGAIN ASSERTED THAT
THEY'VE ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE OF
THIS BACKLOG THAT THEY RESOLVED
IT AND THEY RECENTLY IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY PROVIDED
ANOTHER REPORT SIMILAR TO THE
ONE THAT WE GOT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THAT- PURPORTEDLY
EVIDENCES THAT FACT AND WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW IS
VERIFYING AND VALIDATING THE
INFORMATION THAT REPORT. SO
THAT WE CAN BE SATISFIED THAT
BEER AND DID IN FACT RESOLVED
THIS BACKLOG- ATTRACTIVELY AND
WE'RE THROUGH WITH THAT PROCESS
THEN AT THAT TIME IF IT PANS
OUT WILL CLEAR THE
RECOMMENDATION. THE OTHER THING
I WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT
THESE ALLEGATIONS IN THIS
INVESTIGATION ALL CCURRED
WHILE WE WERE DOING OUR SECOND
AUDIT OF THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING WE'RE TAKING
A LOOK AT THE BOARD'S. ROLE IN
MAKING. DECISIONS THAT AFFECT
THE ENROLLMENT OF NEW AND
EXISTING PROGRAMS. AND WE
ALWAYS EXERCISE DUE DILIGENCE
IN VERIFYING ANY INFORMATION
PROVIDED BY ODDITIES BUT IN
THIS CASE IN THE IN THE ART
THAT THE MOST RECENT NOT THAT
ONE NOW. WE TOOK ADDITIONAL
MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
RELY ON ANY INFORMATION THAT
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
PROVIDED US. SO NOW I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT MOVE ON TO THAT
SECOND AUDIT REPORT OUR MOST
RECENT REPORTS. THAT WAS ISSUED
IN JULY OF LAST YEAR. AND THAT
AUDIT WAS FOCUSED ON THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING- THEIR
OVERSIGHT OF CALIFORNIA'S PRE
LICENSURE NURSING PROGRAMS. AND
IF YOU LOOK AT THE HANDOUT THAT
WE PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE ON
PAGE ONE. IT SUMMARIZES THE
THREE KEY FINDINGS OF THAT
REPORT THAT I'M GONNA TALK
ABOUT THIS MORNING- AND TWO OF
THE KEY FINDINGS REALLY RELATE
TO THE BOARDS- INVOLVEMENT IN
DECISIONS THAT IN FACT THAT A
FACT. THE ENROLLMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S NURSING PROGRAMS
AND THE THIRD ISSUE RELATES TO
THE BOARD'S EFFORTS TO OVERSEE
THESE NURSING PROGRAMS. SO FOR
THE FIRST ISSUE. WHAT WE FOUND
IS THAT- B. RN'S GOVERNING
BOARD DATE LIKE I SAID THEY
APPROVE NEW PROGRAMS AND THEY
ALSO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF ENROLLMENTS TO
APPROVE FOR EXISTING PROGRAMS.
IN THESE DECISIONS ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THEY AFFECT
THE FLOW STUDENTS INTO THE
NURSING PROGRAMS AND ULTIMATELY
THEY AFFECT THE SUPPLY OF STAYS
UP I'M SORRY OF NURSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT ONE OF
THE KEY FACTORS THAT THE BOARD
HAS TO CONSIDER THAT INFLUENCES
THESE DECISIONS IS THE SUPPLY
OF NURSES. NOW BUREN DOES
CONTRACT WITH THE UC SAN
FRANCISCO AND TO PROVIDE A- TO
BASICALLY PROVIDE EVERY TWO
YEARS AS STATEWIDE NURSING-
WORK FORCE FORECAST AND WE
LOOKED AT THEIR MOST RECENT
FORECAST IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND BASICALLY THE
FORECAST IS SAYING THAT THE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND. OF NURSES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO BE FAIRLY WELL
BALANCED OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS- ON IT BASED ON A
STATEWIDE FOCUS HOWEVER THE
REPORT DOES NOT LOOK AT
REGIONAL VARIATIONS IN THE
SUPPLY AND DEMAND OF NURSES
THEREFORE IT OBSCURES ANY HE
REGIONAL SHORTAGES AND FAX WE
IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF OTHER
STUDIES. THAT DID HAVE A
REGIONAL FOCUS AND THOSE
STUDIES ARE PROJECTING THAT
THERE ARE REGIONALSHORTAGES OF
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA NOW AND
THEY'RE PROJECTING THAT THE
SHORTAGES WILL CONTINUE INTO
THE FUTURE FOR EXAMPLE THESE
FORECASTS INDICATE THAT THERE
ARE SEVERAL REGIONS IN
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING THE BAY
AREA THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND THE
CENTRAL COAST. THAT ARE
PROJECTED TO HAVE NURSING
SHORTAGES IN THE FUTURE. SO
BASED ON THOSE FINDINGS OUR
RECOMMENDATION TO B. R. M. WAS
THAT IT NEEDS TO INCORPORATE
REGIONAL FORECASTS INTO THESE
BIENNIAL ANALYSES- TO BETTER
ENABLE ITS GOVERNING BOARD TO
MAKE MORE INFORMED DECISIONS.
THAT WOULD ADDRESS ANY REGIONAL
SHORTAGES OF NURSES. AND SKIN
SO WHEN THE ITEM WENT OUT IN
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY BEER AND
PROVIDED AN INITIAL RESPONSE
AND INITIALLY WHAT THEY SAID
WAS THAT THIS CURRENT CONTRACT.
FOR THE WORK FORCE FORECAST-
WITH EXPIRING IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR AND THEY SAID THAT THE
WORK UNDER THAT CONTRACT HAD
ALREADY BEEN DONE. BUT THEY
ASSURED US THAT THEY WOULD ASK
THEIR CONTRACTOR TO INCLUDE A
REGIONAL ANALYSIS IN THE
REPORT. IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
DELIVERED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
HOWEVER FAST FORWARD TO THEIR
MOST RECENT RESPONSE THAT WE
RECEIVED IN JANUARY OF THIS
YEAR. IT'S A LITTLE BIT
AMBIGUOUS AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
THE NEXT- FORECAST IS GOING TO
INCLUDE THIS REGIONAL ANALYSIS
BECAUSE WHAT B. R. AND SAID IS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO REVISE
THEIR NEXT CONTRACT. THAT WOULD
COVER THE PERIOD JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THREE JUNE OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE TO INCLUDE A
SPECIFIC DELIVERABLE RELATED TO
A REGIONAL ANALYSES- YEAH AND
THEY BASICALLY SAID THAT THEY
ANTICIPATE TO START THAT
CONTRACT PROCUREMENT PROCESS IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR. THE
PROBLEM IS THE LANGUAGE OF THAT
RESPONSE REALLY DOESN'T CLARIFY
WHETHER THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FORECAST THAT'S DUE SOMETIME
THIS YEAR WILL INCLUDE A
REGIONAL ANALYSIS OR NIGHTS.
AND OUR CONCERN IS THAT IF IT
DOESN'T INCLUDE A REGIONAL
ANALYSIS. AND THE BOARD MAY NOT
HAVE THAT INFORMATION UNTIL THE
NEXT. ANALYSIS IS DUE AND
THAT'S NOT TILL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE SO WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
WE MADE THIS RECOMMENDATION TO
THE BOARD. LAST SUMMER OF
TWENTY TWENTY AND NOW SIX
MONTHS LATER IT'S- IT DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT THE BOARD HAS
REVISED THAT CONTRACT TO
REQUIRE THE CONTRACTOR TO
PROVIDE KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
THE REGIONAL SUPPLY AND DEMAND
OF NURSES. AND I WOULD PREFER
TO BE OUR AND TO PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATION TO THE COMMITTEE
REGARDING WHERE THEY'RE OUT
WITH THAT AND WHETHER THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE REGION- I'M
SORRY. WORKFORCE FORECAST WILL
INCLUDE A REGIONAL ANALYSIS OR
NOT. HIS SECOND KEY ISSUE IN
THAT REPORT IS THAT WE FOUND
THAT THE GOVERNING BOARD WHEN
THEY'RE MAKING DECISIONS TO
APPROVE NEW NURSING PROGRAMS.
OR TO INCREASE THE ENROLLMENT
OF EXISTING PROGRAMS THEY'RE
NOT TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
THE AVAILABILITY OF CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS WHEN THEY MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS. AND THIS IS A
THIS IS A KEY FACTOR THAT
REALLY SHOULD BE INFLUENCING
THE GOVERNING BOARD'S DECISIONS
BECAUSE IT AFFECTS THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS ENROLLED AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY LATER AFFECTS THE
SUPPLY OF NURSES IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. BUT THE THING IS
ABOUT THESE PLACEMENTS LOSSES
THAT THESE ARE REQUIRED- AND
NURSING PROGRAMS HAS TO SECURE
THESE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
FLIGHTS SO THAT THEIR STUDENTS
CAN GET THE REQUIRED CLINICAL
PLACEMENT EXPERIENCE. IN ORDER
TO QUALIFY TO TAKE THE STATE
LICENSURE EXAM BUT THESE ARE
LIMITED RESOURCES BECAUSE NOT
ALL CLINICAL FACILITIES HAVE
THE CAPACITY FOR THE DESIRE TO
OFFER PLACEMENT SLOTS TO
NURSING PROGRAM STUDENTS.
CONSEQUENTLY THE NUMBER OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS CAN
REALLY CONSTRAIN THE
AVAILABILITY OF- PROGRAMS TO-
INCREASE THEIR ENROLLMENT TO
STUDENTS. THE OTHER THING THAT
WE FOUND AS WE HEARD THAT THERE
ARE- MANY NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
REPORTING TO US THAT THERE ARE
MANY STUDENTS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY DISPLACED. FROM THEIR
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS BECAUSE
OTHER STUDENTS TOOK THOSE SPOTS
SO THERE APPEARS TO BE A
SHORTAGE OF THESE CLINICAL
FACILITIES THAT STUDENTS REALLY
NEED TO GET THAT REQUIRED
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE. TOM IS.
THAT B. R. AND DOES NOT
ADEQUATELY TRACKED THE NUMBER
OF AVAILABLE SLOTS IN THESE
CLINICAL FACILITIES AND THE
DEMAND FOR THESE CLINICAL
FACILITIES FROM THE NURSING
PROGRAMS. AND SO BECAUSE IT'S
NOT GATHERING THAT INFORMATION
WHEN THE BOARD MAKES ITS
DECISIONS IT DOESN'T HAVE CLEAR
INFORMATION ON THE SUPPLY OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENT SLOTS. IN
THE DEMAND SO IT'S NOT ABLE TO
MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IF IT IF IT
APPROVES INCREASE ENROLLMENT
AND AN EXISTING PROGRAM COULD
THAT RESULTS IN THE
DISPLACEMENT OF STUDENTS FROM
ANOTHER PROGRAM. SO WE
RECOMMENDED THAT BEYOND THE
NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB OF
GATHERING INFORMATION ABOUT THE
AVAILABILITY OF THESE CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE DEMAND FOR
THOSE SLOTS FROM NURSING
PROGRAMS. AND ONCE THEY GET
THAT WE NEED TO START PROVIDING
IT TO THE BOARD SO THAT THE
BOARD HAS THAT INFORMATION WHEN
IT'S MAKING THESE IMPORTANT
ROLE MY DECISIONS. THE B. R.
AND- THEY AGREE WITH THAT
ENDING AND IT MAKES SENSE TO
THEM CONCEPTUALLY AND THERE
JANUARY STATUS UPDATE REPORT
THEY THEY DID REPORT THAT THEY
HAVE REVISED. THE FORMS THAT
THEY USE TO KEEP TRACK OF THE
NUMBER OF THESE DIFFERENT
FACILITIES THAT NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE USING. HOWEVER
THEY REPORTED THAT THEY WERE
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING- REGULATIONS. THAT
THEY SAY ARE NECESSARY TO
REQUIRE NURSING PROGRAMS AND
FACILITIES TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION. AND THEY'RE ALSO
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING A DATABASE BECAUSE
WE UGGESTED THAT THEY NEED TO
START CAPTURING INFORMATION ON
THE AVAILABILITY THIS CLINICAL
CAPACITY THE DEMAND FOR IT. PUT
IT IN A DATABASE SO THEY CAN
SHARE THAT INFORMATION WITH
THEIR BOARD AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE PUBLICLY TO NURSING
PROGRAMS- BUT THAT HAS NOT
HASN'T HAPPENED YET AND IT'S
NOT CLEAR TO US WHETHER THAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN. BY APRIL BY THE
APRIL FIRST DEADLINE THAT WE
INCLUDE IN OUR RECOMMENDATION
SO AGAIN. I WOULD DEFER TO BE
OUR ENDS EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT
TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON THE
CURRENT STATUS OF ITS EFFORTS
IN THAT CRITICAL AREA. ONE OF
THE THING RELATED TO THAT.
BECAUSE THIS ISSUE OF THESE
THIS CLINICAL EXPERIENCES SUCH
A KEY ISSUE FOR STUDENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY- THEY THEY
ARE ABLE TO GET THIS EXPERIENCE
AND MEET THE REQUIREMENTS TO
GRADUATE FROM THESE PROGRAMS
AND TAKE A LICENSURE EXAM. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE DID IS WE
GOT A HOLD OF OSHKOSH IS THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT. THEY
HAVE A DOWNLOADABLE DATABASE
THAT INCLUDES A LIST OF ALL
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES IN THE
ENTIRE STATE SO WE DID. IS WE
GATHER INFORMATION FROM B. R.
N. FIRST SIXTEEN NURSING
PROGRAMS IN THE BAY AREA AND
FIVE AREA COUNTIES AND WHAT WE
DID IS FOR THOSE SIXTEEN
PROGRAMS IN THE BAY AREA. WE
COMPARED THE FACILITIES. THAT
THE PROGRAMS WERE ACTUALLY
USING. THE POPULAR OF ALL
AVAILABLE FACILITIES IN THE BAY
AREA USING ARAFAT'S DATA. AND
WE FOUND THAT. FOR THOSE JUST
THOSE SIXTEEN NURSING PROGRAMS
THEY'RE ONLY USING A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE OF MORE THAN
SEVEN HUNDRED FACILITIES THAT
ARE OUT THERE JUST IN THE BAY
AREA SUCH LESS THAN SEVENTEEN
PERCENT. AND WHAT THAT IS
TELLING US IS THAT THERE ARE
LITERALLY HUNDREDS OF.
FACILITIES IN JUST THOSE FIVE
COUNTIES. THAT NURSING PROGRAMS
ARE CURRENTLY NOT USING. TO
PROVIDE THIS CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE FOR THEIR STUDENTS
AND THIS REALLY REPRESENTS A
POTENTIALLY UNTAPPED SOURCE OF
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS. AND WE BELIEVE THAT YOU
KNOW DOING THIS COMPARISON IS
NECESSARY WE RECOGNIZE THAT- IF
BEER AND STARTS TO DO THIS
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
FOLLOW UP WITH SOME OF THOSE
FACILITIES BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
THAT THERE ARE SOME FACILITIES
THAT. THEY PROBABLY DON'T WANT
TO PROVIDE CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS ARE NOT STAFFED UP TO DO
IT BUT WE STILL THINK IT WOULD
BE WORTHWHILE FOR B. R. AND TO
PERIODICALLY OUR RECOMMENDATION
IS THAT THEY DO THIS ANNUALLY
STARTING IN OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR. COMPARED BE CLINICAL
FACILITIES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
OFFERING SLOTS FOR CALIFORNIA'S
NURSING STUDENTS. TO THE TOTAL
POPULATION OF FACILITIES AND
THEN DO THE FOLLOW UP TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL CLINICAL
PLACEMENT SLOTS THAT COULD BE
USED TO ALLEVIATE THIS
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRAINT ON
ENROLLMENT FOR NURSING PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY IN AREAS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCING NURSING SHORTAGES.
AGAIN B. R. AN AGREES
CONCEPTUALLY THEY AGREE THIS IS
A GOOD IDEA I THINK COULD BE
VERY HELPFUL IN IDENTIFYING
ADDITIONAL CLINICAL PLACEMENT
SLOTS AND THEY'VE TOLD US IN
THEIR MOST RECENT- UPDATE IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THAT
THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS. OF
DEVELOPING THE SYSTEM SO. MAIN
CITIES AS A FALL ON AND WHAT
THE OUTCOME OF THAT WILL BE.
THIRTY ISSUE IN THIS REPORT
THIRD AND FINAL ISSUE IS THAT.
WE FOUND THAT B. R. AND
APPROVAL. AND CONTINUING
OVERSIGHT OF THE- OF NURSING
PROGRAMS IS VERY SIMILAR TO
WHAT NATIONAL ACCREDITING
ORGANIZATIONS ARE DEALING. AND
SO SPECIFICALLY WE FOUNDED B.
R. INS REQUIREMENTS FOR NURSING
PROGRAMS IN MANY AREAS. OVERLAP
THE STANDARDS THAT ARE IMPOSED
BY NATIONAL NURSING PROGRAM
ACCREDITORS AND- ENTERED INTO
EXTENDED THEY OVERLAP. THERE'S
DUPLICATION AND IT'S
INEFFICIENT. SO IF YOU AGAIN IF
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT PAGES TWO
AND THREE OF THE HANDOUT THAT
WE PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE. IT
WALKS THROUGH SOME OF THE
SIMILARITIES AND DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN B. R. ENDS PROCESS
VERSUS THE ACCREDITORS. AND AT
A HIGH LEVEL WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT B. R. ENDS PROCESS FOR
APPROVING BOTH NEW PROGRAMS THE
INITIAL APPROVAL PROCESS AND
FOR OVERSEEING EXISTING
PROGRAMS IS- THERE AND
BASICALLY OVERLAPS FAIRLY
SIGNIFICANTLY WITH THE
STANDARDS OF THESE ARE
CREDITORS. FOR EXAMPLE AS I
SHOWN IN THE IN THE HANDOUTS
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT- BOTH OF
THESE PROCESS SEASON BEERMAN'S
PROCESS AND YOUR CREDITORS IN
BOTH CASES. WE ARE VERIFYING
THAT THE NURSING PROGRAM
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS ARE
QUALIFIED AND HAVE RELEVANT
EXPERIENCE. BUT ALSO VERIFYING
OF NURSING PROGRAM HAS
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES FOR BOTH
ITS STUDENTS AND FACULTY. IN
ADDITION THEY'RE BOTH ENSURE
CURRICULUM IS COMPREHENSIVE AND
INCLUDES THAT CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE THAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT. THEY'RE ALSO CHECKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT NEVER NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE MAINTAINING A
MINIMUM PASS RATE FOR THE
LICENSURE EXAM. AND THOSE ARE
ALL OBVIOUSLY VERY KEY
COMPONENTS OF ANY KIND OF
OVERSIGHT OF NURSING PROGRAMS
BUT I ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE SOME IMPORTANT
DIFFERENCES. BETWEEN B. RN'S
OVERSIGHT AND THE ACCREDITATION
FOR EXAMPLE. BUREN'S PRIMARY
MISSION IS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC AND ENSURE THAT THESE
NURSING PROGRAMS ME ARMENIAN
STATE STANDARDS. WHILE ON THE
OTHER HAND THE ACCREDITORS
THEY'RE THEY'RE BASICALLY
MAKING SURE THEY'RE FOCUSING ON
THE QUALITY AND PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS FOR EACH OF THESE
PROGRAMS. THE OTHER THING I
WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT THE
CREDITORS. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CLOSE A NURSING
PROGRAM DOWN THAT DOESN'T MEET
THEIR STANDARDS WELL BURKE
BOARDS OF NURSING DO YOU HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY. THE OTHER THING
I WANT TO POINT OUT IS THAT FOR
NURSING PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO GET THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING APPROVAL IN
ORDER TO OPERATE WHEREAS THAT'S
NOT THE CASE OR ACCREDITATION
IN CALIFORNIA ACCREDITATION OF
NURSING PROGRAMS IT'S OPTIONAL.
AND AT THE TIME OF OUR AUDIT
ONLY ROUGHLY HALF OF THE
NURSING PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
ARE ACTUALLY A CREDIT.
NOTWITHSTANDING WE BELIEVE THAT
ALIGNING THE STATE REVIEW
PROCESS WITH ACCREDITATION IT
MAKES SENSE AND WE DON'T THINK
IT'S UNCOMMON AND WE IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL OTHER CALIFORNIA.
HEALING ARTS BOARDS THAT
ACTUALLY ALREADY DOING THAT IT
RELY ON ACCREDITATION IN SOME
CASES AND IN OTHER CASES THEY
THEY COLLABORATE WITH THEIR THE
ACCREDITORS AND SO. A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA. THE OSTEOPATHIC
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA THE
PHYSICIAN'S ASSISTANT BOARD THE
DENTAL HYGIENE BOARD THEY ARE
ALL RELYING ON ACCREDITATION
EITHER IN PLACE OR IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THEIR OWN
OVERSIGHT. ANY OTHER THING I
JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT HERE
TOWARDS THE END IS THAT THIS
COLLABORATION BETWEEN STATES
AND ACCREDITORS IT'S
ENCOURAGED. THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF STATE BOARDS AND THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL STATE BOARDS
OF NURSING. THEY RECOMMEND THE
BOARDS OF NURSING SHOULD BE
WORKING TOWARDS HARMONIZING-
WILL PROCESS WITH THE CREDITORS
BECAUSE IT MAKE SENSE. SO AS
PART OF. THIS SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS IN THE REPORT WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER. AS A PART
OF THIS PROCESS WHETHER B. R.
AND SHOULD REVISE ITS
REGULATIONS TO LEVERAGE THE
PORTIONS OF THE ACCREDITORS
REVIEW WHERE THERE IS OVERLAP.
AND WE ARE NOT SUGGESTING THAT
ACCREDITATION IS AN EXACT
REPLACEMENT FOR B. R. IN THE
OVERSIGHT WE KNOW THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. BUT WE DO BELIEVE IT
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE TO
RESTRUCTURE B. R. AND OVERSIGHT.
TO TO REDUCE ANY DUPLICATION OF
EFFORT AND WE THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE TO DO THAT TO REDUCE
THE DUPLICATION. SHE WOULD
SHE'D SOME COST SAVINGS AND
EFFICIENCIES WHILE ALLOWING BE
ARE AND TO STILL ACHIEVE ITS
MISSION OF PROTECTING THE
PUBLIC. SO IN TERMS OF BE
AARON'S RESPONSE THE- THIS IS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE MADE TO
THE LEGISLATURE THAT IT
CONSIDER THIS AS PART OF THIS
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS. BUT B.
ARE INDEED INDICATE THAT THEY
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA. AND
THEY SUGGESTED THAT THEY'RE
WILLING TO TAKE THE LEAD IN
IDENTIFYING AND ADDRESSING ANY
THIS DUPLICATION OF OVERSIGHT
BETWEEN THEIR OVERSIGHT NOW OUT
OF THE ACCREDITORS. AND AGAIN I
WOULD DEFER TO BE OUR ENDS
EXECUTIVES TO PROVIDE AN UPDATE
ON THAT LATER IN THE HEARING.
THAT CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
WITHOUT I'M I CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT THE MEMBER
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHILDREN BEFORE- IT
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS I THOUGHT IT MIGHT
ASK A FEW. JUST A VERY FEW
FOUNDATIONAL QUESTIONS WITH
RESPECT TO THE COMPLAINT DELAY
ISSUE WITH THE B. R. N. AND
YOUR AUDIT REPORT. AND
SPECIFICALLY PM FOR WHICH IS
THE FORMAL COMPLAINT PROCESS.
WERE YOU ABLE TO DETERMINE AS
BETWEEN THE B. R. IN DCA OR THE
END OR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHICH OF THOSE ENTITIES ARE
AGENCIES WERE. RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE DELAY IN PROCESSING FORMAL
COMPLAINTS. YES SENATOR ROCKS
SO WHAT OUR UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE CRITERIA SET BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
BUT IN OUR AUDIT WHAT WE FOUND
ISTHE DELAY WAS IT APPEARED TO
BE OCCURRING WITH THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. BET THERE
WAS A DELAY THERE IN TERMS OF
THEY WERE JUST WERE NOT
TRIAGING THESE COMPLAINTS AND
EITHER ASSIGNING THEM TO THEIR
OWN INTERNAL INVESTIGATORS OR
THEY'RE ACTUALLY REQUIRED
THERE'S A STATE LAW THAT
REQUIRES THEM TO ASSIGN ANY
COMPLAINTS. THERE ARE HIGH
PRIORITY OR URGENT THOUGH
SHOULD BE ASSIGNED TO CONSUMER.
SWORN INVESTIGATORS SO REALLY
THE DELAY WAS STARTING WITH THE
BOARD AND THEIR EFFORTS TO
TRIAGE THESE COMPLAINTS AND
EITHER ASSIGN THEM TO THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATORS OR TO CONSUMER.
THANK YOU- NOW WITH RESPECT TO
THE PRE LICENSURE PROGRAMS IN
THE SUPPLY OF A NURSES IN THE
STATE. AS PART OF YOUR AUDIT
BEYOND ENSURING THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IN NURSING PRACTICE AND
TRYING TO PREVENT A SHORTAGE OF
NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN TERMS OF THE B.
R. ENDS ACTIVITIES BEYOND THAT.
WERE YOU ABLE TO DETERMINE WHAT
THE BOARD'S INTENT OR PURPOSE.
WHAT IS OR ISN'T TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT. THERE'S NO SURPLUS
OF NURSES IN THE STATE. I SURE
SO WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT THE
YEAR ENDS CONSULTANT WAS DOING
IN TERMS OF THE BI ANNUAL
FORECAST. THE PROBLEM AGAIN IS
IT WAS A STATE WIDE FORECASTS
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE LAST
FEW FORECAST THEY WERE VERY
SIMILAR THIS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN FORECAST PROJECTED AT
BALLOT STATEWIDE BETWEEN SUPPLY
AND DEMAND. TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ACTUALLY SUGGESTED
THAT THERE WILL BE A SLIGHT
SURPLUS OF NURSES I BELIEVE IN
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AGAIN ON
STATEWIDE LEVEL. BUT WHEN WE
DRILL DOWN AND LOOK AT SOME OF
THESE OTHER REPORTS AND BY THE
WAY ONE OF THESE OTHER REPORTS
ALSO CAME FROM UC SAN FRANCISCO
AND IN FACT WAS PUT TOGETHER
BY. THE SAME CONSULTANT THAT
THE BOARD USES BUT IT INCLUDED
A REGIONAL ANALYSIS WHEN WE
LOOKED AT BACK. WE FOUND THAT
THERE WERE MANY REGIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES RIGHT NOW
AND ARE PROJECTED TO HAVE A
SHORTAGE IN TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
I GUESS MY QUESTION GOES TO
THIS I MEAN AND THE BOARD'S. IS
IT IS OCCASIONALLY HAVING A
SURPLUS OF NURSES A BAD THING
AND I WAS ASKING REALLY. IF YOU
WERE ABLE TO DETERMINE
DETERMINE WHAT THE MOTIVATION
IS AN ECONOMIC ISSUE WHERE. WE
DON'T WANT TO SURPLUS OF NURSES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE- IT DRIVES DOWN
SALARIES THAT DOES SOMETHING
ELSE. MAYBE THAT WAS BEYOND THE
SCOPE OF YOUR AUDIT BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY IF YOU'RE USING
SHORTAGE VERSUS SURPLUS TO
DETERMINE WHETHER SCHOOL NEW
SCHOOLS ARE APPROVED OR
EXISTING SCHOOLS CAN EXPAND I
UNDERSTAND SHORTAGE BEING A
FACTOR I AM HAVING A DIFFICULT
TIME UNDERSTANDING HOW SURPLUS
IS A FACTOR IN THAT DECISION.
DID THAT COME UP AT ALL IN YOUR
AUDIT. WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT DID THE PROBLEM THAT WE
REALLY NOTED IS THAT THE BOARD
DOESN'T WHEN THEY'RE MAKING
THESE DECISIONS TO APPROVE A
NEW NURSING PROGRAMS OR TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT THAT THE
REAL ROOT PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE INFORMATION
TO MAKE INFORMED DECISIONS SO
LET FOR EXAMPLE IF THERE IS A
NOR IF THERE IS A NURSING
PROGRAM IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAS SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION TO INCREASE
ENROLLMENT BY A HUNDRED
STUDENTS. THE BOARD WHEN THEY
MAKE A DECISION ON WHETHER TO
IMPROVE THAT WRONG THEY DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT WHETHER
THAT AREA ALREADY HAS A
SHORTAGE OF NURSES OR A SURPLUS
OF NURSES AND OR HOW THAT
SITUATION IS PROJECTED TO BE
DIFFERENT IN THE FUTURE SO THAT
WAS. OUR CONCERN WAS THE BOARD
DOESN'T EVEN SEEM TO HAVE A
HANDLE ON WHETHER THERE ARE
SHORTAGES OR SURPLUSESIN
SPECIFIC REGIONS IN THE STATE
OKAY THANK YOU LET ME MOVE ON
SO I CAN TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES FOR MORE DETAILED
QUESTIONS IN THE AREA OF
CLINICAL PLACEMENT I GATHER
FROM YOUR REPORT THAT SLOTS
CLINICAL SLUDGE. MAY OCCUR AT
BOTH HOSPITALS AND CLINICS AT
LEAST. IN SOME CASES IS THAT
CORRECT. THAT'S CORRECT AND
THEN ON ON PAGE TWENTY TWO OF
YOUR OTHER REPORT I FOUND YOUR
CHART INTERESTING. WHERE
APPARENTLY THERE WAS A SURVEY
AND IF MY MATH IS CORRECT.
SIXTY FOUR OF ABOUT A HUNDRED
PROGRAMS THAT WERE SURVEYED
REFLECTED THAT THE REASON. FOR
CLINICAL SLOT DISPLACEMENT WAS
SOMETHING. OTHER THAN ANOTHER
NURSING PRO TO. THE FLOOD THAT
THAT PART OF EUROPE. YEAH
THAT'S DID WE DIDN'T THERE WERE-
NUMBER OF REASON WE TOOK LOOK
AT. THAT WE- THIS. AND I THAT'S
OVER SHOWING IN AND OUT FIGURE
ON PAGE TWO TWO. AND WE DID FOR
THAT THERE WERE NO OF RE SO-
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE I THINK
THERE WAS. THE PROGRAMS THAT
REPORTED CHOICE REPORTED THAT
THERE WERE MORE THAN TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED NURSING STUDENTS
THAT WERE DISPLACED. BUT YOU'RE
RIHT IT WAS NOT ALWAYS BECAUSE
THOSE STUDENTS GOT BOMBS BY
STUDENTS FROM OTHER PROGRAMS
THERE WERE OTHER REASONS
SOMETIMES FACILITIES DECIDE
THAT THEY NO LONGER HAVE. THE
STAFFING. TO BASICALLY MAKE
THESE CLINICAL- SLOTS AVAILABLE
SO CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHER
REASONS. THAT I'VE FOUND WITH
RESPECT TO YOUR- REVIEW OF
THOSE SIXTEEN NURSING PROGRAMS
SORT OF FASCINATING THAT. OF
THE SLOTS 82% OF ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL SLOTS IN THE BAY AREA
WERE USED BUT ONLY 10% OF THE
CLINIC SLOTS WERE UTILIZED FOR
NURSING TRAINING BY THOSE
PROGRAMS WERE YOU ABLE TO
DETERMINE WHY MORE CLINIC AS
OPPOSED TO CLINICAL CLINICS
SLOTS. WERE NOT USED. I THINK
WHAT WHAT WE NOTED THAT- AS HE
SAID THAT IT DOES APPEAR THAT
THE NURSING PROGRAMS ARE ARE
USING THE ACUTE CARE FACILITIES
MUCH MORE THAN THEY USE IN THE
OTHER CLINICS- I DON'T KNOW
THAT WE GOT AN EXPLANATION FOR
WHY THAT'S OCCURRING. BUT I
THINK THAT'S WHY WE THINK OUR
RECOMMENDATION TO AT LEAST TAKE
A LOOK AT THE POPULATION OF NOT
JUST ACUTE CARE FACILITIES BUT
THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF CLINICS.
THE CITY AND BE OUR SPOTS
DATABASE. AND I THINK WHAT B.
R. N. NEEDS TO DO IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE NURSING
PROGRAMS IS REACH OUT TO SOME
OF THESE CLINICS. AND SEE IF
THERE WOULD BE WILLING TO
PROVIDE CLINICAL EXPERIENCE AND
SEE WHETHER THEY HAVE. THE
RIGHT KINDS OF PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE THE APPROPRIATE
TYPES OF EXPERIENCE I THINK OUR
IMPRESSION IS THAT THAT JUST
HASN'T HAPPENED YET. YOU KNOW
GIVEN THE DATA THAT YOU
PROVIDED IN YOUR AUDIT REPORT
ON CLINICS LOTS WHERE THEY ARE
WHICH ONES ARE UTILIZED AND-
WHICH ONES APPARENTLY OR NOT
YOU HAVE NOT BEEN TYPICALLY
UTILIZED AT LEAST IN THE AREAS
THAT YOU SURVEYED. WERE YOU
ABLE TO DETERMINE WHETHER THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
DENIED ANY. POSED NURSING
PROGRAM EXPANSION OR ANY NEW
SCHOOL APPLICATIONS BASED ON
THIS- ONE CERTAIN CLINICAL SLOT
DATA. I DON'T BELIEVE THAT EVER
CAME UP I DON'T BELIEVE IN OUR
TESTING WE IDENTIFY THE
SITUATION WHERE THE BOARD-
DECIDED NOT TO APPROVE EITHER A
NEW PROGRAM OR ANY INCREASE
ENROLLMENT EXISTING PROGRAM
BECAUSE- PROGRAM WAS GOING TO
BE USING AT THE CLINIC. VIDE
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE TO STUDENTS
AS OPPOSED TO A ACUTE CARE
FACILITY. OKAY THANK YOU SIR
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES QUESTIONS
LET'S START FROM THE FOR
CARILLO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ZHOROV INVECTIVE VERY MUCH MISS
UNTIL THEN- WANTED. QATAR
TENSION ON A BACKGROUND PAPER
PAGE TWENTY SEVEN IT'S ON ISSUE
NUMBER SIX AND SEVEN ON THE
YOUR AUDITORS REPORT. BUT
SPECIFICALLY- YOU REFERENCED-
ON D. FALSIFICATION OF DATA AND
THEREFORE THE PENDING-
CONCLUSIONS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
AS TO THE STATUS OF. ADDITIONAL
ANALYSIS NEEDS TO VERIFY
INVESTIGATOR CASELOADS. YOU
ALSO REFERENCED EARLIER IN YOUR
IN YOUR TESTIMONY THE LACK OF
CONFIDENCE IT'S GIVEN THE-
MOVING PIECES IS THAT STILL THE
CASE TODAY WITH RESPECT TO. THE
SENSE OF. OUR CONFIDENCE IN THE
ABILITY TO HAVE VERIFIED DATA
THAT IS BEFORE YOU. YEAH WE DO
HAVE A CONCERN BECAUSE THE
BOARD- BASICALLY AGAIN RECENTLY
IN I THINK NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
TWENTY THEY SENT US A REPORT
AND SAID HEYWE'VE NOW RESOLVED
THIS ISSUE WE RESOLVE THE
BACKLOG BUT- AS YOU SUGGESTED
DID THE REPORT IS THE SAME
REPORT THAT THEY PROVIDED BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. THAT
THEY HAD MANIPULATED AND
FALSIFIED SO WE'RE IN THE
PROCESS WERE ACTUALLY JUST
GETTING STARTED. GOING THROUGH
AND VERIFYING AND VALIDATING
THAT REPORT AND WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE ACTUALLY LOOKING
AT THE DATA. VERIFY THAT THAT
THE PERIOD OF TIME WHEN ANY
REASSIGNMENTS WERE MAY AND
SEVERITY FIVE THAT THE
INVESTIGATORS ALL HAVE
CASELOADS THAT ARE WITHIN.
THEIR CRITERIA ESTABLISHED IN
THE BOARD'S POLICY AND SO WE'RE
NOT CONFIDENT THAT THE BOARD
REALLY HAS RESOLVED THIS
BACKLOG. UNTIL WE GET A CHANCE
TO FINISH VERIFYING AND
VALIDATING WHAT THEY'RE TELLING
US BASED ON DATA. THANK YOU AND
GIVEN THE LACK OF CONFIDENCE ON
THE- CONCLUSION OF THE
FALSIFIED DATA. DO YOU HAVE
SOME INSIGHTS WITHRESPECT TO
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT THE ROLE
IF YOU LACKS AND ALSO YOUR
OFFICE AS WELL TO ENSURE THAT
WE'RE WORKING. AT IT IT
COLLABORATIVE RELATED SURE THAT
WE COME OVER THE SAME. A LEVEL
OF CONFIDENCE IN THE
INFORMATION THAT'S PROVIDED
BEFORE US. YEAH WE HAD TO-
BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE WITH
pWE DID IS NOT ONLY ARE WE
HAVING TO VERIFY AND VALIDATE
THAT MOST RECENT REPORT THAT
THEY SENT US BECAUSE- I MEAN
QUITE HONESTLY WE REALIZE NOW
THAT WE CAN'T TAKE THAT
INFORMATION AT FACE VALUE AND
WE ALWAYS PERFORM DUE DILIGENCE
THAT WE KNOW. WITH ANYTHING
THAT THE BOARDS PROVIDING WE
HAVE TO PERFORM EXTRA DUE
DILIGENCE BEFORE WE CAN RELY ON
THAT INFORMATION- AND SO FROM
OUR STANDPOINT ON A GO FORWARD
BASIS INCLUDING OUR MOST RECENT
AUDIT. WE HAVE BEEN- DONE EXTRA
WORK WE'VE GONE EVEN FURTHER
THAN WE NORMALLY WOULD IN TERMS
OF DUE DILIGENCE TO MAKE SURE
THAT ANYTHING THAT THE BOARD
PROVIDES. IT IS ACCURATE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TO
THE. THANK YOU CARILLO- MR
GRAYSON. THANK YOU CHAIR ROB
AND- THANK YU TO- THE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE FOR A FULL
REPORT- SEVERAL CONCERNS THAT
COME OUT OF THAT REPORT- SUCH
AS LACK OF DATA TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE PROPER DECISIONS IN ONE
AREA AND THEN LOW CONFIDENCE IN
ANOTHER AREA I DID HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT- THE THERE WAS A
LIST THAT WAS DELIVERED OF. OF
DIFFERENT OTHER AGENCIES AND-
BOARDS AND HOW IT WAS
DESCRIBED- IT SOUNDED LIKE
THERE WAS A MUCH BETTER
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH
CREDITORS SO IN. IN REFERENCE
TO BE ARE IN NGUYEN IS THE
JUSTIFICATION FOR THEIR LACK OF
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
CREDITOR IS A PHILOSOPHICAL IS
IT- IS A PROCESS THAT SEEMS TO
BE BROKEN. IS IT SOMETHING-
THAT. MAYBE WE NEED TO TAKE
ACTION ON UP WHAT IS IT THAT
WOULD- ADDRESS THAT MOST
EFFECTIVELY. THROUGH THE AUDIT
WE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH- THE
BOARDS MANAGEMENT AND I THINK
THEY WANT THEIR THEY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE POINT THAT THEIR-
THEIR MISSION IS DIFFERENT THAT
THEIR PRIMARY MISSION IS ALL
ABOUT PROTECTING THE PUBLIC
ENSURING THAT. NURSING PROGRAMS
MEET STANDARDS WHICH WHICH IS
FINE- BUT WHAT WE FOUND WHEN WE
LOOKED AT SOME OF THESE
ACCREDITORS THERE'S TWO PRIMARY
NATIONAL CREDITORS OUT THERE
AND WE FOUND THAT. THE
ACCREDITORS OFTENTIMES IN THEIR
REVIEWS THEY ARE ALSO CHECKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE HEARING TO STATE
REQUIREMENTS. SO WHAT I WOULD
SAY IS THAT DURING THE AUDIT I
THINK. THE BOARD WAS A LITTLE
LESS OPEN TO THIS IDEA THAT
THERE WAS A DUPLICATION OF
EFFORTS. AND THAT IT IS
POSSIBLE LIKE YOU SAID TO HAVE
MORE OF A SYMBIOTIC
RELATIONSHIP AND TO REALLY I
THINK WHAT WHAT SHOULD BE
HAPPENING IS THE BOARD SHOULD
BE COLLABORATING WITH YOUR
CREDITORS SO THAT BOTH SIDES
CAN STREAMLINE YOUR PROCESS
SEES AND ELIMINATE THE
DUPLICATION. BY THE TIME THAT
WE FINISH THE AUDIT IN THE
BOARD'S ACTUAL OFFICIAL
RESPONSE TO THE AUDIT. THEY I
THINK THEY HAD SORT OF COME
ALONG AND AGREED THAT IT MAKES
SENSE AND EVEN THOUGH WE MADE A
LEGISLATIVE RECOMMENDATION OF
THE LEGISLATURE. CONSIDER
REVISING THE BOARD'S RAGS TO
ELIMINATE HIS DUPLICATION AT
THE END OF BOARD SAID THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THE LEAD ON
THIS THEY LIKE TO IDENTIFY THE
OVERLAP. AND COME UP WITH A
PLAN TO ADDRESS IT. THANK YOU.
WHILE I'M WAITING FOR I THINK
DOCTOR PAN WHAT CHIRLA DO YOU
HAVE FURTHER QUESTIONS. JUST
ONE OTHER ONE A IF OF WHAT I
KNOW THAT WE'RE WAITING FOR
ANOTHER COMMITTEE MEMBER I
DON'T KNOW FROM THE FIRST TELL
THEM THIS MIGHT BEAPPROPRIATE
FOR YOU AS WELL TO OR IF YOU
HAVE SOME INSIGHTS. AS YOU KNOW
THIS IS OUR DUTY IT'S OUR JOB
ON THE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU'RE
USING IS UNCOMFORTABLE- IT BY
NO MEANS DO WE DERIVE ANY
PLEASURE IN HIGHLIGHTING THE
DEFICIENCIES. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE WE ARE
ULTIMATELY ALL THE STATE WHAT
IS OUR OBLIGATION TO BE
STEWARDS OF PUBLIC TRUST. I WAS
JUST WE WERE JUST RECENTLY
INFORMED THAT- TO THE
TRADITIONALLY WE WOULD HAVE THE
WORD REPRESENTATION FOR THE
OVERSIGHT OF THESE FEARS.
HEARING SOME PORTS IN BUREAUS
AND DEPARTMENTS CONSUMER
AFFAIRS BUT WERE JUST MADE
AWARE THAT I'M AGENCY HAS
DISCOURAGED THE PUBLIC BOARD
MEMBER FROM PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING- THERE. ONE COULD
CONCLUDE AND INTERPRET THAT AS
THINGS SUCH THAT THERE IS NOT
THE TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE THESE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS. WE WANT TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THESE
ISSUES TOO SO AGAIN IT WAS JUST
MADE UP OF WHICH IS MADE AWARE
THAT THE AGENCY HAS
DISCOURAGED. PUBLIC REPRESENTED
FROM THE BOARD OF REGISTERED.
NURSING NOT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS HEARING. IS THAT THE NEW
YORK AS A TO. HOW MIGHT YOU
SUGGEST WE AND- THE LACK OF
PARTICIPATION FROM ABOARD
MATTER IN AN APPROPRIATE
OVERSIGHT HEARING SUCH AS THE
SUNSET REVIEW. I'M NOT SURE
THAT I CAN COMMENT ON THAT- I'M
NOT SURE- WHAT THE NORMAL
PROTOCOL IS THERE- I WOULD HOPE
THAT THE AGENCY AND THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING SIGN
EXECUTIVE MANAGEMENT TEAM WOULD
BE ON THE SAME PAGE. SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT- WHEN THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FROM THE BOARD
TESTIFIES LOOK AT LATER AT
THAT- MAYBE SHE'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO NOT ONLY
MANAGEMENT PERSPECTIVE ON THIS
BUT ALSO THE PERSPECTIVE OF
AGENCIES SO I WOULD HOPE THAT.
B. R. ENDS EXECUTIVE OFFICER IS
REPRESENTED POSITION NOT JUST
OF THE BOARD BUT ALSO AGENCY.
30% OF. THANK YOU MISTER MEMBER
DOLLARS. I JUST HAVE A
CLARIFYING QUESTION SO- IN
REGARDS TO THAT SEVENTY URGENT
COMPLAINTS WAS THAT YOUR OFFICE
THAT SET THEM TO BE URGENT- WAS
THAT THE BEER AND WHEN THEY RE
DID THE DATA. RE ENTERED THE
NUMBERS TO DATE. CREATE THE
ORDER. YEAH THAT WAS ACTUALLY
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
THEY HAVE CRITERIA WHERE THEY
ASSIGN THESE COMPLAINTS-
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF- PRIORITY
RANGING FROM HIGH PRIORITY
ACTUALLY URGENT HIGH PRIORITY
AND THEY HAVE TWO CATEGORIES
THAT ARE MORE ROUTINE SO THAT
WAS BASED ON THE BOARD'S OWN
IDENTIFICATION AND OWN CRITERIA
THAT THESE SEVENTY COMPLAINTS
WERE HIGH PRIORITY OR OF AN
URGENT NATURE. AND AT THE
MINIMUM THEY'RE BEING ADDRESSED
IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THAT'S THE
REQUIREMENT AND THAT'S THAT
REQUIREMENT COMES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. THAT THESE
THINGS B. R. SIGNED ACTUALLY
THE INVESTIGATION AS COMPLETED
AND RESOLVED WITHIN EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. SO IF THE PURPOSE OF
THE HEARING IS TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC WE HAVE SEVENTY URGENT
COMPLAINTS. EXISTING I HAVE TO
WONDER IF MAYBE THE BEER AND IS
NOT THE BEST. AGENCY TO BE
LOOKING OUT FOR THE PUBLIC.
SEVENTY URGENT COMPLAINTS COULD
MEAN A MULTITUDE OF THINGS AND
SO ON THESE ARE PEOPLE'S LIVES
THAT THEY'RE IN CHARGE OF
SOMETHING. ON VERY CONCERNING
THANK YOU FOR YOUR REPORT.
THANK YOU MEMBER DOLLY SENATOR
MEN. I DON'T HAVE MY HAND UP
BUT- I'M I'M HAPPY I GUESS MY I
DID HAVE A QUESTION THOUGH
SINCE YOU CALLED ON ME- OR
MAYBE COMMENT YOU KNOW I YA
COME FROM THIS IS ALL NEW TO ME
BUT I COME FROM A BACKGROUND-I
STARTED DEBT SECURITIES AND
EXCHANGE COMMISSION I'VE WORKED
ON ACCOUNTING FRAUD CASES IN MY
PAST AND- THE TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
YOU DESCRIBE IF IT HAPPENED IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR- WE WOULD
SEE. A LOT OF CRIMINAL
PROSECUTIONS YOU'D SEE ARE
TYPICALLY A REPLACEMENT OF THE
BOARD YOU SEE- INDEPENDENT
AUDITS- INTERNAL INVESTIGATIONS
INTO LIKE AND I GUESS YOU KNOW
I'D BE INTERESTED IN YOUR
COMMENT- MISTER CHILDREN JUST
ON. ON WHETHER MORE ACTION'S
ALONG THESE LINES ARE PROGRAM.
I CA SAY THAT- WE WERE- VERY-
THIS IS A BIG DEAL THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN VERY OFTEN WE'RE
CONDUCTING AUDITS SO IT WAS.
AGAIN FOR US TO HAVE. AN AUDIT
C. LIKE THE BOARD. TELL US THAT
THEY'VE RESOLVED A VERY
IMPORTANT RECOMMENDATION. AS WE
JUST TALKED ABOUT TO ASSIGN
THESE COMPLAINTS SO THEY COULD
BE RESOLVED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THEY HAVE AN AUDIT T. TELL US
THEY DID THAT. AND THEN WE GO
BACK AND SAY WELL WE NEED SOME
SUPPORT GIVE US THE EVIDENCE
AND THEN TO HAVE THEM DO THAT.
AND THEN LATER TO FIND OUT THAT
IT WAS ALL BOGUS DATA AND THAT
THEY HAD MANIPULATED IT WAS
VERY- OBVIOUSLY VERY CONCERNING
WE TOOK IT VERY SERIOUSLY WE
STARTED AN INVESTIGATION RIGHT
AWAY. AND AS I SAID IT ALL OVER
FUTURE DEALINGS WITH THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING. WE ARE
GOING TO BE EVEN MORE VIGILANT
THAN WE NORMALLY ARE TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE CAN RELY ON ANY
INFORMATION THAT THEY PROVIDE
US. BUT I THINK I WANTED TRYING
TO GET TO IS. YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SIX IS THAT REALLY A CULTURE.
THAT'S VERY PROBLEMATIC
ABSOLUTE TOP TO BOTTOM EIGHT
EIGHT WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
SOUNDS LIKE. A BOARD THAT IS.
NOT FULLY DETERMINED TO YOU
KNOW REMEDY THE WRONGS THAT AND
IT IS YOU DESCRIBE THIS ISN'T A
GREGIS PROBLEM I MEAN THIS THIS
REACHES I BELIEVE CRIMINAL
LEVELS OF- FRIED. AND YET WE
HAVE NOT SEEN IT DOES NOT SOUND
LIKE YOU'RE DESCRIBING A WHOLE
HEARTED EFFORT TO CHANGE THE
CULTURE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS AND MAKE SURE THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN AGAIN IS THAT. IS THAT
SOUND RIGHT TO YOU. WELL I KNOW
THAT- B. R. AND IN THEIR IN
THEIR RESPONSE THEY DID OF THE
THREE EXECUTIVES THAT REALLY.
KIND OF MASTERMIND THIS CLAN TO
REALLY DECEIVE US BY
MANIPULATING DATA. YEAH THEY
DID. THEY DID DISMISS TWO OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES AND ONE HAD
ALREADY LEFT- ONE THING I COULD
PROBABLY DO RIGHT NOW IS. IS
BASICALLY DIFFERENT THIS OVER
TO YOU MR TRUMP. SHE WAS THE-
MANAGER THAT WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE INVESTIGATION AND SHE
MAY BE ABLE TO PROVIDE. A
LITTLE MORE COMMENTS ON ON
BILLBOARDS- REACTION TO THE
FINDINGS OF THE INVESTIGATION.
CNN TRONG THE BY AND THE CHIEF
OF INVESTIGATIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. AND TO FOLLOW UP MISTER
CHILDREN SAID- AND TO ANSWER-
THE QUESTION AT HAND IS THAT-
WE DO NOT CONSIDER IT AT THE
TIME A CRIMINAL MATTER- BECAUSE
OF THE TYPE OF DATA THAT WAS
TURNED OVER TO US. SO WE DIDN'T
LOOK AT IT FROM A CRIMINAL
PERSPECTIVE- THAT'S SOMETHING
OBVIOUSLY THAT WE- COULD
CONSIDER AT ANY TIME DURING THE
COURSE OF THE INVESTIGATION-
BUT BECAUSE OF THE SPECIFICS OF
THE INVESTIGATION WE DID NOT
FEEL THAT IT WAS A CRIMINAL
MATTER AT THE TIME THAT WE WERE
CONDUCTING THE INVESTIGATION.
BUT I GUESS YOU KNOW ASIDE FROM
WHETHER OR NOT A CRIMINAL
SANCTIONS ARE PROBABLY I GUESS
I GUESS THE QUESTION. IS DO YOU
FEEL LIKE THERE IS A CULTURAL
PROBLEM. WITH THE B. R. AND-
AND DO YOU ALSO IS THAT AS A
FOLLOW UP FEEL LIKE THE BOARD
IS. ACTING DILIGENTLY AND
AGGRESSIVELY TO ROOT OUT THE
CAUSES OF THIS TYPE OF PROBLEMS
AND IT NEVER HAPPENS AGAIN.
BECAUSE I GUESS MY ANALOG HERE
MIGHT SORT REFERENCE POINT. IS
DID THIS HAPPEN IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR WE WOULD BE REPLACING
THE ENTIRE BOARD WE WILL BE
LOOKING TO- YOU KNOW TURN
EVERYTHING OVER AND I GUESS
WHAT I'M NOT CLEAR ON ITIS. DO
YOU FEEL LIKE THAT IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW. THAT THERE'S AN
AGGRESSIVE ATTEMPT TO CHANGE
THE CULTURE SO THAT THIS TYPE
OF BOB MISREPRESENTATION. I IN
THIS GROSS. NON COMPLIANCE WITH
THE LAW DOESN'T HAPPEN. I
BELIEVE THAT B. R. ENNIS
TAKING. EFFECTIVE STEPS TO
ENSURE THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN. BUT I
DON'T THINK OF THAT I. HAVE
SUFFICIENT INFORMATION TO SAY
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE MAKING.
A CONCERTED EFFORTS THROUGHOUT
THE BOARD- TO CHANGE. THE
CULTURE AT THE BOARD- I DO
UNDERSTAND YOUR REFERENCE TO A
PRIVATE PRACTICE- BUT I DO KNOW
THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN LEGAL.
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT MIGHT
HINDER- B. R. ENDS TO. TAKE
APPROPRIATE ACTION- AT AS
TIMELY AS YOU MIGHT SEE IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
CENTER MEANT- BEFORE I GO TO
DOCTOR PAN WHO WILL BE NEXT
I'VE I WAS JUST STRUCK BY A
SENTENCE IN THE YARD REPORT ON
PAGE THIRTY ONE. ON THE ISSUE
OF. APPROVAL VERSUS
ACCREDITATION IN COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE STATE APPROVAL
AUTHORTIES AND- THE CREDITORS
AND THE STATEMENT IS. WE ARE IN
THE SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT IT
WILL NOT ACCEPT REPORTS
PREPARED FOR ACCREDITING
BODIES. MR UNDER WERE YOU ABLE
TO DETERMINE THE RATIONALE FOR
THAT. YEAH WE DON'T WE REALLY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
PERSPECTIVE- TO THE EXTENT THAT.
THAT B. B. R. ANY IN THEIR
OVERSIGHT FUNCTION IS ASKING
FOR CERTAIN SUPPORT IN CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS AND YOU HAVE A
CREDITORS THAT ARE ASKING FOR
THE SAME INFORMATION IT MADE NO
SENSE TO US Y. A. B. R. AND
WOULD NOT ACCEPT DOCUMENTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED TO YOUR CREDITORS
BECAUSE THERE. IS SAME
DOCUMENTS AS I SAID EARLIER IN
MANY CASES THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE CREDITORS AND THE BOARD ARE
BASICALLY CHECKING IN THEIR
OVERSIGHT FUNCTIONS ARE THE
SAME. OKAY WELL THAT'S SORT OF
WHAT I THOUGHT THANK YOU MISTER
UNDER DOCTOR PAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUDITOR SO MUCH FOR THEIR
PRESENTATION- I'VE TO-
HOPEFULLY BRIEF QUESTIONS UP
FIRST IS TO CLARIFY WHAT WAS
SUPERIOR TO TIME IN WHICH- THE
SAKE TELL ME THE STATE'S ONLY
TO EXPECT THAT THE STAFF
ACTUALLY- J. SYMPHONY DELETED
THE CASE DATA WHAT'S SO YOU'RE
DOING THE AUDIT SO. BETWEEN
WHICH DATE TO WHICH DATE MONTH
AND YEAR I DON'T NEED TO GET
HAPPENED WHAT THROUGH THE TIME.
SO THE AUDIT NGUYEN OUTS IN-
THE AUDIT WHEN ALEXANDER JULY
I'M SORRY. THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND-
B. R. AND DIDN'T COME BACK TO
US TO SAY THEY HAD FULLY
IMPLEMENTED THIS AND STILL- TO
THAT THIS IS A NO I'M ACTUALLY
TALKING ABOUT THE AUDIT WHERE
YOU SHOWED THAT THEY MANIPULATE
THE KEY STATES THAT THE
EXECUTIVE STATE THE DATA SO
ESSENTIALLY ARE TRYING TO
MANIPULATE THE DATA SO THAT
TOOK PLACE AT WHICH- WHICH
WHICH YEAR. AT THE LAST. SO
THEY THEY PROVIDED THE REPORT
AND BASICALLY THE FALL OUT OF
FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. YEAH BUT
WE DIDN'T HEAR FROM THE ONE
THAT WHISTLEBLOWER. IN TILL THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY TWENTY SO
THERE WAS ABOUT A FOURTEEN
MONTH LAG BETWEEN THE TIME
THAT. B. R. AND- MANIPULATED
THE DATA TO PROVIDE THE
FALSIFIED REPORT AND THEN IT
WAS LIKE. TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
MONTHS LATER. THEIR
WHISTLEBLOWER CAME OUT AND
REYES THE ALLEGATION OKAY SO
THAT THE SERVICE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN. THIS
MANIPULATION TOOK PLACE. AT
OKAY THANK YOU AND THEN THE
SECOND QUESTION IS THAT- NOT
REALLY TO THIS BUT- I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU TOOK A LOOK
AT THE CLINICAL SITES I THINK
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT- SAYING
THAT YOU LOOKED AT. ALTHOUGH AS
A SOMEONE WHO'S A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL EDUCATOR MYSELF
THAT'S A DEAL CLINICAL SITES. I
KNOW YOU LOOK AT OSHKOSH DATA
WAS THERE ANY EFFORT ATTEMPTS
MADE AND I KNOW FOR A ON THE
HARD TO DO. TO EVALUATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF VARIOUS SITES TO
ACTUALLY ACCEPTS TRAINEES
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY WE CAN LOOK
AT HOW MANY LICENSED CLINICAL
SITE- LET'S SEE. HOW MANY
LICENSED- HELPER. SITES TO ARE
TRACKED CYCLE SAFETY BUT THEY
MAY NOT ALL WANT TO HAVE A
NURSE TRAINEE SO. THAT MAY ALSO
AFFECT SO. DID YOU JUST LOOK AT
THE OXFORD DATA OR DID YOU WAS
THERE ANY ATTEMPT TO TRY TO
ABOUT TAKE A LOOK AT. EITHER
THE WILLINGNESS OR THE
EXISTING- OR THE DEGREE TO
WHICH OFFICIALLY BE ACTUALLY
WILLING TO TAKE ON A NURSE
TRAINEE AS A CLINICAL TRAINING
SITES. WE KNOWLEDGE CENTER
REPORT THAT- EVEN THOUGH WE DID
IN THE BAY AREA IDENTIFY. A
LARGE NUMBER OF- FACILITIES
THAT WERE NOT BEING USE WEEK WE
DO ACKNOWLEDGE IN OUR RECORDS
THAT IT COULD BE THAT MANY OF
THOSE- FACILITIES THEY DON'T
WANT TO PARTICIPATE THEY DON'T
WANT TO OFFER CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS WHAT'S THE NURSING
PROGRAM STUDENTS WHERE THEY-DON'T HAVE THE STAFFING TO DO
IT THERE COULD BE A NUMBER OF
REASONS. AND CERTAINLY THE
BOARD BROUGHT THAT UP I MEAN
THEY AGREED THAT YES WE
IDENTIFIED A LARGE NUMBER OF
FACILITIES AND IN ONE AREA THE
AREA. THAT WE'RE NOT BEING
TAPPED. BUT THEY MADE THE SAME
CASE THAT NOT ALL OF THOSE
UNUSED FACILITIES WOULD BE
WILLING TO PARTICIPATE OR WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY OUR POINT WAS
JUST BECAUSE WE IDENTIFIED JUST
MISS ONE REGION SO MANY
FACILITIES THAT WERE NOT BEING
USED. WE THINK IT'S AT LEAST
WORTH WHILE FOR B. R. AND TO
WORK WITH THE NURSING PROGRAMS
AND GO THROUGH THIS COMPARISON
AND IDENTIFY THESE FACILITIES
IN CALIFORNIA THAT AREN'T BEING
USED AND REACH OUT TO SOME OF
THEM HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS. TO
SEE IF THERE ARE SOME
FACILITIES OUT THERE THAT ARE
NOT BEING USED THAT WOULD BE
AMENABLE TO OFFERING TOP
CLINICAL EXPERIENCE IN NURSING
PROGRAM STUDENTS ARE NOT
APPRECIATE THAT I THINK THAT
CERTAINLY I THINK YOU'RE
FINDING THAT THE BOARD HAS NOT
REALLY BEEN CONSIDERING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE- WE
DON'T WANT TO DO IS A PROOF-
TRAINING PROGRAMS FOR THE
PEOPLE CASH ACTUALLY CAN'T
COMPLETE THEIR TRAINING BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A CLINICAL
SITES. SO THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
NOT LOOKING AT THAT AND
APPROVALS IS VERY PROBLEM IS
VERY TROUBLESOME TO ME BECAUSE
I DON'T WANT DON'T WANT TWENTY
STOCK THE SAME TIME I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND. THAT UNFORTUNATELY
MANY HEALTHCARE FACILITIES NO
LONGER WANT TREES BECAUSE THEY
COST MONEY I MEAN IT THE EVEN
IF YOU DON'T TO PAY FOR THE
TRAINEES THAT THAT THE OVERHEAD
TIME FOR TEACHING AND- IT'S AT-
ENDS AND IN FACT- THAT'S A
CHRONIC PROBLEM NOT ONLY
NURSING BUT ACROSS THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS WHERE DOES FEELING
FEWER. HEALTH FACILITIES
WILLING TO TAKE ON TRAINEES
BECAUSE OF. THE EXPENSE AND
DAHLE CERTAIN OF SIDE KNOW
DESTROY. THAT CAN HAPPEN WITH A
TREE NEED. ANY OTHER SKILL
LEVEL CETERA. AND- SO THAT'S A-
FROM BUT CERTAINLY AGREETHAT
THE BOARD. SHOULD THE CERTAINLY
EVALUATE THAT BECAUSE NOTHING
ELSE WE WANNA BE SURE A TRAINEE
IS ABLE ACTUALLY COMPLETE THEIR
TRAINING THEY CAN'T GET A
CLINICAL SITES AND- WORKED AT
THEM THAT'S- THE DISADVANTAGE
OF THAT STUDENTS OF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT INFORMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU A DOCTRINE
MR TOLD JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON
THAT I MEAN. DIDN'T YOU AND
YOUR IN THE COURSE OF YOUR
AUDIT. FIND IN DETERMINE THAT
THE BOARD WAS NOT. UTILIZING
THE DATA THAT IS. IT HAD
COLLECTED CAN TO PERIODICALLY
pHIS OF THE PROCESS EITHER FOR
THE APPLE OF A NEW PROGRAM. OR
FOR THE EXPRESS OF THE PRO HAVE
TO DO WITH CLINICAL SLOTS IN
THE AVAILABILITY OF. CLINICAL
**** IN PARTICULAR REGIONS OF
THE STATE. THAT'S CORRECT
MISTER CHAIRMAN IN ORDER FOR
THE BOARD TO EVEN. DO A
COMPARISON OF THE EXTENT TO
WHICH- FACILITIES ARE CURRENTLY
BEING USED BY NURSING PROGRAMS.
VERSUS THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
POTENTIAL FACILITIES. THEY
FIRST HAVE TO HAVE A HANDLE ON
WHAT FACILITIES ARE CURRENTLY
BEING USED ACROSS THE STATE BY
THE START STATE'S NURSING
PROGRAMS. AND THEY NEED DATA ON
HOW MANY SLOTS ARE BEING USED.
VERSUS HOW MANY SLOTS TO THE
NURSING PROGRAMS NEED SO WE CAN
MINIMIZE THIS RISK OF STUDENTS
BEING DISPLACED. BUT AS YOU BUT
AS YOU SAID RIGHT NOW THE BOARD
DOESN'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION
SO THEY DON'T EVEN HAVE A
HANDLE RIGHT NOW ON THE EXTENT
TO WHICH- NURSING PROGRAMS ARE
USING FACILITIES AND WHICH ONES
THEY'RE USING. AND THAT'S HAS
TO HAPPEN BEFORE THEY CAN
COMPARE IT TO THE ENTIRE
UNIVERSE OF FACILITIES IN THE
STATE. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
FOR YOUR RESPONSES. COLLEAGUES
ON THE SENATE FLOOR ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. O. K.
SAYING NONE OF CALLING SEWER
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SENATORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS BEFORE WE. CONCLUDE
WITH MR TILTON. I DO NOT SEE
ANY REYES STANDS IF I'M READING
MY COMPUTER CORRECTLY SO MR
TOLD  WANT TO THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH US
TODAY APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD
WORK THAT YOU AND YOUR-
COLLEAGUES AT THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE- HAVE ADVANCED
TO INFORM OUR. DISCUSSIONS AND
DECISIONS IN THIS JOINT
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISS
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU. WE ARE
NOW A TO- HERE FROM THE READ
NURSE I THAT THE RED OF MEL B.
THE BOARD EXECUTIVE OFFICERS
WITH THIS- WE WERE GOING TO
HEAR FROM THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. BOARD VICE
PRESIDENT KEN MARLBORO I'M NOT
CERTAIN HE WILL BE WITH US
PARTICIPATING TODAY SO WHY
DON'T WE TURN IT OVER TO THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING TO
FIND OUT. WHO WILL BE
PARTICIPATING. THANK YOU I AM
ALREADY NOBODY ALSO KNOWN AS
LAURIE I AM THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER FOR THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. AND I WILL
BE THE ONE. THAT WILL BE
ANSWERING AS MANY QUESTIONS AS
POSSIBLE TODAY FOR YOU- I DID
RECEIVE. THE PHONE CALL- THIS
MORNING LETTING ME KNOW THAT-
OUR BOARD VICE PRESIDENT KEN
MORROW IS UNABLE TO BE HERE
TODAY- AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE HIS OPENING STATEMENT. ON
HIS BEHALF IF THAT IS OKAY WITH
YOU GUYS THAT'S CERTAINLY
ACCEPTABLE BUT I HAVE TO
COMMENT- I DON'T SPEAK FOR MY
FUTURE LOW ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE
BUT- IT'S RATHER UNUSUAL NOT TO
HAVE A MEMBER OF THE BOARD
PRESENT AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THAT A BOARD MEMBER
MIGHT HAVE A- ANOTHER ISSUE
THAT. PRECLUDES HIS OR HER OR
THEIR ATTENDANCE BUT I WOULD
CERTAINLY HAVE EXPECTED SOMEONE
ELSE TO FILL IN. IN THAT BOARD
MEMBERS PLACE BUT- MISS MEL B.
SINCE YOU'RE HERE WITH US. IN
YOUR IN THE HOT SEAT PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU YEAH- SO
GOOD MORNING TERROR OFTEN SHARE
LOW IN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEES WE THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO COME BEFORE
YOU TO SPEAK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING. AS I SAID IN MY
STATEMENT JUST A MINUTE AGO MY
NAME IS LORETTA MELBY AND I AM
THE BOARD'S EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME I WILL
BRIEFLY HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
BOARDS KEY ACCOMPLISHMENTS. WE
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITIONED TO A
TELEWORK ENVIRONMENTS IN
RESPONSE TO THE CO IN EIGHTEEN
PANDEMIC. I CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH STAFF TO IMPLEMENT
RECOMMENDATIONS TO IMPROVE OUR
EFFICIENCIES AND EFFECTIVENESS
IN THE NEW TELEWORK
ENVIRONMENTS. WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE STRIDES IN THE RECRUITMENT
AND RETENTION EFFORTS OF STAFF
INCLUDING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE POSITIONS THAT STAFF OR NEW
OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS.
WE IDENTIFIED IN IMPLEMENTED
CONTINUOUS QUALITY IMPROVEMENT
STRATEGIES TO REDUCE LICENSING
PROCESSING TIMELINES AND
ENHANCE OUR STATUTORY MANDATE
ACTIVITIES INVOLVING NURSING
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA. WE FOR
THE THIRD OF SUCCESS TOWARDS
THE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION'S
EFFORTS OF AUTOMATION. WE
LAUNCH THE EFFORTS TO
CENTRALIZE ADMINISTRATIVE
FUNCTIONS INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO CONTRACTS. FLEET
MANAGEMENT BUDGETS AND
CORRESPONDENCE. WE ENHANCED OUR
COMMUNICATION AND STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENTS THREE STEPS- SUCH
AS THE BEER AND NEWSLETTER.
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE
GOVERNMENTAL AND ENTITIES AND
PARTICIPATION IN TRAINING AND
CONFERENCES. WILL CONTINUE TO
FOCUS ON REDUCINGUNNECESSARY
BARRIERS TO LICENSE SURE
STREAMLINING OF OUR PROCESS
SEES AND PROVIDING BETTER
CUSTOMER SERVICE TO OUR
LICENSEES AND CONSUMERS. AS THE
BEER AND LOOKS TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE WE'RE EXCITED TO FIND NEW
WAYS TO WORK. CREATING A
CULTURE OF TRANSPARENCY IN
SOLIDARITY STRENGTHENING OUR
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR INTERNAL
AND EXTERNAL STAKEHOLDERS.
BUILDING A SUSTAINABLE
FOUNDATION FOR PROVIDING
EXCEPTIONAL CUSTOMER SERVICE
AND ENSURING FAIR REGULATORY
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS. I AM HAPPY.
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS
TIME. WELL- FOR YOU MAY AS WELL
BE LET ME AS OF. COUPLE OF.
CORE QUESTIONS BEFORE I TURN IT
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES CHAIR LOW
ON MY COLLEAGUES FOR MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS YOU I'M SURE
YOU HEARD SOME OF MY INITIAL
QUESTIONS OF THE- STATE AUDITOR
AND- I'M GOING TO ASK THEM OF
YOU WITH RESPECT TO CONTRACT
DELAYS OF. IT IS NOT UNUSUAL AS
I'M SURE YOU REALIZE IN THIS
BOARD ENVIRONMENT FOR BOARDS TO
HAVE DIFFICULTY. MEETING
ENFORCEMENT TARGETS IN THIS PM
FOR. OF THIS PERFORMANCE A
METRIC THAT THE DCA IS COME UP
WITH- THIS BOARD PEERS TO BE NO
EXCEPTION. DO YOU AGREE WITH
THE AUDITOR'S COMMENT THAT THE-
REASON FOR THE FAILURE TO MEET
THE TARGET LARGELY IS THE
RESULT OF THE R. ENDS IN ACTION
WITH RESPECT TO THE PROCESSING
OF FORMAL COMPLAINTS THE FIVE
HAVEN'T PUT WORDS IN HIS MOUTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR OFF- I THINK
THAT IS A TWO FOLD ANSWER AND
SO AT THE TIME OF THE AUDIT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN YES I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT- WHAT WAS FOUND. ON
THE AUDIT WAS ACCURATE AND IT
WAS A PROBLEM THAT OUR BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING- WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR- THAT HAS
CHANGED EAST- WE DID SUBMIT
EVIDENCE THAT- WE ARE IMPROVING
OUR TIMELINES- WE ARE NOW TO
TWENTY MONTHS AND THE GOAL IS
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. SO WE'VE MADE
QUITE A BIT OF PROGRESS IN THAT
TOO- CLOSING OUT THE CASES IN
THAT TIME LINE. AND I THINK AS
WITH ALL OF THE OTHER BOARD
CENTER AND THEY'RE HAVING
DIFFICULTY MEETING THAT THAT
COLLABORATIVELY STREAMLINE
BINDING ACROSS THE SEAS AND
REALLY DOING SOME DEEP DIVES
TRYING TO FIND OUT WHERE THE
HOLD UPS ARE- CAN BRING US TO
AND THE OTHER BOARDS AND
BUREAUS TO THAT EIGHTEEN MONTHS
TIMELINE- SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE DO COME ACROSS THIS
RECORD ATTAINMENTS- IN GETTING
THEIR APPROPRIATE RECORDS. IN
ORDER TO DO THAT AND THAT
DOESN'T JUST STOP WITH US THAT
DOES HAPPEN WITH- DAY DEAR BYE-
AG'S AND OTHERS- WHAT WOULD
HELP US. IS TO- GET A SWORN
LIMITED PEACE OFFICER STATUS
FOR OUR- SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS
THAT WOULD ALLOW THEM TO GET
SOME DOCUMENTS A LOT FASTER-
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
OUR PROCESSES RECEIVE MONEY AND
WE'RE MAKING. GREAT STRIDES
WHAT. WHAT TWO THINGS ONE CAN
GO. THANK YOU FOR IT. BUT TO
MAY HAVE HEARD ME SUGGEST TO
OTHER BOARDS ON THIS PARTICULAR
ISSUE THAT I THINK IT THE DCA
AND THE BOARDS NEED TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO SPLIT UP. AT FIRST I
TO HAVE INTO IT IN TIME TARGETS
WITHIN PM FOR. AND BE ABLE TO
SPLIT UP THE TIME AND EXPLAIN
THE DELAY. BETWEEN THE BOARD
THE DCA IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SO IF IT'S SOMETHING OTHER THAN
DELAY AT THE BOARD LEVEL WE CAN
FIGURE OUT HOW TO FOCUS ON IT
AND HELP YOU FIX IT. SO YOU IS
A BORDER NOT. A TARGETED AND
TAGGED WITH THE COMPLETE.
RESPONSIBILITY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR DELAY THAT
MAY NOT BE TOTALLY WITHIN YOUR
CONTROL SECONDLY WOULD YOU
EXPLAIN TO ME THIS NEED FOR. A
PEACE OFFICER STATUS WHAT
DOCUMENTS TYPICALLY DO YOU TRY
TO OBTAIN AND DOESN'T
NECESSARILY REQUIRE A PEACE
OFFICER WITH ALL THAT GOES
ALONG WITH. PEACE OFFICER
STATUS COMPENSATION BENEFITS
TRAINING AND ALL THE REST.
INSIDE A NON. TRADITIONAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. YEAH I
AGAIN- SENATOR UP I WILL GO
AHEAD AND- TRY TO ANSWER THAT
IT WAS A COUPLE DIFFERENT
QUESTIONS SO- I MAY HAVE YOU-
REPEAT THE LAST QUESTION OR THE
FIRST QUESTION IF I IF I DON'T.
ANSWER THE QUESTION IS WHY WHY
PEACE OFFICERS INSIDE THE
BORDER REGISTERED NURSING TO
GET INFORMATION. YES SO RIGHT
NOW WE DO SEE- THAT WE HAVE
DELAYS IN RECEIVING CERTIFIED
COURT DOCUMENTS URESTI
CONVICTION RECORDS THAT
INCREASES THE COST AND
DECREASES EFFICIENCIES AND-
WITH THAT WE MIGHT GET NO
RESPONSE- FROM OBTAINING
DOCUMENTS INCLUDING CONSENT TO
RELEASE MEDICAL RECORDS- SO
WITH THAT STATUS- AND IT'S A
LIMITED PEACE OFFICER STATUS I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WAS
WHERE IT DOESN'T CHANGE SALARY.
AND IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
BENEFITS- SO IT IS NO
ADDITIONAL COST- IN WITH THAT-
LIMITED SWORN PEACE OFFICER
STATUS- IT DOES IMPLORE- THOSE
AGENCIES TO RESPOND A LITTLE
MORE EFFICIENTLY. THANK YOU MY
COLLEAGUES MAY HAVE MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS ON THAT AND
IF THEY DON'T WILL HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO EXPLORE THAT
A LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL UP
OUTSIDE OF THE SETTING. YOU YOU
YOU HEARD MY QUESTIONS ON THE
SUPPLY ISSUE AND THE SURVEYS
AND WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON
TRYING TO. FIGURE OUT AND THEN
DEBATE WHETHER THERE IS A
SHORTAGE OR AN OVERSUPPLY. OF
NURSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND YOU HEARD MY
QUESTION TO THE AUDITOR I
BELIEVE YOU KNOW BEYOND
ENSURING. PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY THE BOARD ENSURING
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY WITH
RESPECT TO THE NURSING
PRACTICE. AND TRYING TO
PREVENT. A SHORTAGE OF NURSES
IN THE STATE. WHICH OF COURSE
IMPACTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHAT'S THE PURPOSE IN
THE BOARD APPARENTLY TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NOT A
SURPLUS OF NURSES. IN THE STATE
AS PART OF THE APPROVAL OF NEW
PROGRAMS EXPANSION OF EXISTING
PROGRAMS. A DEBATE. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION IS THAT A
CLEAR QUESTION. IT IS IT
DEFINITELY HAS THANK YOU-
ACTUALLY WANT TO KIND OF A-
ANSWERED THAT- BY SAYING THAT
I'M NOT AWARE THAT THE BOARD IS
TRYING TO LIMIT A SURPLUS-
THAT'S NOT ANYTHING MY
UNDERSTANDING I'M AN ARE IN
MYSELF- AND I'VE BEEN ARE IN
FOR TWENTY YEARS I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS A GOAL THAT- MY
BOARD HAS- I CAN DEFINITELY
SPEAK THAT THAT'S NOT A GOAL
THAT MY BOARD STAFF HAS. LATER
ACTUALLY SHARE. THE REPRESENT.
BRING WHAT I'VE READ I
UNDERSTOOD THAT TO BE A FACTOR.
IN THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
NOT IN A SURPLUS IN NURSING BUT
WHEN LOOKING AT CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT- IF YOU HAVE TOO
MANY STUDENTS IN ONE
CONCENTRATED AREA IT DOES
AFFECT THE HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES AND THEIR ABILITY TO
FUNCTION AND ACCOMMODATE THE
STUDENTS AND IT ALSO AFFECTS
THE ABILITY OF ALL OF THE
STUDENTS TO PROGRESS IN
GRADUATE. AND I GET TO MY
QUESTION ON THAT THE SECOND BUT
IT WAS ALL IT'S BEEN ADDRESSED
IN THE MATERIAL IS SORT OF TWO
SEPARATE ISSUES THAT ARE
CONSIDERED- DURING THE DECISION
MAKING PROCESS I UNDERSTAND
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS. I
UNDERSTAND. SHORTAGE BUT NOT
SOMETHING THAT GOES BEYOND
SHORTAGE OKAY I'LL MOVE ON
BECAUSE I WANT MY COLLEAGUES TO
HAVE PLENTY OF TIME TO ASK MORE
DETAILED QUESTIONS WITH RESPECT
TO THIS CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ISSUE WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE TO
THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
WHERE WHEN THEY LOOKED AT THE
SIXTEEN PROGRAMS IN THE BAY
AREA- 82% OF THE ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL SLOTS FOR USE BUT ONLY
TEN PERCENT. OF THE CLINIC NOT
CLINICAL BUT CLINIC SLOTS WERE
USED. IS IT PROVE THAT. CLINIC
SLOTS GO UNUSED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH RESPECT TO
CLINICAL PLACEMENT OF NURSING
TRAINEES. YES THAT IS TRUE
THERE ARE MANY MANY CLINICS AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE FACILITIES
THAT ARE NOT USED FOR- CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE SPECIFICALLY RELATED
TO THE REGISTERED NURSING
STUDENT- THE GOAL FOR PREPARING
A REGISTERED NURSING STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA IS TO PROPERLY EQUIP
THEM WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND THE
REQUISITE SKILLS TO BE A SAFE
PRACTICING OUR AND- THAT
REQUIREMENTS- IS AIDED BY THAT
DIRECT PATIENT CARE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE. MOST- LET ME
CORRECT THAT MANY CLINICS- MAY
NOT EMPLOY IN OUR AT- MAY NOT
HAVE THOSE KIND OF EXPERIENCES
AVAILABLE FOR AN HOUR AND A LOT
OF- PHYSICIAN CLINICS HAVE
MEDICAL ASSISTANCE- SOME
EMPLOYEE- A LICENSED VOCATIONAL
NURSE BUT RARELY DO THEY EMPLOY
A SPECIFIC R. AND FOR- ARE IN
SKILL AND KNOWLEDGE ATTAINMENT.
THEREFORE A CLINIC THERE'S MANY
REASONS THAT CLINIC MAY NOT BE
YEARS IT COULD BE THAT- THERE
WOULD NOT BE APPROPRIATE ARE AN
OVERSIGHT THAT- THE CLINIC IT
MAY NOT. BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
APPROPRIATE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES THE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCES ARE SET FORTH BY
THE ACADEMIC INSTITUTION WHEN
THEY WRITE THEIR GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES FOR THE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE FOR THEIR STUDENTS-
AND THEN IT JUST MAY BE THE
INABILITY OF THE THAT CLINIC TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT I WAS-
MENTIONED EARLIER- BY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS HERE. THAT SOME
CLINICS MAY NOT BE WILLING TO
DO THAT- THERE IS A SUPPLY
ISSUE WE DID SEE THAT EXPRESSED
WITH COOPERATE WITH GETTING
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
PPE ESE- AND THAT- TYPICALLY
COMES FROM THAT INSTITUTION
THAT IS PROVIDING THE CLINICAL
EXPERIENCE AND SO- DO YOU TO
THE ORIENTATION THAT HAS TO BE
PROVIDED AT THE TIME AWAY FROM
STAFF AND PRODUCTIVITY. THE
INCREASED ADEQUATE MAKE YOU
STANDS- AND NOW SPACE WITH THE
SOCIAL DISTANCING- IT HAS BEEN
VERY DIFFICULT FOR ACADEMIC
PARTNERS TO OBTAIN CLINICAL.
FACILITIES FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
WELL I WOULD HAVE THAT YOU
AGREE THE- DEMAND FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. THE REGARDLESS OF
THESE STUDIES THAT I SEE- AT
LEAST IN SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE WILL CONTINUE- AND THE
SHORTAGE OF. HOSPITAL ****
PAROLEE. PROBABLY MORE SO IN
THE FUTURE. I THINK THE BEER IN
TO TAKE A CLOSER LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE CLINICS SETTINGS TO
SEE WHAT REALLY IS THE STORY.
WHAT TRULY IS APPROPRIATE AND
INAPPROPRIATE IN TERMS OF UGH
CLINICAL SLOT. CLINIC SLOTS
USAGE. THEN TRY TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO EXPAND THE OPPORTUNITIES
IN THESE CLINICS WHETHER THEIR
URGENT CARE CLINICS OR OTHER-
CLINICS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE MAKE SURE THAT
WE PROVIDE. AS MANY TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES AS WE CAN FOR OUR
NURSING STUDENTS NOW I REALIZE
AND RECOGNIZE IT GIVEN THE
SUBJECTS THAT. NURSE NURSE
STUDENTS MISSING STUDENTS HAVE
TO TRAIN IN THAT SOME NEED TO
BE DONE SOME TRAINING NEEDS TO
BE DONE ABSOLUTELY IN THE
HOSPITAL'S PERHAPS MUCH OF IT
BUT THERE IS PROBABLY SOME OF
IT THAT CAN BE DONE. ELSEWHERE
LET ME TURN BRIEFLY BEFORE I
PUT MY COLLEAGUES TO SLEEP TO.
LICENSE RECIPROCITY THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT IS NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO. MILITARY OF FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO- TRANSFER INTO THIS
STATE WITH THEIR- MILITARY
MEMBER SPOUSE. FULLY LICENSED-
CERTIFICATED DEPENDING ON THE
OCCUPATION WITH. APPROPRIATE
TRAINING LICENSURE AND
EXPERIENCE IN OTHER STATES. BUT
ONE OF THE ISSUES IN OUR
BACKGROUND PAPER. NOTES THAT
THE RECIPROCITY PROCESS. CAN BE
LENGTHY. HOW LENGTHY IS THE
RECIPROCITY PROCESS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND IF IT IS WHY. I
HAVE SOME CLARIFYING QUESTIONS-
IF YOU DON'T MIND IS THAT OKAY
CERTAINLY. SO I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHAT YOU MEAN BY
RECIPROCITY WE HAD TO BUSINESS
PROCESS SEES AND ONE OF THEM IS
CALLED ENDORSEMENTS AND THAT
IS- WHERE OKAY OKAY GOOD SO IS
THAT THE ONE THAT YOU WANT
SPECIFICALLY ASKED ABOUT-
HAVING OUT OF STATE OURENSE
COMING INTO CALIFORNIA ROAD
RUNNER. YOU CALLED ENDORSEMENT
IN A LOT OF BUSINESS WE CALLED
RECIPROCITY YOU AT LEAST HAVE
ENDORSEMENT WE'VE GOT NONE OF
THAT IN THE LAW BUSINESS BUT
WHAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
I'LL BE EVEN CLEARER. IN THE
CASE OF NURSES WERE A NURSE
COMPLETES A TRAINING PROGRAM
TAKES A NATIONAL EXAM PASSES
THE TRAINING PROGRAM IS
LICENSED IN ANOTHER STATE AND
PRACTICES SUCCESSFULLY IN
ANOTHER STATE. PRESUMABLY
WITHOUT DISCIPLINARY ACTION
WITH A CLEAN RECORD INCOMES TO
CALIFORNIA WHY DOES IT TAKE ANY
LENGTH OF TIME AT ALL IN TERMS
OF PUTTING THAT NURSE TO WORK.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
CAN SPEAK TO THAT- A LOT OF
THAT LATE THE TIME COMES FROM
THE FINGERPRINT CHECKS THAT ARE
DONE TO DOJ- ARE OUT OF STATE
NURSES THAT DO NOT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. CANNOT COMPLETE THE
LIVE SCAN FINGERPRINTING
PROCESS AND THEY HAVE TO SUBMIT
WHAT IS CALLED A HARD CARD.
THAT HARD CARD IS REQUESTED BY
THE B. R. N. WEEKS MAIL IT OUT
TO THEM BECAUSE IT IS NOT
ELECTRONIC.WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THAT MAIL TO GET TO THEM THEY
THEN HAVE TO GO INCOMPLETE THAT
THE HARD CARD PROCESS ACTS
MAYBE THEIR LCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENT. AND THEN THEY HAVE
TO MAIL THAT AGAIN BACK INTO
US- THE DOJ STANDARDS THE LIVE
SCAN PROCESS WHICH IS A VERY
QUICK PROCESS CAN ONLY BE DONE
IF YOU WERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEREFORE THAT
DELAYS THAT TIME FRAME WHAT I
CAN'T SPEAK TO IS OUR
ENDORSEMENT PUBLICATIONS RIGHT
NOW OUR CURRENT- AS OF JANUARY-
WE ONLY HAVE THREE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE. PEOPLE WAITING TO
BE PROCESSED IN JANUARY AND WE
ARE WAITING FOR THOSE
FINGERPRINT RESULTS TO COME
BACK EACH MORNING WE PULL
REPORT TO SEE WHAT NEW
FINGERPRINT RESULTS HAVE CAME
IN. AND THEY IF THEY ARE CLEAR
THEY HAVE NO PRIOR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION ON THEIR LICENSE THEY
ARE THEN ISSUED AN ENDORSEMENT
APPLICATION IF THEY MEET OUR-
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS AS
WELL. AND IF NOT THEY ARE
ISSUED A TEMPORARY LICENSE SO
THAT THEY CAN IMMEDIATELY HELP-
OUR CALIFORNIA PATIENTS WHILE
THEY PROVIDE ANYDOCUMENTATION
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN MISSING. OR
NOT TURN THE IN TO PROVIDE
PROOF THAT THEY MEET OUR
EDUCATIONAL STANDARDS AS WELL
AND. HOW LONG DOES THAT PROCESS
TAKE. I'M AS I'M RIGHT NOW I WE
HAVE WE ARE PRO. IN JANUARY SO
WE ARE ABOUT A SIXTY DAY- AND
THAT IS CURRENT SO WE'RE WE'RE
PRESENT CURRENT AS OF TODAY
WITH ANYBODY THAT HAS A
FINGERPRINT RESULTS BACK- IN SO
AGAIN EACH MORNING WE DO PULL
REPORT. SOME DAYS WE RECEIVED A
HUNDRED FINGERPRINT- RESULTS
BACK AND THOSE HUNDRED PEOPLE
WILL BE PROCESSING GIVEN
LICENSE TODAY. THAT IS A
FINGERPRINT REQUIREMENT IS IT
SET THE SAME REQUIREMENT EVEN
THOUGH. THE NURSES LICENSE
LET'S SAY IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AND GEORGIA ALSO
REQUIRES A FINGERPRINT. FINGER
PRINTS THAT THE FINGERPRINT
CARD FINGERPRINT LIVE SCANNERS
OF THE CULT LIKE SCAN WHATEVER
THEY CALL IT BACK THERE- THAT
IS RUN THROUGH THE U. S. DOJ
AND THAT STATE TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE IS THE
SAME. FINGERPRINT RECORDED JAN
OF A NURSE COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA. IT IS- AND THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOR WHAT'S CALLED
RAP BACK AND WHAT OCCURS WITH
THAT IS ONCE YOU ESTABLISH
FINGERPRINTS WITH THE DOJ HERE
IN CALIFORNIA IT IS NOT A ONE
TIME SNAPSHOT IT DOES NOT JUST
SAY HEY YOU'RE CLEAR TODAY IT
ENSURES THAT ANY POSSIBLE
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT IS-
TENSELY DIçN. BY THAT LICENSE
FEE THAT WE'VE THAT WE ARE AND
WILL RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
IMMEDIATELY THEREFORE AND THE
IN THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC
PROTECTION IF ANY GREGIS
ACTIVITY DID OCCUR WE CAN
SUSPEND THAT LICENSE AS EARLY
AS THE NEXT DAY. IF THE IF THE
FINGER BROTHER WANT TO BELABOR
THIS BUT LET ME BELABORED FOR
SECOND IF THE FINGERPRINTS ARE
DIGITIZED IN GEORGIA. CAN'T
THOSE DIGIT THE FINGERPRINTS
DON'T CHANGE AT LEAST I GUESS
UNLESS YOU SEND THEM OFF. IF HE
CAN'T CALIFORNIA ACCESS THE
DIGITIZED PRINCE IN THE STATE
OF GEORGIA TO EXPEDITE THIS
pIS A DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE-
ISSUE AND THEIR REGULATION IS
THAT IT IS THE CALIFORNIA AND
IT WILL GO TO ONE AGENCY- SO AS
AN EXAMPLE I HAVE A LIVE SCAN
AS AN R&D WHERE- MY RECORDS
WILL GO TO THE B. R. N. AS A
LICENSEE I ACTUALLY HAD TO LIVE
STAND AGAIN AS AN EMPLOYEE.
BECAUSE THEN IT WOULD GO TO THE
B. R. A. AS IN AGENCIES SO- I
HAVE BEEN EMPLOYED IN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT REALMS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE- AS AN R&D AND I HAVE TO
GET LICENSE EACH INDIVIDUAL
TIME BECAUSE IT DOES GO TO ONE
PERSON AND THAT IS- A DOJ
PROCESS I SEE SO IT'S A STATE.
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ISSUE. YES AT THE STATE AGENCY
YOUR CREDIT THAT FINGERPRINT
PROCESS WITH GOING TO ONE
AGENCY AND MEETING NEW
FINGERPRINTS TO COMING TO
CALIFORNIA THAT IS A PROCESS WE
DO HAVE TO FOLLOW THAT IS
OUTLINED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE YOU SAY BUT THERE'S U.
S. DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT ITS
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYER. THANK
YOU OKAY COLLEAGUES I'M
FINISHED I APOLOGIZED- DOCTOR
PAN. I THANK THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH- AND- I WOULD MAKE NOTE
THAT THERE ARE THIRTY EIGHT
ISSUES NOW NOT ALL OF THEM ARE
NECESSARILY NEW PRODUCT THAT'S
A PROBLEM SOME. SO THERE'S
QUITE A LOT OF GROUND ON THAT
CONTRACT COVER ALL THIRTY
EIGHT- BUT THERE ARE THREE
MAJOR AREAS I DID WANT TO TOUCH
ON- FIRST OF ALL. ON ISSUE
NUMBER TWO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILLING RATE- I DID WANT TO
TOUCH ON THAT- THIS IS
SOMETHING I KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT EACH BOARD IS A COMES
THROUGH I DO WANNA MAKE NOTE
THAT WITH THE INCREASE IN.
HOURLY FEES- AND AGAIN THIS IS
A BACK OF THE NAPKIN TYPE
CALCULATION BUT FOR AN ATTORNEY
THAT WOULD REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY- FOUR HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND. AN ANNUAL
K. PREPARE LEGAL FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND ANNUAL PAY
AND FOR AN ANALYST FOUR HUNDRED
FIVE THOUSAND AND HEN YOU'LL
PAY ALL RIGHT- YET I ALSO KNOW
BECAUSE I'M SO USED TO CHAIR
PERS- I KNOW HOW TO LOOK UP
THESE- ACTUAL THE ACTUAL PAY SO
REFERRED TO DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL- LEVEL THREE- AT THE
TOP OF THE SCALE IS A HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND- THE TOP OF
THE PEACEFUL FOR LONG DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL LEVEL FIVE
WHICH IS THE TOP END IS A
1-006-900-0100 SIXTEEN- DOLLARS
A YEAR. AND A SUPERVISING
DEPUTY AG IS ACTUALLY A
1-007-700-0500 SIXTY FOUR OR SO
THAT MEANS WE HAVE AN OVERHEAD
RATE OF OVER A 100% PROBABLY
LIKE A HUNDRED TWENTY OR A 130%
AND THEN WE THINK ABOUT
ANALYSTS WHICH I SAID WAS
400-500-0600 FOR HOURLY RATE-
TO TYPE IN FOR A SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE LEGAL ANALYST IS
ONLY 810-002-0050 TWO SO
THEREFORE DEBTS AND OVER THREE
HUNDRED PERCENT. OVERHEAD RATE.
SO SO REALIZE THE FOR THE BOARD
OF NURSING I GUESS THE QUESTION
HERE IS THAT- GIVEN THE FACT
THAT YOU ARE COLLECTING FEES
FROM NURSES- HOW ARE YOU
DEALING WITH THE COST PRESSURES
RELATED TO. THESE TYPES OF FEES
WITH SUCH HIGH OVERHEAD RATES.
CURRENTLY WEEK WE HAVE SEEN AN
INCREASE THAT IS EXPECTED WE DO
HAVE PROCESSES IN PLACE WHERE
WE TREAT. ALL OF THE CASES THAT
COME IN AND SEE IF THEY EVEN
NEED TO BE ELEVATED TO THE
EIGHTY LEVEL SO WE MAY- RIGHT
AND FINE WE MAY EVALUATE
INTERNALLY WITH AND- SPEAK WITH
THE DC DAYS. DEPARTMENT OF
INVESTIGATIONS DIVISIONS OF
INVESTIGATIONS SORRY ABOUT
THAT- AND THEN ONLY CASES THAT
HAVE TO GO TO AG GO TODAY. IN
AN INCREASE IN OUR FOR YOUR
DEGREE THE NUMBER REFERRALS TO
DOJ STAFF THAN TO TRY TO LIMIT
COST. AS LONG AS THE. WHAT IT
HOLD THE CASE BACK IF IT WAS
NOT APPROPRIATE CARE BRIDGET
THAT DO YOU DO SO WHAT DO YOU
THINK WILL BE I MEAN GIVEN YOU
LOOKED AT YOUR WORKLOAD WHAT DO
YOU THINK IS GOING TO BE THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT TO YOUR BOARDS
WHICH FAMILIES FINANCIALLY
DOING BETTER AND MANY OTHER
BOARDS BUT STILL. IT'S AN
IMPACT- WILL HAVE YOU DONE AN
ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE WHAT THE-
FINANCIAL IMPACT WOULD BE.
SQUARE IT WE DO GET- MONTHLY
STATEMENTS FROM OUR AG'S
OFFICE- OKAY SO. AS A YEAR AGO
WE DID RECEIVE THAT AND WE
CANNOT DO OUR PLEADINGS. AND
THAT WAS DUE TO AN
INTERPRETATION OF A LAW- AND
WHEN THAT LAW WAS APPROPRIATELY
INTERPRETED- THAT DIEGO DID
DECIDE THAT. THEY NEED TO SERVE
THE PLEADINGS AND THAT DID
CAUSE A- COSTINCREASE FOR US
AS WELL. OKAY SO I WOULD HOPE
AND AGAIN- I'M REALIZING BRING
UP HERE BUT I MEAN WITH EVERY
BOARD DAY WE SHOULD SHOULD
DOING SOME SORT PROJECTION
LOOKING AT YOUR WORKLOAD SAYING
WELL. WE GENERALLY NEED TO USE
AG STAFFER THAT'S- WHAT
EXACTLY. IS GOING TO BE TO
INCREASE COSTS- ANDI DO THINK
THAT. THIS BY MORE FOR US THAN
FOR USE THAT- WE REALLY DO NEED
TO DELVE INTO IT I THINK THOSE
OVERHEAD RATES ARE EXTREMELY.
EXCESSIVE AND- I'M NOT SURE
WHAT IT SHOULD BE BORNE BY
LICENSEES- AS WELL SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT TOPIC- SO I
ALWAYS. I'M ALWAYS INTERESTED
IN CONTINUING EDUCATION- HAVING
SERVED ON AND- THIS- COMMITTEE
FOR A WHILE. ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAS COME UP WITH THE REST
OF BOARD REGISTERED NURSING
OTHER PRIOR TO YOUR UP. BEING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR IS-
REGARDING TEACHING EDUCATION-
COUPLE LEVELS OF ONE IS THAT
YEAH I NOTICED IN THE WRITE UP
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY. ALL TOO
BRIEF ON CONTINUING EDUCATION
THAT- YOUR THAT OF COURSE THE
BOARD ACTUALLY- REVIEWS AND
APPROVES CONTINUING EDUCATION
SO- THERE'S BEEN IN THE PAST
SOME QUESTIONS RAISED ABOUT
SOME SOMEWHAT QUESTIONABLE
COURSES THAT WERE APPROVED FOR
CONTINUING EDUCATION THAT
DIDN'T SEEM TO BE PARTICULARLY
SCIENCE BASED A PRACTICE BASED.
AND SO HOW'S THAT BEING DEALT
WITH AND THEN THE OTHER ISSUE.
RELATED TO HOLD CONTINUING
EDUCATION IS. DO YOU HAVE A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST POLICY TO
ENSURE THAT- COURSES THEY'RE
BEING TAUGHT ARE ACTUALLY
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND
MARKETING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
SOMEONE WHO HAS A PRODUCT OR
SERVICE THEY WISH TO SELL
NURSES. AND IT ASIDE FROM THAT.
THE ROLE OF THE BOARD AND
APPROVING. MEDINA DOES ALSO
NOTE. THAT PROVIDE. WHICH OTHER
BOARDS. ON YOU- ASSESS THAT WE
THAT YOUR MEMBERS ARE ACTUALLY
MEETING THE REQUIREMENTS SO
THERE'S A CLIMATE OF THIRTY
CREDITS EVERY. TWO YEARS- THE
HOW WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
LICENSEES ARE. MADE TO MIDDLE
TOWARDS DO IT OUT RENEWAL DO
YOU ACTUALLY- DO AT SOME OF
ALKYLATION OF- ARE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY FULFILLING THIS
REQUIREMENT OF DOING THIRTY
CREDITS- EVERY. EVERY TWO YEARS
ARE NOT SO WHAT PERCENTAGE
YOUR- SO DO YOU HAVE SOME DATA
YOU CAN SHARE WITH US AS TO.
HOW COMPLIANT LICENSEES ARE
WITH THE C. REQUIREMENTS SO I
DO REALIZE OF SEVERAL QUESTIONS
EMBEDDED IN THERE BUT- THOSE.
ARE SOME QUESTIONS RELATED
CONTINUING EDUCATION. THERE IS
THANK YOU CENTER PAM- WITH OUR
CONTINUING EDUCATION PROCESS IT
IS- MULTI FACETED SO I'LL TRY
TO EXPLAIN THAT AND BE AS
SUCCINCT AS POSSIBLE. WE DO
STRIVE TO AUDIT ABOUT 10% OF
OUR LICENSEES- IT IS A
RANDOMIZED AUDIT. AND WITH THEM
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSEES
IT'S A VERY LARGE NUMBER SO WE
DO. HAVE THAT AS ARTICLE. ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE DO
IS ON OUR RENEWAL PROCESS WHEN
THEY ACCESS THE BREEZE SYSTEM.
EACH OUR END HAS TO. MAKE AN
ATTESTATION THAT THEY HAVE IN
FACT COMPLETED THE THIRTY C. E.
USE IN THAT LAST TWO YEAR TIME
FRAME- WITH OUR ENDS BEING
VOTED AS MOST ETHICAL
PROFESSIONAL LAST TWENTY YEARS
I'D LIKE TO THINK THAT WE CAN
BELIEVE THAT. I MEAN I THINK I.
DO A TEST THAT STATION SO BUT
YOU SAID YES ACTUALLY AUDIT DO
YOU ACTUALLY AUDIT 10% THEN.
OUR GOAL IS ABOUT. 10% OF ALL
ISRAEL. IT I THINK WE'VE DONE
ABOUT 8% I THINK STILL WRAPPING
THAT I. BUT WE HAVE MADE OUR
GOAL OF TEN PER YET BUT I THINK
READ EIGHT. ADDITIONALLY EACH
ONE OF OUR- LICENSEES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO SUBMIT THAT- ON
THAT REFORM THEY SUBMIT THE
NAME OF THE PROGRAM THAT THEY
RECEIVE THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION UNITS THROUGH. HOW
MANY HOURLY UNITS ARE- PART IN
THAT ADDITION TO THE C. E. P.
PROVIDER NUMBER THAT IS INPUT
IT AND THEY HAVE THE OPTION TO
DIRECTLY UPLOAD A COPY OF THE
CERTIFICATE THAT THEY HAVE
COMPLAINTS. THAT SHOWS THAT
THEY COMPLETED INTO OUR PRE
SYSTEM FOR REVIEW- RIGHT NOW
THAT THAT IS NOT IN STOCK. SO
THEY CAN'T GO PAST THAT- AREA
WITHOUT SUBMITTING THAT
CERTIFICATE. BUT WE DO WE ARE
LOOKING AT TECHNOLOGICALLY.
ADVANCES TO REQUIRE THAT A
STOPPER PROVED HAS TO BE
SUBMITTED AT THAT TIME. OKAY.
AND THEN APPROVAL OF C. COURSES.
APPROVED OF SECOURS RIGHT NOW
WE DO HAVE REGULATION THAT
STATES THAT- IT HAS VERY IS SET
OF REQUIREMENTS ONE BEING THAT
IT HASTO BE AT OR ABOVE THE
LEVEL. OF THE EDUCATION THAT IS
PROVIDING FOR- PRIOR TO
LICENSING- WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH THAT RIGHT NOW HE IS-
THERE ARE MANY AREAS IMPROVING
WITH THAT WE- APPROVED ONE
SAMPLE COURSE. FOR THAT CD
PROVIDER AND BASED ON THAT THEY
ARE ABLE TO- HAVE A CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROVIDER NUMBER WE
HAVE WORKED TO UPDATE OUR
REGULATIONS TO PROVIDE IT MORE.
GUIDELINES TO THAT AND THAT IS
INTHE PROCESS OF GOING THROUGH
APPROVAL AS FOR ATTENDEES IS
THERE A CONFLICT OF INTEREST
POLICY. THERE IS NOT A CONFLICT
OF INTEREST POLICY AS OF NOW IT
IS SOMETHING THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE ADDED INTO THIS
REGULATORY DATE UNLESS THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS ADDED IN THE
STATUTE OKAY SO I WOULD MAKE
NOTE OF THE ISSUE THIRTY TWO
AND THIRTY THREE REAL- IF WE
CAN. HAVE MORE INFORMATION I'D
APPRECIATE THAT- THE
INFORMATION PROVIDED IS I THINK
A- VERY BRIEF AND NOT
PARTICULARLY ILLUMINATING. IT
DIDN'T WANT JUST A ONE LAST
QUESTION ABOUT C. E. YOU OF
COURSE THE LICENSE MADE
DIFFERENT TYPES AND HEARSES-
NURSE PRACTITIONERS AS WELL A
DAY ONLY DO THEY ONLY HAVE TO
DO THIRTY CREDITS BECAUSE
PHYSICIANS HAVE TO BE FIFTY
CREDITS OF. EVERY TWO YEARS SO-
DISPATCHERS- HAVING TO DO AT
LEAST FIFTY LIKE PHYSICIANS
DEALER. THERE'S ONLY A THIRTY.
FOR THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING CURRENT. ALL OF OUR
ADVANCED PRACTICE OUR HANDS
INCLUDING YOURS PRACTITIONERS
ARE LICENSED AS IRAN'S AND
THEREFORE HAVE B. R. AND C. E.
REQUIREMENT WHICH IS THIRTY
EVERY TWO. YEARS NOW THEIR
NATIONAL CERTIFICATION THAT IS
FOR THEIR NURSE PRACTITIONER-
CERTIFICATION THEY MAY REQUIRE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT OKAY BUT
FOR LICENSURE THE ONLY THIRTY
OKAY AT THAT PERHAPS SOMETHING
WE SHOULD ADDRESS AND- IN THE
FUTURE. AND THEN FINALLY- THE
OTHER ISSUE IS THAT- I
UNDERSTAND YOU BECAME LAW- THE
WELL YOU ARE ACTING EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR- STARTING IN SEPARATE
TWENTY TWENTY BUT SEE JUST HOW
LONG HAVE YOU BEEN WITH THE
FORD REGISTERED NURSING ON
STAFF. YEAH I WAS IN NURSING
EDUCATION CONSULTANT PRIOR TO
DOING THE VOLUNTEER POSITION OF
ACTING EXECUTIVE OFFICER. AND I
STARTED HERE WITH THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING- I BELIEVE
TWENTY FOURTEEN MAYOR TWENTY.
MAY TWENTY FOURTH EVEN WITH-
YOU'VE BEEN ON STAFF OF THE
BILL REGISTERED NURSING SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN OKAY THANK YOU
YES- SO. SO THEREFORE YOU ARE
ACTUALLY ON THE STAFF ALTHOUGH
IN A DIFFERENT ROLE WHEN THE
AUDIT CAME OUT- DATA SHOWED
THAT UNFORTUNATELY AT LEAST
THREE. US MEMBERS OF THE STAFF-
SHE WOULD SAY COMMITTED FRAUD-
AND LYFT YELLED- IN DETROIT AND
SEE THE STATE AUDITOR NOW YOUR
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- AND- YOU
HEARD OF SOME QUESTIONS PRIOR
FROM- MY COLLEAGUES ABOUT
CULTURE AND BECAUSE AFTER ALL
THIS IS JUST ONE PERSON. WHO
MIGHT HAVE BEEN TRYING TO HIDE
SOMETHING THEY WERE DOING IT
THREE I MEAN THAT'S THAT'S I
MEAN THERE'S A CODE THAT
THERE'S COLLUSION THERE- WHAT
ARE YOU WOW. I MEAN HAVING BEEN
ON THE BOARD ACTUALLY ON THE
STAFF AT THE TIME AGAIN- WHEN
THIS WAS HAPPENING. ONE WHAT DO
YOU THINK LED TO THAT AND WHAT
ARE YOU DOING ITS EXACT
DIRECTOR TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM- THE THIS CULTURAL-
THAT APPARENTLY ALLOW THE THREE
THREE MEMBERS OF THE STAFF AT
LEAST- TO ENGAGE IN THIS AND
THAT. KIND OF. BEHAVIOR HE AT
YEAH THAT WAS A SO TO ME THAT
WAS NOT THE CULT THAT I WAS
AWAY OF. A AND YOU KNOW I'D
AGAIN BUT IT'S UNFORTUNATE IS
THAT WAS THE CULTURE RIGHT I
MEAN IT MAY BE A SHOCK TO YOU
BUT APPARENTLY IT WAS THE
CULTURE BECAUSE THREE PEOPLE
FELT IT WAS OKAY TO DO THAT. SO
SO HOPEFULLY IN RETROSPECT AS
MUCH AS WE DON'T WANT TO THINK
THAT WAS THE CULTURE IT WAS. SO
WHAT ARE WE DOING TO CHANGE IT.
YEAH WHAT WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
DOING A LOT OF THINGS TO CHANGE
IT IT'S STUDENTS RECEIVE THAT
REPORT WHICH AS I SAID WAS A
DEFINITELY A SHOCK TO ME- I
REACHED OUT TO DCA I WANTED TO
KNOW WHAT MY- ABILITIES WERE TO
ADDRESS THIS AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE. I WAS SIMPLY I WAS IN
MY ACTING ROLE- AND HAD NOT
BECOME THE OFFICIAL EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AT THAT POINT- AND SO I
DID I SOUGHT GUIDANCE- WHEN I
GOT THAT REPORT I MET WITH THAT
D. C. A. AND I RECEIVED AN
AMAZING AMOUNT OF SUPPORT AND
EVEN MET WITH AGENCY AS WELL
WHO SUPPORTED ME IN THIS
PROCESS- WE LAUNCHED- AN
INVESTIGATION INTERNAL
MASTICATION WITH DCA- AND THE
REQUEST THAT I ACTUALLY WANTED
TO DO. WHICH I WAS GRANTED WAS
A COMPLETE REVIEW OF EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WERE
TURNED OVER TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR MY THOUGHT IS IF
THIS HAPPENED TO ONE IT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED. WITH OTHER OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS BUT WANTED
TO ENSURE THAT THIS WAS A ONE
TIME ONLY AND ONLY DONE FOR
THAT ONE AREA OF
RECOMMENDATION- AND THAT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ME. THE OTHER
THING THAT I THAT I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU GUYS ARE
WHERE IT IS WE HAVE A BRAND NEW
EXECUTIVE TEAM- THEY'VE ALL
BEEN HIRED AND WITHIN THE LAST
YEAR TO YEAR AND A HALF- AND
THAT CHANGES THE CULTURE
AUTOMATICALLY THERE SO WE'RE
WORKING REALLY HARD TO CONTINUE
WITH THAT CULTURE CHANGE AND BE
AS TRANSPARENT AS POSSIBLE. I
AM SURE THAT YOU NOTICED IN
OUR- SENSOR REPORT THE RETURN
THE AND WHERE WE ADMITTED THAT
THERE ARE MANY ITEMS THAT WE
HAD NOT MET- OVER THE YEARS AND
WE ARE COMMITTED TO MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT- OTHER THAN.
THAT IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
SUGGESTIONS I'M WILLING TO TAKE
THEM AND KEEP THEM AND SEE WHAT
WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE ALSO
CERTAINLY CHANGING SOME OF THE
EXECUTIVES- CAN. HELP BUT AGAIN
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THEY'RE
COMMUNICATING TO THE STAFF.
AND- AND A WE HAVE BEEN. TIME
HERE I WHAT I WOULD JUST WE DID
TRAINING AS WELL DIDN'T WITH-
WHERE EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THE
SUPERVISORS AND MANAGEMENT TEAM
DID. RECEIVE THAT TRAINING
ONLINE- IO OTHER OTHER AREAS
AND HE DID INFORM THE COURT
THAT THAT TRAINING WAS
COMPLETED. BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT I DID THAT I GUESS WHAT.
I'M LOOKING CERTAIN ABOUT I
DON'T SEE HERE IS
IDENTIFICATION OF WHAT WAS THE
UNDERLYING PROBLEM SO YES WE'RE
DOING YOU KNOW THINGS WE
CHANGED OVER SOME STAFF BUT-
SOME REFLECTION ON WHAT WHAT
LED TO THAT WHY WAS IT OKAY WHY
DO THOSE PEOPLE THINK I MEAN. I
WAS OKAY AND I THINK WE WHAT A-
YOU KNOW CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE
WHO ENGAGE IN THAT BEHAVIOR-
THERE NEED BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
BUT ALSO WE NEED TO GO BEYOND
LIKE ALL THE SHAME AND BLAME
CULTURE LIKE THOSE THOSE PEOPLE
IT WAS AN S. RIGHT SO SOMEHOW
IT WAS THE FOR THEM BILLS OKAY.
WHY WAS THAT AND WHAT CULTURAL
TO IT'S LARGER CULTURAL THING
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND THERE'S SOME
CHANGE OVER I GUESS I'LL JUST
CONCLUDE- MY OVERALL COMMENTS
BY SAYING IS THAT I APPRECIATE
THERE'S A NEW TEAM THERE'S
THIRTY EIGHT DIFFERENT ISSUES
HERE AND- ETCETERA- YOU
MENTIONED THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS ARE CHANGING- I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.I WOULD
JUST URGE AND I HOPE YOU WOULD
BE SUPPORT OF THIS IS THAT
THERE'S NO I DON'T THINK WE
COULD GO THROUGH EVERYTHING THE
SESSION OR EVEN THIS YEAR. THAT
I FEEL THAT THERE'S SO MANY
ISSUES ARE STILL OUTSTANDING
THAT WE SHOULD DO IT OVERSIGHT-REVIEW OF THIS EXTEND THE BOARD
FOR ONLY A YEAR. LET'S GO SEE
WHAT KIND OF PROGRESS YOU'VE
MADE I KNOW YOU JUST BEEN IN
THIS POSITION FOR ESSENTIALLY A
YEAR SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO
DO THIS OVERSIGHT AND
MONITORING AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET SOME MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION YOU CAN ALSO AS
YOU'VE BEEN YOU KNOW IN YOUR
NEW ROLE WITH YOUR NEW TEAM.
FEEDBACK MORE INFORMATION TO US
ABOUT WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE WHAT WE GAIN
SOME MORE DETAILED INFORMATION
ON HOW YOU'RE GOING THE
PROGRESS YOU'RE MAKING THAT YOU
ITS TOP YOU TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF THIS YOUR DRESSING THE
AUDITS AND SO FORTH. AND WITH
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR I
GIVE ME THE TIME- CHAIRS- TO-
TO ASK THESE QUESTIONS THANK
YOU THANK YOU DR PAN KILLINGS
ON THE FLOOR. OF SURE LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RICHARD
ROTH MISMO YOU- WALK. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH FOR. US HERE. TODAY A
FIRST OF ALL. WHO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE
ALSO THE CIRCUMSTANCE WE ARE
IN. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SPECIFICALLY WITH. THAT OF OUR
ENDS AND NURSES. AND THE
INCREDIBLE WORK THAT THEY DO
DAY IN AND DAY OUT ESPECIALLY
DURING THIS CALL THE PANDEMIC
SO- APPLAUDS- YOU. AND ALL OF
THE- LICENSEES FOR THE
INCREDIBLE WORK IN. HELPING TO
SUPPORT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THIS TIME OF NEED. RIGHT WE
NEED TO SEE DAILY THAT LIVES
ARE BEING LOST. AND ANYTHING
THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP UP LIFT.
THAT OF THOSE. WHO ARE. DOING
THEIR JOBS AS FRONTLINE
RESPONDERS AND- HELPING TO SAVE
LIVES IS IMPORTANT FOR US.
COLLECTIVELY SO AGAIN COME
COMMENDING YOU. FOR THE WORK
AND- A PLEASE KEEP A SURPRISED
AT WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
SUPPORT. THOSE WHO HELP SUPPORT
US. THAT THE NEWSOME MEL B. AS
YOU KNOW THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT HEARING AND I SAID
SAID EARLIER THAT WE ARE SIMPLY
DOING OUR JOB OR LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT IN OUR JOB I MUST
MEET YOU REITERATE- THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE SPECIFICALLY THAT A
LEGISLATIVE APPOINTEE PUBLIC
MEMBERS I WAS INSTRUCTED NOT TO
PARTICIPATE. TODAY'S IN TODAY'S
TESTIMONY FOR TESTIMONY TODAY'S
HEARING- SIMILARLY GOVERNMENT
CODE DOES RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF TESTIMONY BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE BY GRANTING
COMMITTEES BROAD SUBPOENA POWER
TO COMPEL WITNESSES TO
PARTICIPATE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES TO
PARTICIPATION WILL BE MINDFUL
OF OUR AUTHORITY- SO DO YOU
COMMIT TO HELPING TO ENSURE
THAT YOU AND YOUR BOARD WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THIS FULLY
PUBLIC PROCESS. I DO COMMIT TO
THAT GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT. ALSO IT WAS REFERENCE
EARLIER ABOUT YOUR NEW ROLE- IN
IN THIS CAPACITY TO AND- THEIR
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED BUT JUST SOME
GENERAL COMMENTS IS AT. WITH
RESPECT TO THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
THE CHALLENGING TIMES
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR ENDS AND HOW
WE CAN HELP UPLIFT AND EMPOWER.
PUBLIC COLLEGES I AM A PRODUCT
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES MYSELF AS
WELL AS SEE ISSUES I THINK THE
PROVIDE A KEY ROLE IN TERMS OF
THE PIPELINE AND DEVELOPMENT-
I. PERSONALLY TAKE THE POSITION
OF TRYING TO GO AGAINST THE
CORPORATE IS A NATION OF THE
INDUSTRY AND HELPING TO FURTHER
THE PIPELINE DEVELOPMENT OF
COURSE PRIVATE. COLLEGES PLAY A
KEY ROLE AS WELL BUT I THINK IT
IS OUR OBLIGATION AS A PUBLIC
ENTITY A TO HELP SUPPORT WHERE
POSSIBLE TO. US ALL ALONG THOSE
LINES- WITH RESPECT TO SOME OF
THOSE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS- HOW.
CAN YOU PROVIDE SOME INSIGHT ON
HOW WE CAN HELP EMPOWER OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IN OUR
PUBLIC ENTITIES. SPECIFICALLY
WITH THAT OF MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE A HEALTHY PIPELINE-
ANDERSON PIPELINE. I HAVE SOME
SUGGESTIONS I DO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I SHARE SOME AMAZING
STATISTICS AT THE END OF THE
START OFF WITH- FROM. FEBRUARY
OR SORRY MARCH. NINETEENTH OF
FEBRUARY TWENTY RIGHT BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC STARTED- THERE
WERE. HE I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
I GOT MY NUMBERS RIGHT TWELVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND
NINETY EIGHT LICENSOR BY EXAMS
FOR INITIAL CALIFORNIA OUR
ENDS. AND THEN EVEN WITH THAT
PANDEMIC AND ALL OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE DID FACE TOGETHER WITH
THAT FROM MARCH SECOND TO
FEBRUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
HAVE LICENSE WE HAVE RECEIVED
LICENSE BY EXAM FOR THE FIRST
TIME LICENSE OR FOR IN STATE
CALIFORNIA'S- CALIFORNIA GRADS.
TWELVE THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
AND FORTY SEVEN SO WE HAVE
EXCEEDED WHAT WAS DONE THE
PRIOR YEAR. ACTUALLY TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY SO- THROUGH
THE HARD WORK OF MY NURSING
EDUCATION CONSULTANTS. THE
DEDICATION OF THE STUDENTS AND-
THAT TIRELESSLY HOURS THAT ARE
DECENT DIRECTORS PUT IN OUR
NURSING STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO
PROGRESSIVE GRADUATE ALTHOUGH
THEY HAD MANY MANY HURDLES TO
OVERCOME SO I WANT TO- HELP TO
ASSURE YOU THAT OUR PIPELINE
CURRENTLY IS STILL SECURE. AND
THAT WE ARE ALL WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
STAYS- SECURE. IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION ON THE- WHAT CAN
WE DO TO HELP AMERICAN
COMMUNITY BASED SCHOOLS IS
REALLY COMES DOWN TO FUNDING
HONESTLY- AS IN MY PRIOR ROLE I
WENT OUT TO THE SCHOOLS I DID
THOSE- REVIEWS ON EVERY TEAM
BASIC AND WHAT I FOUND A LOT OF
TIMES THEY'RE OPERATING OFF THE
GRANT FUNDS- AND THAT SOME OF
THEIR FACULTY POSITIONS HAVE
NOT BEEN INSTITUTIONALIZED-
AND- THAT. AND THEY'RE MISSING
SOME KEY PLAYERS ON THEIR TEAM
THAT SOME OF OUR PRIVATE
SCHOOLS HAVE- SOME OF THEM
BEING CONTINUE UP KIDS AND
CLINICAL PLACEMENT
COORDINATORS- WHERE THAT
PERSON'S SOLE RESPONSIBILITY IS
TO ENSURE. THAT THEY HAVE
ADEQUATE CLINICAL PLACEMENTS
THAT THEIR COMPETITIVE IN THE
REGION- THAT THEY GET THE
PAPERWORK IN THE VARIOUS
DOCUMENTS TURNED INTO DAM- SO
THAT THE STUDENTS CAN- CAN ADD
TEN THOSE CLINICAL SITE. AND A
LOT OF OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING FOR THAT
AND IF THEY DO HAVE THE FUNDING
IS DONE THROUGH GRANT FUNDS- SO
REALLY OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ALREADY DISADVANTAGED WHEN IT.
COMES TO- GETTING BACK THE-
ADMINISTRATIVE SUPPORT AS WELL
AS FACULTY SUPPORT AND
COMMUNITY SUPPORT BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF FUNDING THAT THEY
RECEIVE. GREAT THE ECONOMICALLY
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN THAT AND I
QUESTION THE DESIRE CERTAINLY
TO HELP EMPOWER THAT OF OUR
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS AND- JUST
BREAKS MY HEART SEEING THAT.
SYSTEM BEAR THE BURDEN OF THE
COST HIGH CUTS OF THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY PLUS THOUSAND TO
GRADUATE AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
TIME WHEN WHICH WE NEED. THE
PIPELINE FOR THE FUTURE IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO KEEP
MINDFUL OF TO. WITH RESPECT TO
SCHOOLS- IF AT A FUTURE MEETING
SCHOOLS WHO HAVE DEMONSTRATED
EXCEPTIONAL OUTCOMES INCLUDING
HIGH NCLEX PASS RATES AND CAN
ALSO APPROVED CLINICAL SITE
AVAILABILITY. BOTH OF THOSE
PROGRAMS BE APPROVED. I CAN'T
SPEAK FOR MY BOARD BUT WHAT I
CAN SAY IS THAT THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT COMES FROM
OR ANY SEASON- THE THROUGH THE
AGENDA ITEM SUMMARY AFTER THEY
DO THEIR RUBIO- IT IS IT'S KEY
IN THAT PROCESS. THE SCHOOL IS
ASSIGNED A NURSING EDUCATION
CONSULTANT THAT THEY WORK ONE
ON ONE WITH WHEN IS SCHOOL HAS
B- THE THOUGHT THAT THEY WANT
TO INCREASE ENROLLMENT OR OPEN
A NEW CAMPUS OR OFFER AD AND IT
DID TIONAL DEGREE GRANTING
OPTION. THEY APPROACH THEIR
NURSING EDUCATION ASSAULTED AND
THEY PROVIDE- INFORMATION ON
HOW THEY CAN SUPPORT THAT THAT
ADDITIONAL- AMOUNT OF STUDENTS
TEACHER RESOURCES THEY ENSURE
FACULTY BE ASSURE THE BUDGET
THE ENSURE THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
HAVE THE CLINICAL SITES THAT
SUPPORT THAT. ONCE THAT IS DONE
IN OUR NURSING EDUCATION
SULTANS DO WITH THOROUGH REVIEW
OF THAT INFORMATION. COMPARE
THAT TO THE DATA THAT IS- THERE
IN THE REGION WHERE THEY LOOK
AT IS THEIR WORK NEEDS ARE
THERE- CLINICAL STATEMENTS HAVE
THE HAS A SCHOOL THEMSELF
ENABLE TO SECURITY ADDITIONAL
CLINICAL SITE SITE. AND THEN
THEY DO THEY HAVE THE FACULTY
THAT CAN SUPPORT BECAUSE AS
STUDENTS GO TO CLINICAL SITES
THEY ALSO NEED FACULTY THAT
WILL OVERSEE THEM. IF AT THAT
POINT IT IS- ASCERTAINED BY THE
NURSING EDUCATION CONSULTANTS
THAT THEY HAVE MET THAT THAT
INFORMATION IS PASSED YOU ARE
BOARD MEMBERS IN THE EDUCATION
LICENSING COMMITTEE MEETING AND
THEN THE EDUCATION LICENSE YOU
CAN REALLY MEETING MAKES THE
RECOMMENDATION THAT GOES
FORWARD TO THE FULL BOARD- THE
FOLLOWING MONTH AND THAT FULL
BOARD WILL BE NEAT. THEY
DISCUSS AND ASK QUESTIONS THE
DEAN AND RECTOR OR ANY OTHER
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATION IS ON THE
LINE AND AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS AND THE BOARD MEMBERS
TAKE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS ABOUT TUITION ABOUT
WHAT THE SIZE OF THAT
ENROLLMENT CREASE IS. AND
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE SUPPORT
FOR THAT AND THAT THEY WILL NOT
BE CAUSING ANY CLINICAL
DISPLACEMENT. IF THAT IS- ABLE
TO BE ASSURED THEN ENROLLMENT
INCREASES NEAR CAMPUS IS- NEW
PROGRAMS ANYTHING THERE IS
COMPLETED- I DO HAVE SOME TO
STATISTICS ON THAT IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN I'M ON THE
ENROLLMENT INCREASES THAT WE'VE
DONE EVEN THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC IF THAT- IS
INTERESTING. IF NOT WE CAN PUT
THAT IN OUR REPORT. IF THAT BE
THE BE HELPFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. YOUR THANK YOU CHAIR LOW
ANY OTHER CAR IN THE CHAMBER
MEMBER DOLLY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I HAVE- SO QUESTIONS SOME
QUESTIONS IN REGARDS SEAT
LICENSURE VERIFICATION- ON MAY
TWENTY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY I
PRESENTED AB THIRTY SIXTEEN
BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY BUSINESS
AND PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL WOULD HAVE REQUIRED AND TO IMPLEMENT AN
ELECTRONIC LICENSE
VERIFICATION. SYSTEM KNOWN AS
NURSES DOT COM THAT IS USED BY
FORTY SEVEN OTHER STATES FOR
IMMEDIATE ONLINE LICENSE FOR
VERIFICATION AND OFFERS ONLINE
PAYMENT SERVICES. AT THAT
HEARING THE BEER AND TESTIFIED
IN OPPOSITION AGREEING THAT
THERE WAS A PROBLEM WITH
BACKLOG FOR LICENSURE
VERIFICATION AND PROMISING TO
IMPLEMENT AN ONLINE PAYMENT
OPTION IN ELECTRONIC
VERIFICATION PROCESS THROUGH
THE BREEZE SYSTEM BY THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY. MY QUESTIONS.
THE FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT IS
YOUR CURRENT BACKLOG FOR
LICENSURE VERIFICATION. THANK
YOU I'M TRYING TO ACCESS THAT
DATA REALLY QUICK I DID GET AN
UPDATE FROM MY DEPUTY CHIEF OF
LICENSING THIS MORNING AS I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE I HAD THE
MOST ACCURATE. DATA FOR YOU
RIGHT NOW FOR IN I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT I'M CLEAR AGAIN
VERIFICATIONS ARE WHEN A NURSE
THAT IS LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA
IS TRYING TO GO TO OUT OF
STATE. AND THEN WE HAVE
ENDORSEMENTS FOR NURSES OUT OF
STATE TRYING TO GET IN
CALIFORNIA SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE
I GIVE YOU- THAT CORRECT
INFORMATION CAN YOU SPECIFY TO
ME YES ONE YES THAT'S- WORTH
YES THAT'S A QUESTION AND- YOU
CAN. RIGHT RIGHT NOW ASK ANSWER
THIS- HAS A B. R. AND
IMPLEMENTED. THE ON ELECTRONIC
PAYMENT PROCESS. WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING IT AND
I DID GET A REPORT OUT
YESTERDAY THAT THE HOPE IS FOR
IT TO GO ONLINE. AS EARLY AS
NEXT MONTH. IS THAT TRUE BREEZE
THAT WILL BE THROUGH BREEZE YES
I DO HAVE AN I. T. TEAM THAT I
NEED WITH THE DAILY- IT JUST IN
THE LAST COUPLE MONTHS AND- AND
THEY ARE DOING SMALL
IMPLEMENTATIONS AND VARIOUS
THINGS- AS RAPID AS POSSIBLE AS
WE DO SEE THAT WE HAVE A NEED
FOR THIS SIZE IT LOOKS LIKE THE
VERIFICATIONS WILL GO ONLINE.
MARCH FIRST. AS THE COMING
THERE THEY WENT ONLINE I'M
SORRY OKAY IS IT ME JUST CHECK
THIS DATA REALLY QUICK. OKAY WE
ARE PROCESSING VERIFICATIONS AS
OF MARCH FIRST SO I JUST GOT MY
WIRES CROSSED THERE FOR A
SECOND AND IT DOES CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE GOAL. FOR IT TO GO
LIVE FOR AN ONLINE PROCESS AS
SOON AS NEXT. SO YOUR WEBSITE.
RIGHT NOW SAYS A TARGET TIME
FRAME FOR PROCESSING A REQUEST
FOR ONLINE LICENSE VERIFICATION
THROUGH BREEZE IS FOUR TO SIX
WEEKS THIS SEEMS. IF IT'S AN
ONLINE PROCESS THAT SEEMS TO BE
A VERY LONG TIME TO FOR ME- AND
ALSO WHY IS THE TIMELINE SO
LONG IF THE NURSES SYSTEM CAN
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE VERIFICATION.
ME AGAIN FORTY SEVEN OTHER
STATES USE THIS PROCESS. YEAH I
COULD SPEAK TO THAT- RIGHT NOW
WE HAVE THE BREEZE WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
AND BASS LICENSE PROP FORWARD
FROM TWENTY THIRTEEN ARE WITHIN
THE PRE SYSTEM AND THEY ARE
ELECTRONIC AND THOSE ARE LIKE
WE SAID CURRENT AS OF MARCH
FIRST SO THAT'S JUST ELEVEN
DAYS- FROM RIGHT NOW AND SO WE
ARE PROCESSING THEM. FAST WITH
THE LICENSEES THAT- CAME INTO
THE BOARD PRIOR TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF BREEZE IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN THOSE LICENSEES
THE BEST DOCUMENTS AND
INFORMATION ON THEM ARE NOT
STORED WITHIN BREEZE. AS WE GET
IN EQUITY WE ADD THAT INTO
BREEZE AND WE DO HAVE STAFF
ASSIGNED TO TRY TO IMPLEMENT
THE UPDATE ALL THAT INFORMATION
IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR- AS WE
SAID- IN SOME OF THAT.
COMMUNICATION HERE IS THAT WE
HAVE OVER FIVE WE HAVE ABOUT
FIVE THOUSAND LICENSEES IS THE
RICH WERE DOING- WHAT WE- OUR
INTENT IS TO GET ALL OF THEM IN
DEGREES. EVEN IF WE WENT SEE
YOU THE NURSES SYSTEM THERE
WOULD BE A DELAY IN
IMPLEMENTATION AS WE DO HAVE TO
DIGITALIZE. THOSE DOCUMENTS AND
ALLOW FOR THEM TO BE
TRANSFERRED EVEN INTO THAT THE
NURSE THE SYSTEM THE NURSES
SYSTEM COMMUNICATES TO OUR
BREEZE- WE DO YOU CURRENTLY USE
NURSES SYSTEMS FOR. DISCIPLINE
AND OTHER STATES AND- MARTIN
FORSMAN SYSTEM. SO WE DO HAVE
THE ABILITY FOR TO COMMUNICATE
BUT IT CAN ONLY COMMUNICATE
WITH THE INFORMATION THAT IS
THE THREE SYSTEM. PRIOR TO ME
COMING ON AS EXECUTIVE OFFICER
IN JUNE LAST YEAR- WE HAD
DOCUMENTS- ON LICENSEES BUILT
ON MICROFILM. AS WELL AS
MICROFICHE AND SO- WE DID GO
AHEAD AND GET A CONTRACTOR THAT
HAS TRANSCRIBED THE MICROFILM
ONTO A DIGITAL AND SEARCH FOR
DOCUMENTS. AND DCA IS WORKING
THROUGH THAT INFORMATION IN
ORDER TO WRITE BACK TO US SO
THAT WE CAN SEARCH THAT
INFORMATION. AND WE'LL BE ABLE
SAID THEN. INPUT THAT INTO
GREASE- IT'S OUR HOPE BUT RIGHT
NOW WE'RE MEETING SOME
ROADBLOCKS IN AS THOSE SYSTEMS
ARE NOT COMMUNICATING. SO WHAT
WOULD BE THE TIMELINE TO EXPECT
THE IN THIS IS A B. R. AND- FOR
PROMISE. THE FIVE DAY
PROCESSING TIME. WITH THE ONE
EVERYTHING- SETS WERE ALREADY
AN AT PROCESSING I THINK WE CAN.
MOVE F. R. FORWARD QUICKLY- WE
ARE LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR
LICENSE PROCESS SEES AND WE
ACTUALLY JOINED TO DCA AND THE
VERY FIRST IT'S CALLED THE
ENLIGHTENED LICENSING PROJECT-
AND WE VOLUNTEERED FOR THAT.
AND WE'RE RECEIVING A LOT OF
HELP FROM ALL THE BOARDS AND
BUREAUS COMING TOGETHER AND SEE
WHAT THEY CAN DO TO HELP US
ENHANCE THIS PROCESS AS WE ARE
ABOUT THE LARGEST BOARD. WITH
THE LARGEST AMOUNT OF
LICENSEES. IN THAT PATTERN
THAT'S GREAT NEWS DID YOU FIND
OUT THE CURRENT BACKLOG. AMOUNT
FOR VERIFICATION OUT I WAS NOT
ABLE TO HAVE THAT THEY GAVE ME
INTEREST ME AND I DID SEND AN
EMAIL OUT- AND IT JUST CAME AND
WE HAVE A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE THAT ARE PENDING RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH. YOU'RE
WELCOME THANK YOU THANK YOU
MEMBER DOLLARS JUST TO FOLLOW
UP ON THAT YOU KNOW. IN PAGE
THIRTY EIGHT OF THE BACKGROUND
PAPER THAT WAS PREPARED FOR
THIS HEARING- ON THIS
PARTICULAR NURSES ISSUE.
THERE'S A STATEMENT THE BEER IN
PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED UTILIZING
NURSES FOR OUT OF STATE
ENDORSEMENTS STATING THAT IT
WOULD LOSE AND THIS IS A QUOTE
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN REVENUE. WOULD BE
LOST FROM CONTRACTING THE
BUSINESS OF THE STATE TO A
PRIVATE ENTITY THIS REVENUE
SUPPORTS OTHER AREAS WITHIN THE
B. R. AND SUCH IS ENFORCEMENT
AND DISCIPLINE WHICH MAINTAINS.
PUBLIC SAFETY THAT'S THE END OF
THE QUOTE THAT THAT WOULD SORT
OF SUGGESTS TO ME AT LEAST AT
SOME POINT IN TIME. THAT WE
ELECTED TO USE A SLOWER PROCESS
IN ORDER TO GENERATE FEES FROM
LICENSEES TO RAISE REVENUE USED
FOR OTHER PURPOSES. I ASSUME
THAT- TO THE IT TO THE EXTENT
THAT STATEMENT IS ACCURATEI
ASSUME THAT PREDATES YOU MA'AM.
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT PREDATES
ME AS WELL- AGAIN I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE CLARIFY THE
PROCESS HERE I KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ENDORSING BUT YOU
SAID ENDORSING OUT. AND SO
ENDORSING TO THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING MEANS.
NURSES THAT ARE OUT OF STATE
THAT ARE COMING INTO CALIFORNIA
AND I BELIEVE THE QUESTION I
JUST ANSWERED WAS ACTUALLY
ABOUT VERIFICATIONS AND THAT IS
WHERE LICENSE. ARE ENDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE TRYING
TO GO OUT OF CALIFORNIA SO I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
COMPARING THAT THAT. CORRECT
TERMS WELL LIKE A KITTEN SO I
DID NOT PREPARE THE BACKGROUND
PAPER I CAN'T. ATTEST TO THAT
BUT IT RELATES TO THE ISSUE
HAVING TO DO WITH CALIFORNIA
LICENSE. PORTABILITY IN
LICENSED CALIFORNIA REGISTERED
NURSES THAT WHICH WHICH TO
PRACTICE OUT OF STATE.
ENDORSING TO OTHER STATES
NURSING BOARD SO I DO THINK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT APPLES ARE
APPLES HERE. AND IF SO I WOULD
CERTAINLY HOPE THAT WE DON'T
FAVOR SLOWER PROCESS SEES IN
ORDER TO RAISE REVENUE TO
BENEFIT OTHER PARTS OF THE-
BOARD'S OPERATION AND I'M- SURE
THAT YOU. FEAR THAT WORK I'M
SURE THAT YOU WILL. ENSURE THAT
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN. I AND
WE'VE ACTUALLY UPDATED ARE
BREEZE PUBLIC FACING LICENSE
VERIFICATION AND I'M JUST IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. WHERE
WE'VE ADDED OUR LOCAL THE
CALIFORNIA BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING AND THEN ON REQUEST WE
ALSO ADDED WHETHER OR NOT BE
OUR ENDS BETTER IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE LICENSE INITIALLY BY
EXAM. OR WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WERE LICENSED BY ENDORSING IN
FROM ANOTHER STATE THOSE WERE
SPECIFIC REQUESTS FROM OHER
STATES- THAT SAID THAT THEY
COULD THEN USE OUR BREEZE
SYSTEM THAT IS CURRENTLY PUBLIC
FACING. THE START THE
ENDORSEMENT PROCESS WITH THE
VERIFICATION IS WHAT WE CALL IT
INTO THEIR STATE WITH OUT- BE.
THE NURSE EVEN HAPPEN TO MAKE A
REQUEST TO US- CURRENTLY I DID
SPEAK WITH FLORIDA AND THEY ARE
USING THIS AND- THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRING A FEAT- AND THEY ARE
NOT REQUIRING THEIR- NURSES
THAT ARE TRYING TO BE LICENSED
IN CALIFORNIA TO DO ANYTHING
FURTHER. THEY'RE GETTING THAT
INFORMATION OFF OF OUR WEBSITE
WHICH IS A DIRECT COPY OF WHAT
OUR BREEZE IS IT'S ACTUALLY GET
THAT INFORMATION FROM THAT AND
THERE'S NO DELAY AND NO FEE AND
FORD IS USING THAT. SO I HAVE
BEEN- MEETING WITH THE NATIONAL
COUNCIL THE STATE BOARDS OF
NURSING TYPICALLY ON EVERY
OTHER WEEK BASIS WHERE I. OTHER
E. EXECUTIVE OFFICERS FROM
OTHER BOARDS ARE THERE AND THEY
ARE- JUST THROUGH EDUCATION
THROUGH GETTING THE WORDS OUT
THREE TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT
DIFFERENT PROCESSES ARE AND
WHAT THEY NEED. WE'RE WORKING
TO SEE WHAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
THEM IN THOSE PROCESS SEES SOME
STATES STILL REQUIRE AN
OFFICIAL EMAIL OTHERS REQUIRE A
PAPER DOCUMENT WITH THE SEAL ON
IT. AND BASED ON THOSE BOARDS
OF NURSING'S REQUIREMENTS WE'RE
LOOKINGAT WHAT WE CAN DO TO
HELP THEM- SO THAT OUR NURSES
CAN. GO IN AND OUT OF STATE AND
DO THAT IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FROM- LET
ME TURN THE SIGNAL OTHER MAKES
UP IN THE CHAMBER LET ME TURN
TO. MY COLLEAGUES REMOTELY
CENTER BATES. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ROSS THE END OF. I
HAVE BAD ALLERGIES THIS MORNING
GUYS SO. BEAR WITH ME. ISMAEL
BE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE
YOU JUMPED INTO THE MIDDLE OF
THIS AND A DIFFICULT TIME AT
YOU WITH THE PIER MY QUESTION
IS REGARDING THE PROBLEM GOING
BACK TO SOME OF THE CONCERN
OVER THE AUDIT. IN THE END WHAT
SEEM TO BE ALMOST A LIBERTY OF-
CRIED HERE- THE RELATIONSHIP OF
THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER WITH THE
BOARD. HAVING SERVED ON MANY
BOARDS AND HAVING HAD A FEW
ROGUE STAFF ON THAT WE HAD TO.
BASICALLY FIRE FOR SOME OF THE
SIMILAR REASONS WHAT ROLE DOES
THE BOARD HAVE AN OVERSEEING IT
STAFF TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
GETTING CORRECT INFORMATION ON
YOUR WHATEVER THEY SET FOR WAS
FOR THEIR EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN
THE STAFF. ON SOME OF THESE.
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
FORTH INVOICE AUDITING AND
CERTAINLY IN OUR- BUSINESS AND
PROFESSION ON SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS THESE BECAUSE THAT
SEEMS TO BE A SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
HERE THE MORE SEEMS TO BE
DETACHED. FROM SOME SORT OF A
FLIRTY OVER THE WORK THAT YOU
PRODUCE ARE WHAT THEY ASSIGNED
TO YOU- COULD YOU ELABORATE ON
THAT. I CAN'T SENATE BATES
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION-
OUR BOARD HAS DIRECT OVERSIGHT
OF B. SO THEY APPOINT ME AND
THEY CAN REMOVE ME AS WELL SO
THAT IS WHERE THE BOARD HAS THE
SPECIFIC OVERSIGHT I DO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO MEET WITH THE
EXECUTIVE TEAM- I'VE BEEN. HELD
TEN DAYS AGO WE DID HAVE A
PRESIDENT AND A VICE PRESIDENT
IN PLACE AND I DID MEET WITH
THEM WEEKLY- IF NOT MORE AND
THEY WERE FULLY AWARE OF
EVERYTHING THAT I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON- WE DID HAVE A
RECENT TURNOVER OF OUR- BOARD
STAFF HE WAS ON HIS GRACE
PERIOD- OF. RTC AFTER ALREADY
SERVING TWO TERMS- AND WE HAVE
A BOARD MEETING SCHEDULED FOR
TUESDAY. WHERE THE HOPE IS
THAT- BOARD PRESIDENT AND VICE
PRESIDENT WILL BE APPOINTED- SO
THAT WILL THAT JUST HAPPENED WE
DID A TEN DAY NOTICE- AND SO WE
DID A QUICK TURN AROUND TO TRY
TO GET THAT TAKEN CARE OF- AS
FOR A SPECIFIC PERSONNEL
ISSUES. THE BOARD DOES NOT
TYPICALLY HAVE ANY ROLE IN
PERSONAL ISSUES OTHER THAN MICE
MYSELF- WHAT WE DO YOU CAN DO
IS- IN CLOSED SESSION- DO AN
AGENDA ITEM FOR PERSONNEL
ISSUES WHERE CERTAIN ITEMS IF
THEY MEET THE CRITERIA OUTLINED
IT BASICALLY CAME CAN BE
DISCUSSED- AND- BECAUSE THIS
WAS A CALIFORNIA STATE AUDIT.
RECOMMENDATION WE'RE INVOLVED
THIS WILL WHISTLE BLOWER WE DID
SHARE THIS IMMEDIATELY OUT WITH
OUR BOARD MEMBERS AND WE DID
DISCUSS THIS ISSUE WITHIN CLOSE
SESSION SO THAT THEY WERE AWARE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON. I DO WANT
TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THAT BACKGROUND PAPER
IN PRINT SOME OF THE STATEMENTS
THAT- WHAT IS THAT SAID IN-
THIS HEARING HERE IS THAT THE
BOARD REQUESTED DISMISSAL- AS
PART OF THE STATE PROCESS OUR
BOARD. AND MYSELF IS AN EEO DO
NOT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
TERMINATE AN EMPLOYEE- WE HAVE
TO REQUEST THE DISMISSAL SO
BASED ON REQUESTING THAT
DISMISSAL THAT EMPLOY ONLY HAS
OPTIONS TO- ASK FOR A HEARING
WITH THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD
AND THEN- LEGAL DECISIONS AND-
POTENTIALLY SETTLEMENTS CANNOT
CURSE BASED ON THAT STATE
PROCESS. SO I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WAS CLEAR THAT
IN MY COMMUNICATION WITH THE-
STATE AUDITOR I DID SAY THAT I
REQUESTED DISMISSAL ARE ADVERSE
ACTION AND I SAID THE
SUPPORTING INFORMATION TO THAT-
APAN RECEDING THE BACKGROUND
PAPER LAST NIGHT I DID GO ON TO
THE WEBSITE. AND THE WEBSITE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR DOES SAY THAT. I
REQUEST A DISMISSAL THAT WAS
NOT BE A FROM THAT WE SOME TO
THE HOW. I MEAN TO THE STATE
AUDITOR'S IN A WRITTEN RESPONSE
HOWEVER WITH THE SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION THAT WAS
SUBMITTED THEIR THAT SUPPORTING
DOCUMENTATION DOES STATE THAT
ME AS THE EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN
OUR BOARD IN SUPPORT DID
REQUEST DISMISSAL. THANK YOU
FOR THAT RESPONSE I'M- THINKING
MAYBE THERE NEEDS TO BE. IF NOT
LEGISLATION SOME DISCUSSION
REGARDING THE MEMBERS THEY GET
APPOINTED TO THIS BOARD
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR
AUTHORITY IS. CERTAINLY WHAT
THEIR BACKGROUND YEARS SO THAT
THEY KNOW THE QUESTIONS TO ASK
WHEN THEY'RE FEELING THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING OUT OF ALL
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED
BECAUSE I THINK THE
RELATIONSHIP OF THE BOARD
MEMBERS ARE TO THEIR EXECUTIVE
OFFICER AND CERTAINLY THEIR
STAFFIS A CRITICAL WAY. TO
ENSURE SOMETHING LIKE THIS DOES
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN YEAH. TO ME
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF A
DISCONNECT THERE WHEN IT WENT
ON TO THE LEVELS AND THE AMOUNT
OF TIME NINETEEN BECAUSE- AN
ATTORNEY AND I. REALLY BROUGHT
OUT SOMETHING THAT WE BE- I
THINK LOOKED. MORE CAREFULLY
AND DEEPLY BECAUSE THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT I DIDN'T PUT
THE PUBLIC SAFETY BACK IN THE
EQUATION. I IS THAT WE ASK
SIGNIFICANTLY AT RISK WHEN
THESE KINDS OF THINGS ARE GOING
ON SO. IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A
BIG JOB THAT YOUR BACKGROUND
AND CERTAINLY IN YOUR RESPONSES
HERE. I THINK GIVE ME
PERSONALLY A LITTLE MORE
COMFORT. THEY ACTION THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
IN YOUR PAST NOT CHILD
PROGRESSING INTO THE FUTURE BUT
AGAIN WE NEED TO LOOK CLOSELY.
AT THE APPOINTEES THAT ARE ON
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
THEY NEED TO KNOW THEIR
RESPONSIBILITY THERE IS ALREADY
AND CERTAINLY THEIR OWN
ACCOUNTABILITY. IN ISSUES LIKE
THIS AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE AND OFF WE'LL BE
WATCHING IT CLOSELY AND
CERTAINLY BE COMING UP WITH
SOME NEW RECOMMENDATIONS.
POTENTIALLY GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR RATES. THANK
YOU CENTER BY. IN THE SENATE
ANY QUESTIONS. COLLEAGUES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY ANY
QUESTIONS OF SO PLEASE INDICATE
BY USING THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FUNCTION. I SEE NONE. IBM YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ABOUT THE
INDICATION IS WE HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING ON
THE- TELECONFERENCE LINE TO
PARTICIPATE. WELL AS YOU KNOW
WEALSO SET TWELVE NOON IS SORT
OF THE STOP FOR THIS HEARING. I
AM A LITTLE DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE SOME OF THESE OTHER ISSUES
CAN'T BE EXPORT BE EXPLORED DUE
TO TIME I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE I
HAVE A NUMBER OF QUESTIONS I'D
LIKE TO PURSUE WHICH I WON'T
BUT- GIVEN THE APPARENT ISSUES
WITH CLINICAL PLACEMENTS ACTUAL
OR PERCEIVED AND I'M TALKING TO
THE BOARD- EXECUTIVE OFFICER
NOW. QUESTIONS I'M GOING TO
THROW OUT THERE THAT PERHAPS WE
CAN GET INFORMATION ON OFFLINE
OR WILL BE BACK HERE IN THE
SENATE OR SOMEWHERE ELSE TO.
HAVE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THEM
BUT FOR EXAMPLE THE TIMELINE
FOR DEVELOPING A PROCESS FOR
THE USE OF. ADVANCED SIMULATION
IN OUR NURSING TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN LIEU OF SOME
CLINICAL PLACEMENTS OBSTACLES
THINGS THAT WE CAN DEAL WITH TO
TRY TO. IMPROVE THE ABILITY TO
USE A- IN GREATER. NUMBERS WITH
RESPECT TO NURSE PRACTITIONERS
THE ISSUE OF TRANSITION TO
PRACTICE IN THE RULES. AND THE
IMPACT OF THOSE RULES ON
INDIVIDUALS WHO PERHAPS HAVE
BEEN IN PRACTICE. AS NURSE
PRACTITIONERS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND HOW THAT PROCESS
GIVEN THE- STATUTES THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE LAST YEAR. HOW THAT'S
GOING TO WORK- WITH REGARD TO
APPROVALS BY BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING. I HAVE
QUESTIONS AS TO THE RATIONALE
FOR THE BOARD'S ROLE IN
APPROVING FACULTY MEMBERS BELOW
THE LEVEL OF PROGRAM DIRECTORS
IN NURSING DIRECTORS. IN OUR
STATE'S NURSING PROGRAMS AND
QUESTIONS WITH REGARD. TO THE
NEED FOR B. R. N. TO APPROVE
SPECIFIC CLINICAL **** AT LEAST
AS I UNDERSTAND THE CURRENT.
SITUATION AND QUESTIONS
REGARDING PERHAPS THE VALUE OF
ADDING MORE PUBLIC MEMBERS. TO
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
AMONG THE VARIOUS QUESTIONS
THAT I THINK ARE STILL
OUTSTANDING AND THAT I HAVE.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET THOSE
ADDRESSED AT SOME POINT IN
TIME. BUT SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS- WITH MEL B. THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING TODAY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING YOU AND
PERHAPS ONE OF YOUR BOARD
MEMBERS THE NEXT TIME SO WE CAN
GET PERHAPS A BOARD
PERSPECTIVE. IN ADDITION TO
YOUR PERSPECTIVE IS THE BOARD
EXECUTIVE OFFICER ON MANY OF
THESE VERY VERY- IMPORTANT
ISSUES. LET'S NOW ACCEPT
TESTIMONY FROM MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. CONCERNING THE BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING AND THE
SUNSET REVIEW HEARING. LET'S
BEGIN WITH WITNESSES HERE IN
THE GALLERY AND SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO BE PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE TWELVE
LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCING OF THIS.
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
WE WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO. I'M SORRY
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON
TODAY'S OF ALL. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN GENERAL AT THIS
TIME. THE MODERATOR WITH
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOUR LINE
NUMBERS. WHEN YOU'RE LINE
NUMBERS CALLED PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME. FOR THE RECORD. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WATER AND WHEN YOU HAVE A
CHANCE WOULD YOU PLEASE GIVE ME
THE TOTAL NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE TEN IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU. IF YOU WOULD- WHEN
READY TO OPEN THE LINES AND
CALL THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY WE WILL PROCEED.
NINE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS KATHY BURKE WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA- I'M CALLING TO URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO RECONSIDER
AN ISSUE RELATED TO PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSING AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
PAID A HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS TO
APPLY FOR INITIAL CERTIFICATION
SCHEMES AND RENEWAL HAD NO
COST. UNFORTUNATELY THAT BE
GREATLY INCREASED THAT THE R.
AND IS NOW ABLE TO SET THE
AGENT CERTIFICATION FEES
ANYWHERE BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND WITHOUT WITHOUT AND
WITH NEW CERTIFICATE YEAH BUT
BUT ALEX AT THIS VERGE OF
PEOPLE FOR ME DO THAT. MUCH
NEEDED. THANK ONLY YOU TO TAKE
A LOOK AT THANK YOU. I THINK
THE NEXT. NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH CHAIRMAN ROBERT SHERMAN
MALL MONICA MILLER REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA CITIES YOU NURSE
ANESTHETIST AND WE WOULD
DEFINITELY SUPPORT THE B. R.
AND GETTING THEIR EXTENSION ON
THE DEBT OR REGULATORY BODY AND
THEY ARE THERE TO SERVE THE
PUBLIC- I. WE HOPE THAT THE
WALKING THAT AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME AND THE HEARING WILL
BE HELD TODAY COULD BECOME MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT. AND MR SHIRT WE
ARE RECEIVING SOME FEEDBACK.
WELL IT SAYS THE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE LINE TO PLEASE MUTE THEIR
PHONES OR COMPUTERS- AND
PROCEED. NINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN BERMAN. GOOD
MORNING MATURE THE MEMBERS
PURPOSE PLAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND THINK ABOUT. YOU NAY
APPRECIATE TODAY THAT'S NOT.
YOUR PERSONAL PROGRAMS AT THE
OTHER NO IT OVER THE BEAT UP
AND CIRCLED. BUT THEN THAT BUT
IF A PERSON. AND IF THE
GOVERNMENT WITH THE STEP THREE
MANDATE PROTECT THE WHERE RIGHT
ARE BUSINESS- PERSON PROGRAMS.
THE KAREN THE AUTHORITY TO VOTE
AND PROGRAM TAKE IMMEDIATE BUT
IT. THAT'S NOT CREDIT ASIAN
BILLS NOT. B. REGIONAL OR STATE
BOB WEBER PARK. AT A MEETING
TODAY. MAKE SURE PUBLIC NURSE
PROGRAMS OF BEAT UP UP WITH A
RABBIT ON RYE. I'VE BEEN
PROPERLY TAUGHT. 2% OF WITH
WRAP PUBLIC PROGRAM IN OUR X.
PASS RATES YEAR WAS EAT IT 7%
THERE THAT THE FLOOR. THERE
NURSING ARE PRIVATE AND THERE
AND BY. WITH ONLY SPEAKS POINT
8% FLORIDA'S PHONE AND NOW PUT
IT RIGHT I'M PAT RATES WERE
ABOUT NATIONAL WHEREAS I BE
PROGRAMS WITH BELOW. THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. IN THE
MEANTIME. STUDENTS ARE WITH IT
THAT IT IN OUR LYFT THERE. SIR
LET ME MAKE THIS A WICKS ARE
HAVING TO HERE YOU YOUR COULD
IS TERRIBLE. WELL LET'S YOU TRY
IT AGAIN IN YOU THINK OF WORK
IF NOT- I THINK ALL OF US WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR OR READ WHAT YOU
HAVE TO SAY SO I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT YOU IF THE CONNECTION
CANNOT BE IMPROVE THAT YOU
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN
WRITING. TO OUR COMMITTEE
COMMITTEES FOR REVIEW AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU SIR.
IS THIS CAN YOU HEAR ME AT THIS
POINT HI CAN I'M NOT SURE HOW
LONG YOU WILL STAY SO I DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU ARE IF YOU'RE
DRIVING OR DOING SOMETHING ELSE
BUT- IT WAS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE
TO PUT IT TOGETHER I DID CATCH
FLORIDA. SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
OKAY THANK YOU STARK AMERICAN-
LITTLE A LAND LINE SO IT'S
INTERESTING THAT- POPULAR BIT-
OKAY IT'S ALL CONTINUED
FLORIDA'S OWN ANALYSIS NOTATE-
PUBLIC PROGRAM PASS RATES. WERE
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
WHEREAS THE PRIVATE PROGRAMS
WERE WELL BELOW THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. IN THE MEANTIME MANY
STUDENTS ARE LEFT WITH
SIGNIFICANT DEBT. AND UNABLE TO
OBTAIN ARE IN LICENSE OR- SOME
CONTENT INCLUDING IN THE
BACKGROUND PAPER THAT JOIN THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT WOULD
BROADEN THE POOL OF NURSES
ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA. HOWEVER THE NLC HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS AND YET THERE'S
NO EVIDENCE HE HAS LED TO
GREATER NURSE MOBILITY OR
INCREASED LABOR SUPPLY. JOINING
THE COMPACT WOULD UNDERMINE
PUBLIC PROTECTION BY INHIBITING
CALIFORNIA'S ABILITY TO SET
STANDARDS THAT APPLY TO ALL
NURSES PRACTICING HERE. IT
WOULD ALSO RESTRICT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR UPWARD
MOBILITY- NURSES WHO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF CALIFORNIA'S L. B.
AND ARE AN OPTION FOR THE
MILITARY EXPERIENCE OPTION
WOULD BE INELIGIBLE FOR LICENSE
OR UNDER THE CONTACT. THANK
YOU. IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU HAVE
THAT IN WRITING SO PLEASE
SUBMIT IT TO OUR COMPLETE JOINT
COMMITTEES FOR REVIEW AND
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT. NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NEXT. NINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THINK WE NEED TO GO TO
THE NET MOVING UNTIL NINE
NINETY TO NINE NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS PRODUCTS AND GOLD
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAD A FEW
SPECIFIC COMMENTS BUT ALSO WANT
TO THANK THE STATE AUDITOR AND
OUR STAFF FOR THEIR THOROUGH
AND DILIGENT WORK. ADULTERESS
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
AND DETAILED QUESTIONS. ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY WE SUPPORT THE USE
OF RELEVANT REGIONAL DATA
CENTERS AROUND PRO BOWL. WE
ALSO WELCOME THE RECOMMENDATION
TO COOPERATE WITH NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION BODY AGENT- THE
CALIFORNIA NORTH IN. THE
ADEQUATE AND RELEVANT
EDUCATION. AND THEN LASTLY THE
IMPORTANCE OF SWISS COMPLAINTS
INVESTIGATION MY TO BE HONEST.
ABOUT THAT YEARS OF PROTRACTED
PROCESS THESE AFFECTING OUR
CITIZENS ABILITY TO RETURN OF
THE CROP I THINK. OF COURSE
WHEN APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL AND
BE PASSED BY. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS NEXT. NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KENDRA MAHLER AND I'M A
STUDENT INTERN ACT THE CENTER
FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO SCHOOL
OF LAW. CPI AUTHORITY SUBMITTED
A WRITTEN TESTIMONY BUT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT TWO KEY ISSUES-
FIRST WE RECOMMEND TO ADD TO
PUBLIC MEMBERS TO THE BOARD.
ANTILL MAN SECTION TWENTY SEVEN
OH EIGHT OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CODE TO PRECLUDE
THE BOARD EXECUTIVE OFFICER
FROM BECOMING A LICENSEE OF THE
BOARD ARE CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THAT PUBLIC. PROTECTION IS B.
R. AND- ON PRIORITY. I REDUCE
IN OUR LETTER THAT. PER THAT
LISTING CONTROL OVER THE BOARD
PREVENT. AMPLE OPPORTUNITY FOR
ANTI COMPETITIVE BEHAVIOR AND
IT EXPLODES ABOARD ITS MEMBERS
TO ANTITRUST LIABILITY. AND
CONTROL OVER THE SUPPLY OF
NURSES IN CALIFORNIA PRESENTS A
PARTICULAR RISK TO ANTI
COMPETITIVE ACTIVITY. AND THE
SCOPE CONTROLS NEED TO BE PUT
IN PLACE. SECOND EMPLOYER
SHOULD STAY. BURKE BE REQUIRED
TO REPORT DISAPPOINTED THAT TO
THE BOARD. WELL I THEIR
HEALTHCARE LICENSING BOARDS
MOST NOTABLY THAT MEDICAL BOARD
RECEIVE A HOST OF MANAGED
HEATED REPORT ABOUT THEIR
LICENSEES YEAR AND RECEIVED NO
SUCH SUPPORT. SIGNIFICANTLY IF
THE BOARD ADMITS THAT IT CAN
ONLY INVESTIGATE KNOWN
ALLEGATIONS OR VIOLATIONS AND
THAT THE LACK OF MANDATORY
REPORTING LEADS THE PUBLIC
AVERAGE. INDEED THE MEDICAL
BOARD'S ENFORCEMENT MONITOR
BROWN THE REPORTING OF ADVERSE
EVENTS PURSUANT TO SECTION
EIGHT OH FIVE TO BE THE SINGLE
HIGHEST SOURCE OF INFORMATION
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD. WITH
RESPECT TO DETECTION OF AN
ETHICAL AND DANGEROUS
CONDITIONS THE FACT THAT THE
BEER AND DID NOT RECEIVE THESE
REPORTS IS WHOLLY INCONSISTENT
WITH THE BOARD'S PARAMOUNT
PRIORITY TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
ESPECIALLY TRUE IN LIGHT OF THE
BOARD'S INEFFECTIVE OVERSIGHT
OVER DISCIPLINE SYSTEM. AND THE
CONCERNING INFORMATION WITH
RESPECT TO THE FALSIFICATION OF
RECORDS ABOUT INVESTIGATIONS-
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE THIS MORNING.
MATAHARI WAS RAIN DURING THE
BOARD'S BLACK CENTERRA BEALE
AND BEYOND TIME TO IMPLEMENT
THIS RECOMMENDATION TO ENSURE
PUBLIC PROTECTION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. NINE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- HELLO CENTER AND A
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
EVERYONE JOINING- MY NAME IS
MICHAEL GOODNESS I'M A NATIVE
CALIFORNIA FOR THIRTY YEARS I'M
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY FIANCE
TODAY. WHO WISHES TO REMAIN
ANONYMOUS OUT OF FEAR OF BEING
RETALIATED AGAINST BY THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSES. I SAY
THIS BECAUSE MY FIANCE IS AN
ACTIVE LICENSE PROBATIONARY
NURSE WHO CURRENTLY PRACTICES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE-
THAT WAS NOT MENTIONED HERE
TODAY THE DIFFICULTY WHAT THE
IMPORTANT PROGRAM AT THE BRD
FROM DEALING WITH THOSE
PRODUCTS FOR OVER A YEAR I CAN
STATE THAT MY FIANCE WORKS VERY
HARD TO BECOME A REGISTERED
NURSE. GOT A CRIMINAL RECORD-
OVER TEN YEARS AGO THAT SHE
WAS- OVER TEN YEARS AGO AND WAS
UNDER THE IMPRESSION- IT WOULD
NOT AFFECT YOUR DO THE BILL AB
TWO ONE THREE EIGHT. THAT WAS
PACKED IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY.
MY FIANCE GRADUATED IN MAY TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AND SHE
FOUGHT FOR OVER A YEAR TO GAIN
ACCESS TO OUR LICENSE AND WAS
GRANTED A PROBATIONARY LICENSE
IN JUNE TWENTY TWENTY. THE PART
THAT IT IS HEARTENING
POSSESSION PASSED ALL
BACKGROUND CHECKS BEGIN THE
CLINICAL WHAT'S UP FRONT WITH
THEIR NURSING PROGRAM- ABOUT
HER EX BUDGET RECORD. BUT STILL
FELL. THE BACKGROUND WHETHER IT.
A PARTY BUT OCCASIONALLY JOB.
FOR AND- MY FIANCE'S CASE WAS
FIGHTING FOR A RECORD OF OVER A
DECADE AGO- WELL LEADING UNDER
LICENSE SHE CONTACTED. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND WALDRON- RIVERSIDE
UNDER MELENDEZ AND-
PROBATIONARY MANAGER JOHN
KNOWLES AND EVEN THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR NYESOM. ALL TO NO
AVAIL EVEN EVENTUALLY SHE WAS
FORCED TO ACCEPT THREE YEARS
PROBATION AND AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE. FOR FAMILY SINCE THE
MUCH TIME HAD A LAPSE THAT SHE
NEEDED AN INCOME TO PROVIDE FOR
CHILDREN. ONE OF THE ISSUES WE
CAN SIMPLY RIGHT- CONTINUALLY
RUN INTO. IS THE STIPULATIONS
ONE THROUGH NINETEEN. WHICH
RECALL- REQUIRED. THE
PROBATIONERS TO DO MANY THINGS
AND JUMP THROUGH MANY HOOPS TO
STEAL THE PRACTICE. I SEE ON TO
WORKED AT HEMET GLOBAL MEDICAL
CENTER FOR FOUR YEARS HAD FORTY
EIGHT LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HAD NEVER.
HAD AN ISSUE AND SHE WORKED IN
THE PANDEMIC AND EVEN GOT
COLLUDED DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHILE PREGNANT. SHE FIGHTS VERY
HARD TO ADVOCATE FOR THE
PATIENT. LEFT BARELY.
FORTUNATELY NOW THAT THE
PANDEMIC DIED DOWN. SHE'S BEEN
LET GO FOR JOBS TO THE DUE TO
THE EMPLOYER NOT WANTED TO
FOLLOW PROBATIONARY TERMS
ANYMORE. BECAUSE SHE WAS FORCED
TO TEST DURING WORK WHILE
URGING KERR'S- WERE CLOSED
EARLY DUE TO THE PANDEMIC.
ANOTHER ISSUE THAT IS
CONCERNING IS THIS A NURSES
CAUGHT DIVERTING MEDICATIONS ON
THE JOB THE RECORD. IS NOT
PERMANENT I WILL FOLLOW UP HER
LIFE WHEN HER DIVERSIONARY
PROGRAM COMPLETE. A
PROBATIONARY MERIT AT THE
RECORDS THEY ON A LIGHTNING
FOREVER. EVEN THOUGH THE
COMMISSIONER AND ARTS WORKS SO
HARD TO COMPLETE ALL
STIPULATIONS INCOME OCCUPATION.
AS YOU MIGHT BE ABLE TO TELL.
THIS MAKES IT HARD FOR
PROBATIONERS TO GET A JOB. NOT
ONLY WHILE ON PROBATION BUT
AFTER ALSO. A. B. R. IN THE
CLAIMS TO BE FOR THE WORKING
PROBATIONARY NURSE MAKE IT
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
PROBATIONARY NURSE THE OTHER
HOLD ON THE JOB. I ASK THAT THE
PROBATIONARY PROCESS BE
REVIEWED AND WE CATCH UP. THE
DISCIPLINARY. PROCESS TO YOUR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. IT'S
HEARTENING THAT A NON WRECKER
OF OVER YEARS OF. AND STILL BE
HELD AGAINST. WHEN I EVEN IF A
CALL. IS THAT TRAIN MORE. BY
FIANCE OVER SEVEN DOLLARS A
MONTH THE KEEPER LICENSING
STANDING INCLUDING- SUPPORT
GROUPS. PROTESTING THANK ON
PHYSICAL EXAMINATION WHICH SHE
NOW STRUGGLES HEY NOW THAT IS
WHAT THEIR JOB. I'M ASKING AND
BEGGING YOU ALL PLEASE CONSIDER
A CHANGE AND IT'S NOT THAT AS I
SPEAK FOR MANY STATIONARY TODAY
WE'RE HAVING A PROBLEM. ALL
NURSES CAN. BECOME ALSO DRUG
TESTING THAT YEAR BEHAVIOR. BUT
HER SPECIFIC MONITOR. BY EIGHT
IS NEVER SEEN APPROVED HERE BUT
IT SHOULD BE OUR AND CITED A
LOT OF FEEDBACK- IN MY CARE LET
ME MAKE SURE I MEAN BECAUSE LET
ME MAKE A SUGGEST MYSELF AND
HEARD WHICH IS LIKE THE EIGHT
AND THE CHANGE. THAT THIS BE
ARE IN DESPERATELY NEED. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR LISTENING TO ME
AND I HOPE YOU ALSO BLESS THEM.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND
BY THE WAY IF YOU HAVE THAT IN
WRITING YOU CAN CLEAN IT UP TO
MAKE IT ANONYMOUS BUT THE
COMMITTEES JOINT COMMITTEES
WOULD APPRECIATE. SEATING THAT
IN WRITING SO WE CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT THE STATEMENTS THAT YOU
MADE AND- SEE IF THERE'S A WAY
TO- SOMETHING WE NEED TO ADJUST
DURING HIS SUNSET REVIEW
PROCESS SO LOOK FORWARD TO
RECEIVING THAT WRITING SIR.
NEXT. MONTEREY. NINE NINE NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AM I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
KNOW THAT THE EXECUTIVE. I FELT
COMFORTABLE COMMITTING FRAUD
BECAUSE THERE WAS AND STILL IS
A CULTURE OF CORRUPTION AND
UNETHICAL BEHAVIOR AT THE BOARD.
HELLO RENDON MELBY STATED THAT
THERE'S NEW MANAGEMENT THE
BOARD BUT THAT NEW MANAGEMENT
ONLY HERE BECAUSE OF NEPOTISM.
IF IT'S AN EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
THE BOARD YVONNE LETTER OPENLY
BOASTED THAT SHE WOULD BRING
HER OWN PEOPLE AND THEN
PROCEEDED TO AND SO IF SHE
COULD. THE RECENTLY HIRED
CAREER EXECUTIVE ASSIGNMENT OF
LICENSING THE CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS AND THE MANAGER OF
THE CALL CENTER- ALL THE IO'S
FORMER COLLEAGUE. OF ALL THE
APPLICANTS FOR THESE POSITIONS
THAT WERE QUALIFIED JEFF STONE
HAPPENS TO BE THE EIGHTY YEAR
OLD FORMER CO WORKERS. AND
FACEBOOK FRIENDS. MANAGEMENT
SAID THE TONE AND THEY HAVE
MADE IT TO PASS THAT ALONG TO
IS A ACCEPT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME NEXT.
MONTEREY- NINE EIGHTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOUTHANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DR MARIANNE VAN DAMME. I'M I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY. AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE VOICES OF THE
OTHER EIGHTEEN DIRECTORS OF
SCHOOL NURSING- I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS A COUPLE POINTS- ONE OF
THEM IS INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF STIMULATION ALLOWED. BY THE
B. R. AND NOW THERE WAS SOME
TALK TODAY ABOUT- I WAS HAPPY-
LONG. ABILITY TO HAVE CRITICAL
PLACES THAT IS FUNCTIONALLY NOT
TRUE- BECAUSE OTHER VARIABLES
ARE FOR GOT. SUCH BAD- THE
LEVEL OF EDUCATION THAT THE
STUDENTS NEEDS AND THEN THE
SPECIALTY THAT WE MUST SPELL SO
ALL OF THOSE ARE. ALL THE
BOTTLENECKS. YEAH INTO THE
THREE PARENTS. THAT THE SPOT
DATA STATES THAT THERE ARE- I
WOULD ALL. LIKE POINT OUT THAT
WOULD BE OF WE HAVE THIS
INCREASING- NUMBER OF. S. IN
THE LAST FIVE CAN YEARS- THAT
WE WERE ESPECIALLY BADLY HIT
THE PANDEMIC CASH INCLUDED A
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT DEGREES
OUR ABILITY. TO GO FORTH WITH
NURSING EDUCATION. I THAT HAS
HELPED US GREATLY- HOWEVER
GOING BACK 225% RATHER THAN THE
50% GRANTED BY AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT WILL NOT BE THE
ANSWER TO US BECAUSE WE NEED TO
SECURE A CLINICAL PLACEMENT
HOURS. AND THAT ISSUE IS NOT
GOING TO GO AWAY AFTER THE
PANDEMIC. SO WE ARE ASKING TO
PERMANENTLY INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF. NON DIRECT PATIENT HOURS
YEAH I QUALITY SIMULATION
EXPERIENCES. OTHER BOARD OF
REGISTERED NURSING IN THIS
COUNTRY- HOW. MANY MORE NON
DIRECT PATIENT CARE HOURS AGAIN
CALIFORNIA DOES ONLY 15% OF
THOSE BOARDS CAP THAT AT TWENTY
FIVE EDGE. OF CALIFORNIA DOES
PRESENTLY. STUDY SHOWS IBM THE
CSU BEYOND SPECULATION STARTED
TO TWENTY FOURTEEN SHOWS THAT
THERE IS NO DIFFERENCE IN THE
THE QUALITY OF THE NEW
GRADUATE. WHEN COMPARED 225%
250% WITH THE CONTROL GROUP IN
OTHER WORDS THE GRADUATES LEARN
JUST AS WELL AND SOME DATA
SHOWS THAT THEY COME OUT WITH
BETTER CRITICAL THINKING SKILLS
AND DECISION. MAKING SKILLS BUT
WE ARE ASKING PLEASED TO
DECREASE THE AMOUNT OF DIRECT
PATIENT CARE HOURS THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY. AND ALSO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT. OF QUALITY
IN THE NATION. THE OTHER POINT
ON TO MAKE IS OF ON GOING. ON
CONCURRENT J. OF SCARY AND
PRACTICE- PRESENT MAYBE WE HAVE.
OUR HANDS RATHER. BECAUSE MUST.
YOU DON'T TO OF THEY ARE REAL-
THAT'LL BE GIVEN AND THE CLINIC
LOOKS- WE HAVE TO DO IT
CONCURRENT WHILE OTHER- AREAS
OF HEALTHCARE DOES SUCH AS AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY. OUR ABLE TO
PURSUE THAT THE AND THEN GIVE
THE FACT CALIXTE. THAT
CERTAINLY GIVES US MORE
FLEXIBILITY AND ALSO WITH
STRATEGY THAT IS OFTEN BETTER
FOR THE STUDENTS BECAUSE THEY
HAVE MORE THAN JUST ONE WEEK OF
GEARING. BEFORE THEY ARE PLACED
IN A HOSPITAL THAT IS
UNPREDICTABLE AS TO WHAT THEY
COME UP TO. IT THAT IS- IT FOR
NOW I THINK YOU FOR CONSIDERING.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE COMMENTS
NEXT. NINE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MEMBERS SHAUNA SHANNON
AND I WORK AT THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING IN
RESPONSE TO ISSUE NUMBER FIVE
IN THE BACKGROUND PAPER PRIOR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
MISCONDUCT ALLEGATIONS IT WAS
PASSED WHAT WAS THE OUTCOME OF
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE
PRIOR EXECUTIVE OFFICER IN THE
BEER AND REPORTED THAT THE
INVESTIGATION CONTINUE TO
PROGRESS. AND ULTIMATELY
ALTHOUGH DISCUSSED IN A CLOSED
SESSION THERE IS NO FINDING OF
IMPROPRIETY AT THE BOARD MEMBER
OR STAFF LEVEL I HAVE A LETTER
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS HE- OFFICE THAT STATE.
THE PREPONDERANCE OF EVIDENCE
DEVELOPED DURING THE
INVESTIGATION THAT STAND SHE
ADDED THAT DOCTOR MORRIS
VIOLATED HIS ZERO TOLERANCE
PROVISION CONTAINED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION
POLICY THE BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING HAVE BEEN NOTIFIED OF
THIS FINDING. AND THE MATTER
WILL BE ADDRESSED THE MINISTRY
OF LATE HERE WE HAVE AGAIN THE
BOARD PROVIDING FALSE
INFORMATION TO AN OVERSIGHT
ENTITY. AND RECORD ALSO A FLAP
IN THE FACE TO THE WOMEN
WORKING AT THE BOARD WHO COULD
JACKETS HARASSMENT AND FELT
UNSAFE IT AND OBJECTIFIES. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO REPORT THAT ONE OF
THE MANAGERS CARLY TREVINO
INVOLVING HEARING ALLEN LEADING
FALSIFIED DATA TO THE STATE
AUDITOR WAS PROMOTED FROM
SUPERVISING INVESTIGATOR WANTS
TO SUPERVISING SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR Q. HE NOW OVERSEES
THE BOARD. PROGRAM SHE CLAIMED
THAT SHE ONLY PARTICIPATED
BECAUSE HE WAS DIRECTED BUT AT
THAT LEVEL OF MANAGEMENT HE
SHOULD HAVE REFUSED OR RECORDED
THE LEGAL DIRECTIVES BUT CHOSE
NOT TO DO YOU FELT IT WAS A
WHISTLEBLOWER WHO PRACTICE
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PUBLIC ATTENTION. AS AN
EMPLOYEE I'M TELLING YOU THAT
THERE IS A CULTURE OF
CORRUPTION AND FRAUD AT OR IN
MANAGEMENT IN EXECUTIVE LEVEL
STAFF FEEL COMFORTABLE IN DOING
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES BECAUSE THAT
IS THE CULTURE THAT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED HERE THANK YOU.
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS
NEXT PLEASE. NINE ONE HUNDRED
AND NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR AND MEMBER. BY NAME CONNOR
SO- THE CAL SAYS OF HEALTH BUT
SO. AFTER PORTS THE- THAT WE
ARE CAN WORK WELL. TIMELINE
ADJUSTMENTS WILL JUSTICE BE
BETTER PROVIDE INDIVIDUALS WITH
THE ABILITY TO PRACTICE NURSING
IN CALIFORNIA FORTUNE MOVED TO
ANOTHER STATE AND CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE NURSING. THAT AND
URGES THE B. R. AND TO ADOPT
VINSOLUTIONS AND ENTER THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT
MEMBERSHIP IN THE NLC ALLOWS
ARE ENCOURAGED HEARD IN ONE OF
THIRTY FOUR OTHER MEMBER STATES
TO PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA. IT
ALLOWS CALIFORNIA ORANGE TO
PRACTICE. IN OTHER MEMBER
STATES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT. NINE ONE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI I AM AN EMPLOYEE AT THE
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AND
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE MY NAME
BECAUSE IN THE PAST I'VE BEEN
RETALIATED AGAINST FOR SPEAKING
UP THAT BOARD MEETING. BOARD
MEMBER THE BOARD MEMBER WANTED
TO FIND OUT WHO I WAS TO
PROHIBIT YOU FROM ATTACHMENT AT
THE B. R. AND HE WANTED TO PUT
AN EMAIL I SENT TO ALL THE
BOARD MEMBERS VOICING MY
CONCERNS OVER HIRING PRACTICES
IN MY FILE AT THE DISCIPLINARY.
ALSO THE CURRENT. CONSISTENTLY
YVONNE MENARD HAS PARTICIPATED
IN NEPOTISM. CULTURE BY
BRINGING IN MULTIPLE FORMER
COURT CO WORKERS. FROM OTHER
PLACES OF EMPLOYMENT TO PUT
THEM INTO TOP MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS AT THE B. R. M.
RIFLED THROUGH OUR DESK WHEN WE
HAVE GONE HOME FOR THE DAY.
ALSO THERE IS A CULTURE OF
APATHY EVIDENCED BY BOARD
MEMBERS WALKING OUT ON
EMPLOYEES WHO WERE SPEAKING TO
THE PUBLIC ABOUT THE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CULTURE AT THE BOARD
OF REGISTERED NURSING. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. FOR THOSE
COMMENTS. NEXT. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND BOARD MEMBERS THEY'RE
THE CAT ON BEHALF OF THE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA COMMENTING ON ISSUE
ELEVEN TWELVE THE BACKGROUND
PAPER. ARE HERE HE SUPPORT
SOLUTIONS LIKE THE NURSE
LICENSURE COMPACT WHICH CAN
HELP ADDRESS THE CHRONIC
NURSING SHORTAGES IN A LITTLE
COUNTY EXPANDING THE POOL OF
ELIGIBLE NURSES CRITICAL TO
BUILDING HEALTHCARE CAPACITY
ESPECIALLY DURING HE NINETEEN.
WILL COMMUNITIES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO LOSE ALL BY NURSES
THAT THERE AREN'T POPULATION
RETIRES YOU ARE IN EDUCATION
PROGRAMS IN THOSE REGIONS THE
NURSES ARE DIFFICULT FOR A
STATE WILL COMMUNITIES WITH
HIGH RATES OF POVERTY AND THE
GREATEST DIFFICULTY ATTRACTING
AND RETAINING NURSES. LIVING
FOR THE NURSING RECIPROCITY
PROGRAM LIKE THE AND I'LL SEE
WILL HELP A LITTLE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS SO THEY CAN FEES WITH
PENSION TRAVEL NURSES WHAT
PERMANENT POSITIONS ARE FILLED
ENSURING THERE'S NO LACK OF
CARE FOR PATIENTS INCLUDING ARE
HERE C. OR IS IT BE OUR END TO
ADOPT AND I'LL BE BUT YOU CAN
BUY THAT MUCH NEEDED TOOL TO
HELP HEALTHCARE NEEDS AND WILL
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT PLEASE. WINDS ONE YOUR
LINE IS A- PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON MUTE. HELLO
YOUR HONOR YES GOOD MORNING
CARE ROCK CARILLO AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
KELLY NAY DOUGLAS AND I AM
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST REGIONAL
LIAISON FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE DEFENSE STATE LIAISON
OFFICE. WE WORK OUR OFFICE
WORKS WITH STATE POLICYMAKERS
THAT WAS ON TOP QUALITY OF LIFE
ISSUES FACING MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILY. I
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
ON ISSUE NUMBER ONE I'M SORRY
ISSUE NUMBER ELEVEN AND IT.
BACKGROUND PAPER PARTICULARLY.
REGARDING LICENSE PLATE THEY
CHECKED THE PROPERTY-
ADDRESSING LIFE INSURANCE
PROPERTY AND PORTABILITY ISSUES
FOR THE THOUSANDS OF OUR
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS HAS
BEEN A PRIORITY FOR THE
DEPARTMENT FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
MILITARY SPOUSES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED BY
THE PACIFIC LIFE MAJOR
EQUIPMENT THAT CAN CAUSE DELAYS
AND GAPS IN EMPLOYMENT. I
NOTING NOTABLE IS THAT THE
ANNUAL COST STATEMENT
RELOCATION RATE IS TEN TIMES
HIGHER THE MILITARY FASTER THAN
THEIR CIVILIAN COUNTERPARTS AS
THEY MOVE WITH THEIR MILITARY.
MEMBERS SOUTH EVERY FOUR YEARS.
SH CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF NOT GREAT IN THE
NATION AT NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND MILITARY THOUSANDS IN
CALIFORNIA. SIXTY ONE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SO THERE I COULD
BE THERE WITH MEMBERS- DOT
CONSIDERED CONTACT BUDGET THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT THE
LONG TERM HE TOLD HE ENTERED
THE PROVIDING RECIPROCITY AND
THE ABILITY PER MILITARY
THOUGHT THE TO GET TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT DELAY.
NATIONAL COUNCIL OF STATE BOARD
NURSING PROMOTE THE USE OF THE
NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT- FOR
THE FOLLOWING REASON THE END
ALL BE WOULD ALLOW QUALIFIED
ADDED THE NURSES RESPOND TO
CRISES AND CALIFORNIA GROWING
DEMAND- IT WOULD FIX THE B. R.
AND PROBLEMATIC INDICTMENT
PROCESS THAT HAVE BEEN TO-
DEFECT TODAY INCLUDING DELAYS
AND FINGERPRINT PROCESSING
WHICH UP TO ADDRESS THE ISSUES
NUMBER. NINE TEN AND TWELVE IN
THE REPORT. I AN AUDITOR REPORT.
AND CALIFORNIA'S WORK EXPAND
TELE OPPORTUNE THANK EMPLOYMENT
CREDIBILITY FOR NURSES IN
NURSING STUDENTS WHICH ISSUE
NUMBER TWELVE AND IT WOULD
INCREASE THE PRICE FOR RURAL
AND UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
WHICH ARE OFTEN COLOCATED WITH
MILITARY INSTALLATION WHICH IS
ISSUED NUMBER TWENTY ONE
REGIONAL. SHORTAGES SHINGLING.
ENOUGH FACILITY GREATER CAREER
THE DATA TELEGRAPH MILITARY
NURSES. INCREASING THEIR FAMILY
FINANCE SECURE AND OVERALL
RESILIENCE BY ALLOWING THEM TO
WORK ON THEIR HOME LIFE AND AS
SOON AS THEY ARE ASSIGNED TO
CALIFORNIA WITH THE ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY SOUTH. AND
ADDITIONALLY WOULD ALLOW
MILITARY THOUSAND TO OUR
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA AND
TRANSFERRED OUT OF THE STATE
CONTINUE WORKING WITHOUT DELAY
IN OTHER CONTACT EIGHT. THIRTY
FOUR STATES AND ONE TERRITORY
ARE NOW MEMBERS OF THE L. B.
AND IF I THINK THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF MILITARY THOUGHT THIS
REPRESENTING 50% OF ALL ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY THOUSAND IN THE
U. S. CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY
STATE. THAT HAVE NOT JOINED THE
CONTACT. THE END OF THE OF THE
CAR. APPROACH TO IT ENSURING
THAT CAN PROTECT CONSUMERS TAKE
THE WILD SOHIT INTO A LIKE. OF
THE PROPERTY PUTTING. MOBILE
PROFESSIONAL POPULOUS. IS
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT. AND NOT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE DOT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE STATE OF THE
HIGHER. IN THE POSITIVE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT THAT THE
MILITARY COMMUNITY PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA. WITH THAT I THINK.
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. THANKS FOR
THE COMMENTS NEXT PLEASE. IN
OUR LAST COMMENT COMES FROM
MIND ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR ONE ONE TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MERRY WITH
MEN AND I AM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES OF NURSING. FIRST I
WANT TO THANK- SENATOR ROB AND
LOW AS WELL AS ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONAL. PROFESSION
COMMITTEE FOR. THIS YEAR GREAT
ATTENTION TO DETAIL DURING THIS
HEARING SO- WE WANT TO KNOW HOW
MUCH YOU'RE APPRECIATED BUT MY
COMMENT TODAY REALLY- GOES BACK
TO A COMMENT MADE- DURING. THE
PRESENTATION BY THE BEER AND-
EXECUTIVE OFFICER ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS. WHO
GRADUATED DURING COLD BUT- SHE-
AND IT'S GRAY TO SEE THAT THE
NUMBERS ARE THERE BUT I THANK
THE SCHOOL DIFFERENT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THAT WAS REPORTED IN
THAT COMMENT- SO- AT TIMES-
NURSING DIRECTORS ABOUT THE
THIRD BEER AND WAS NOT HELPFUL
AND TIME CONSTRUCTIONISM AND
FOR MAKING SURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS PREFER AFTER THE
NURSING PROGRAM ON TIME- SO WE
ARE AWARE THAT OTHER STATES-
THEIR BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING WORK WITH SCHOOLS TO
PROVIDE A BETTER LEVEL OF
FLEXIBILITY ACCORDING STUDENTS
TO MOVE AHEAD. IN THE PIPELINE
WELL STILL BE BECOMING GREAT
REGISTERED NURSES AND MEETING
LEARNING OBJECTIVES- SO WE DID
HEAR THAT FROM OTHER STATES AND
CALIFORNIA WE DIDN'T FEEL THE
SAME- SO INITIALLY THE BEER AND
LISTED ON MAINTAINING A 75%
DIRECT HERE MANDATE AND- WHY WE
THOUGHT OTHER. HAVE A MUCH MORE.
IN REGARDS THE MAGIC CARE ACT.
WHEN WAIVER CAME OF THE OFFICE
SCHOOLS ARE NURSING HAD PROVIDE.
CARE TO. BUT THEY WERE DECLINE
FROM. AND JUST ABOUT HOLD BROAD
OF THE PAPER WORK AND- CONTACT
FROM ABOUT AGENCIES. PROVIDED
ADDITIONAL BURDEN OF FOURTEENTH
AND DIRECTORS DURING THAT TIME
WHEN THEY WERE JUST WORKING
ABOVE AND BEYOND TO DEAL ITH
STUDENTS. AS TO MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE GETTING CLINICAL
OPPORTUNITIES AS NEEDED. I'M
ALSO THE BOARD GRANT- OPPOSED
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY EIGHT. AND
AT TIMES CONTINUE TO DISCOUNT
THE VALUE OF STIMULATION SO- I
DO WANT TO MENTION THAT DURING-
IN THE ANTI AMERICAN ALL OF THE
SCHOOLS HAVE THE LIGHTS THE
LIFESPAN THANK YOU IT STILL
EXPAND AND THE BAN HAS GIVEN US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
STIMULATE ON OUR PROGRAMS- SO-
YOU KNOW WE WOULD LIKE TO.
CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
STIMULATION AT 50% OF CLINICAL
TIME I THANK YOU FOR THIS BUT
MADETHIS COMMENT AND- THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM FOR YOUR COMMENTS-
MODERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
CHECK THE LINE. ONCE AGAIN TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEARD.
FROM ALL MEMBER OF THE- WE DO
ONE MORE COMMENT THAT HAS CUTER
NINE ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR. NINE
ONE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS WANDA MORRIS I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF NURSING AT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
REPRESENT NINETY TWO-
CALIFORNIA ORGANIZATIONS
DIFFICULT INTEGRATING OUR
STUDENTS AND DIRECTORS WHICH
EDUCATE 90% OF THE NURSING
EDUCATION WORKFORCE. THANK YOU.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
MODERNIZING YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS MODERATE
I THINK THE NEED TO BE
EXCHANGING AN EDUCATIONAL
MENTORING. SUCH AS BANYAN. THE
U. THE- BRADENTON FOR TWENTY TO
BE PERCENT WHICH IS IN LINE. WE
REVERSE OR. TWO RESEARCH
TRAINING EDUCATION OUTCOME
SIMULATION BASED IN THEY HIDE
TECH WAY UP FRONT. HE'LL TRAIN
IN A EFFECTIVE MANNER. I
COMMITTEE ON MA'AM IT'S- A FOR
STUDENTS TO AT POWER THEY'RE
ARE INTO PRACTICE. THEY ARE
MAKING AND WHAT THEN LATER REAL
COULD. LEARNING ANY IN MANAGE
AND PROVIDING FINANCIAL HEALTH
ON EXPERIENCE THAT INTERSTATE.
CORRECT TO OUR- POPULARLY OR
TO. THANK YOU FOR A LONG. TIME
BEFORE YOU. BEFORE YOU LEAVE
THE LINE WE HAD A AMOUNT OF INR
FOR DURING PRESENT SO I THINK
WE CAUGHT MOST OF IT BUT IF YOU
WOULD BE SO KIND AS TO SEND US
THOSE YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS
DIRECTED TO BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
IN THE SENATE. COMMITTEES WE
WOULD LIKE TO CONSIDER THEM AS
PART OF THIS OVERSIGHT SUNSET
REVIEW PROCESS. OKAY WILL DO
SEND THE SAME WAY WILL WE- YOU.
KNOW ABOUT MEXICO EARLY YES
THAT'S CORRECT TO THE STAFF OF
BOTH FOOD TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN THE- SENATE
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENT OKAY THANK. GALLAGHER
IS THAT IT. WE HAVE TWO MORE
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PROCEED. MY NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREETINGS MY NAME IS KENYA
WILLIAMS DEPUTY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE NATIONAL
STUDENT NURSES ASSOCIATION. THE
NATIONAL NURSES ASSOCIATION
HAVE COMMITTED A WRITTEN REPORT
ISSUE A LETTER. N. AS IS A
ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIA INTRIGUED
TO THE NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT
WITH THIRTY FOUR PARTICIPATING
STATE THAT FAR IN THIRTEEN
STATES HIM BEING LEGISLATION
THE NLC GRANT OVER TWO MILLION
NURSES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND TO CRISIS. AND DEMAND
BY PROVIDING CARE ACROSS STATE
LINES. THE END OF THE WORLD
EIGHT EIGHT HIGH NURSES QUICKLY.
AND PROVIDE ROOM TO THEIR STATE
INPATIENT AND CAL. AND YOU
TELEHEALTH TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO CARE IN UNDERSERVED
POPULATION WHAT THE STATE.
TAKING A CRITICAL STEP ADDRESS
CAL NURSING SURE. WILL IN I
FOR. FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES.
WHILE THIS MAY SEEM LIKE A
RADICALLY NEW SYSTEM BUT ENOUGH
THE HAVE BEEN OPERATING SAFELY
WITH NURSES PARTICIPATING
ACROSS STATE LINES. EIGHTEEN
YEARS THE SAME ALL THE SAME
STRICT STANDARDS TO GET FROM
THINGS LYFT FUTURE RE STILL IN
PLACE. BOB GRAHAM BEEN TO THE
BASED ON ISSUE AND IT FOR MORE
THAN. AND THE BENEFITS ARE TO
ME TO THE- IN SHORT
CALIFORNIANS INTRIGUED ME TO
THE NURSE LICENSURE COMPACT
LUCRECE THE NURSING WORKFORCE
IN CALIFORNIA WHILE ADDRESSING
THE NURSE SHORTAGE. INCREASED
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY BENEFIT
MILITARY FALCON IN RELOCATING
INCREASED ACCESS TO TELEHEALTH
AND CAREFUL MOVEMENT
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES IN THE-
SOUTH OF BOTH THE STATE'S
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
PROVIDE DIRE RELEASED. FOR OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF THE MONEY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT. MY ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS A CLICK GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
TERRY BOTH I'M CHAIR OF NEW AND
CAL STATE BAND BERMAN. CAN WE
GO IN DIFFERENT OF BACKING
APPROVE AND HIRING BY THE BE
OUR N. I BELIEVE THAT IS UNLESS.
OVER. BACK THE DIRECTOR OF WHO
IS A BY THE L. A. TWO AND NO
CALL. AND THE UNIVERSE I WAS.
FOR DETERMINING. WHETHER AN
INDIVIDUAL THE NECESSARY. SUCH
AS OF NOW. ACADEMIC TRANSCRIPT
REFERENCES LONDON BACKGROUND
CHECKS. IT IS ALL ON EXPECT. OF
THE ACCREDITING BODIES HE HE
AND HE DATA NURSING LEADERSHIP
CONGRESS DIDN'T HIRING AND
EVALUATION OF THE FACULTY. THE
B. O. N. OVER IS DUPLICATED IN
TRYING TO. IT IS A THE NEW
PROBLEM WHEN THERE IS AN ISSUE
OF A SHORTAGE OF FACULTY WHEN
THERE'S AN EMERGENCY NEED SUCH
AS A PANDEMIC OR OTHER ISSUES
SUCH AS AN INDIVIDUAL ONLY. ONE
OF FACULTY MEMBER MUST BE
REPLACED IF THE DEPARTMENT OF
NURSING AND LEADERSHIP AND THE
ACT OF NOT HAVING THAT ABILITY
IT COULD LEAD TO A STUDENT NOT
HAVING A FACULTY MEMBER WHICH
WOULD FURTHER ENHANCE THEIR
LEARNING AND PROGRESSION. THANK.
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE
MODERATOR THAT CAN THE END OF.
QUEUED UP ON THE TELE LINE. WE
HAVE ONE LAST COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE OKAY PLEASE PROCEED. NINE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY SHOULD SAY
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING COMMON. MY NAME IS DR
PHIL GREINER AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE SCHOOL OF
NURSING AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY. I WOULD LIKE TO
COLLECT A COMMENT MADE BY MR
CHILDREN FROM THE STATE AUDITOR-
ALL BACCALAUREATE. NURSING
PROGRAMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE NATIONALLY
ACCREDITED. PROGRAMS THAT ARE
NOT ACCREDITED ARE THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE. DEGREE ARE AND IS
NOT FOLLOWING NATIONAL
GUIDELINES. MOST STATES REQUIRE
THAT ALL SCHOOLS OF NURSING BE
NATIONALLY ACCREDITED AND MOST
OF US BUILT THAT INTO OUR
BUDGET AT THE EITHER THE SCHOOL
OR COLLEGE OR THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
MEETING QUALITY STANDARDS OVER
AND ABOVE WHAT THE DR AND
REQUIRES. SO HE WILL HI WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE B. R. AND
REQUIRE NATIONAL ACCREDITATION.
FOR STATE APPROVAL. THANK YOU
FOR LONG WITH THAT. WE WERE
ASKING HER SCHOOLS OF NURSING
COULD PROVIDE INFORMATION TO
THE B. R. AND TO MEET THE STATE
ORDERS REQUIREMENT. THAT
INFORMATION IS INACCURATE. IT
WAS COLLECTED FROM MULTIPLE
SCHOOLS AND TO B. R. AND IN THE
INTENT IS TO HAVE THAT
COLLECTED ONE. NOT EVERY YEAR.
SO THE INFORMATION THAT THE
AUDITOR REQUESTED FOR MAKING
DECISIONS ABOUT CLINICAL
PLACEMENTS. WILL CONTINUE TO BE
AN ACCURATE AND WILL NOT ENABLE
THE B. R. AND TO MAKE DECISIONS
ACCERN I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME AND HAVE A GREAT DAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OF YOUR
COMMENTS- WE WILL CONCLUDE THE
THAT WILL BE THE CONCLUSION OF
OUR PUBLIC. TESTIMONY TODAY-
CHAIR LOW ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
OSTROFF- AS YOU CONCLUDED IT'S
A ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE WELCOME
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
HAVE. MEETING FULL AND
THOUGHTFUL DIALOGUE ON THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT HAVE
BEEN BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION
FROM THEIR STATE AUDITOR AS
WELL AS THE ARDUOUS WORK OF THE
SENATE BNP COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE ASSEMBLY BMP COMMITTEE. I
COMMEND YOU CHAIR ROSS FOR
HELPING TO FACILITATE AND
DIVING DEEP INTO THESE ISSUES I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT WE HEARD AND TOOK TO HEART
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
SPECIFICALLY FROM THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO CALLED IN. IT
TAKES COURAGE SPECIFICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO THE WHISTLE BLOWER
COMPLAINTS AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AND WE TAKE YOU WARTS VERY
SERIOUSLY AND WILL BE SURE TO
LOOK INTO THOSE FOR THOSE WHO
WERE NOT ABLE TO. GET AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN PLEASED
TO SUBMIT IN WRITING YOUR
TESTIMONY TO BOTH COMMITTEES
AND WILL BE SURE TO ADDRESS
THEM AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND
WELCOMED THE CONTINUED
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CHIRLA AND THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING THANKS TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEES AND BOARD
REPRESENTATIVES FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING ALSO THANK SAYS.
CARILLO INDICATED TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC FOR VERY COMPELLING-
COMMENTS AND FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO PROVIDE THOSE AS
CARILLO INDICATED IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFYBE THE
TELECONFERENCE OF HIS TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS. OF STATEMENTS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE FOR THE
ASSEMBLY BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE OR BOTH
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL. HEARING RECORD SIN
THAT WE CONSIDER IT DURING THE
SUNSET REVIEW PROCESS THANK YOU
AND WE DO APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. WE HAVE
CONCLUDED AGENDA THIS JOINT
SUNSET REVIEW OVERSIGHT HEARING
IS ADJOURNED.